OKAY GOOD MORNING WILL START
TODAY'S BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE-
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
RIGHT TO ON EDUCATION FINANCE
TODAY IS THE HIGHER EDUCATION
PORTION FOR FINANCIAL AID
RELATE TO THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION- IN CERTAINLY ALWAYS
AN IMPORTANT TOPIC BUT DURING
CODE WE NOW EVEN MORE SO THAT
TODAY WILL BE DISCUSSING
FINANCIAL AID ISSUES OVERALL.
WE KNOW GIVING THEM THE
CHALLENGES DURING COVERT
NINETEEN IS A VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC FOR STUDENTS THAT'S
ALWAYS IT WAS AN IMPORTANT
TOPIC BEFORE BECAUSE OF IT EVEN
MORE SO NOW. THE SURVEY BY CITY
COMMISSION FOUND THAT DURING
THE PANDEMIC OVER 70% OF
STUDENTS REPORTED LOSING INCOME
AND ABOUT HALF HAVE THEIR
LIVING SITUATIONS CHANGE. EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC HALF OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS IN
AT LEAST ONE THIRD OF CSU AND
UC STUDENTS FOR PRE REPORTED
FOOD INSECURITY- TODAY WE'LL
DISCUSS SOME OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS AND HEAR ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE STATE TO
GIVE MORE MONEY FOR COLLEGE
STUDENTS. INTO THE CALFRESH
PROGRAM ALSO EFFORTS TO REFORM
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS TO SERVE
MORE STUDENTS AND ALSO A SERVE
THEM WITH GREATER SUPPORT NOT
JUST TUITION LOOKING UP THAT
THE FULL COST OF. COLLEGE BOOKS
HOUSING- TRANSPORTATION FOOD
AND SO FORTH GOD WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FINANCIALLY
PROPOSALS- THEY ARE SMALL
PROPOSALS THAT WILL HELP SOME
STUDENTS. BUT WE WANT TO REALLY
FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE AND HOPE
THE GOVERNMENT AND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WILL HELP US THINK
BIGGER WE RELATE TO CAL GRANT
REFORM WE KNOW THAT CAL GRANT
LEAVES TOO MANY STUDENTS OUT
AND WE KNOW IT'S TOO
COMPLICATED. AND OUR COLLECTIVE
STATE INSTITUTIONAL AIDS
PROGRAMS DON'T ADDRESS STUDENTS
REAL COSTS AND AGAIN WE HOPE
THAT- THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
WILL WORK WITH WITH ME AND MR
MEDINA WHO'S TAKING A LEAD AS
THE CHAIR OF THE HIGHER ED
COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT THIS ISSUE
TO REALLY AFFECTS FINANCIAL
AID- ONE NOTE OF COURSE WERE
VERY- HOP TO MISS. ABOUT THE IN.
PER TO RE. SCHOOLS TO HAVE
STUDENTS FILL OUT THE FASTER.
OR DREAM ACT- WE TALKED ABOUT
THE LAST WEEK DURING A HEARING
IS WELCOME GETS VERY PROMISING-
SO WITH THAT WILL BEGIN TODAY'S
HEARING JUST REMINDER THIS IS
A- AT- KOBE NINETEEN STYLE
HEARING. WE HAVE A PHYSICALLY
DISTANCE POLICY IN TODAY'S
HEARING ROOM. AND WE WILL HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENTS. FOR OUR DIAL
IN NUMBER WE WILL GET TO THAT-
LATER IN THE HEARING- BUT WITH
THAT- TODAY'S INFORMATIONAL
THERE'S NO VOTE SO NO NOT
TAKING ROLE. WE'LL START BY
HAVING. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN THE L. A. L. IN THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION- BEGAN
ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE. WHO. CAN
YOU START OVER AND- BECAUSE
THEY ARE YOU CAN'T HEAR YOU.
WHAT'S THE SPEAK LOUDER WHAT
THE STATE BUDGET. COMING
THROUGH BOTH PASSWORD
CALIFORNIA ABOUT. EIGHT YOUR
THAT YOU TURN OFF YOUR IN TURN
ON THE COULD RESET. I STILL
CAN'T HEAR YOU AND YOUR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GABRIELLE ALL OF THE POWER.
YEAH OKAY GOOD MORNING CHEN
MEMBERS I'VE GOT LIKE CABIN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROJECTS
AT APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS WILL RECEIVE NEARLY
TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION IN LATE
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. KAGUM THE STATE'S LARGEST
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM
IS EXPECTED TO SERVE ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWELVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS. AND PROVIDE MORE THAN
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION EIGHT.
THIS TOTALS INCLUDED REVISED
COCHRAN ESTIMATES FOR NUMBER OF
NEW AND RENEWABLE STUDENTS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. IN ADDITION- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
FIFTY EIGHT POINT TWO MILLION
I'M GOING GENERAL FUND THE REST
OF COCHRAN'S ELIGIBILITY FOR
STUDENTS IMPACTED BY A CHANGE
IN THE REGION STATUS. IT TO THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
WHOOTHERWISE WOULD HAVE LOST
THEIR COGNATE. HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY Q. L. A. O.
GOOD MORNING CAN MEMBERS THE
THINKING THAT LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. H. THREE
PICKERING AGENDA PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL CONTACTS AND ALSO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST
DESCRIBED TO RESTORE
ELIGIBILITY FOR STUDENTS WHO
LACK YOU WANT STATE DUE TO A
CHANGE IN THEIR LIVING
ARRANGEMENTS. WELCOME BACK AND
BRIEFLY THIS IS A NEW ISSUE
THIS YEAR. IN ORDER TO QUALIFY
FOR CALTRANS STUDENTS NEED TO
DEMONSTRATE A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
FINANCIAL NEED AND- FINANCIAL
NEED IS BASED IN PART ON THE
COST OF ATTENDANCE. IN GENERAL
CAMPUS ASSUME THAT STUDENTS
WERE LIVING AT HOME WITH FAMILY
HAVE LOWER COSTS OF ATTENDANCE
INSTANCE WERE LIVING ON CAMPUS.
BECAUSE CAMPUS AT THIS YEAR
OFFERING LARGELY REMOTELY DUE
TO THE PANDEMIC. MANY STUDENTS
WHO WOULD OTHERWISE LIVED ON
CAMPUS ARE INSTEAD LIVING AT
HOME. AS A RESULT SOME OF THE
STUDENTS LOST THEIR COGNITIVE
ABILITY. ALSO ADDRESSES THIS
UNINTENDED. WE THINK IT'S
REASONABLE TO ALLOW STUDENTS TO
MOVE HOME TO THE PANDEMIC TO
RECEIVE THE TUITION COVERAGE
THEY WOULD HAVE RECEIVED HAD
THE OTHERWISE LOOKED ON CAMPUS.
AND AS THE STUDENTS ARE
IMPACTED IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
ACTION IS WARRANTED TO RESTORE
THEIR TUITION COVERAGE AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE. WANT TO KNOW WHAT
THIS PROPOSAL IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FUNDING
LEVEL IS BASED ON FOOTBALL
ESTIMATES FROM THE SEGMENTS
PARTICULARLY UC AND CSU. THANKS
BEEN REVISED DOWNWARD
SIGNIFICANTLY SO THE COST COULD
BE SOMEWHAT LOWER THAN
PROPOSED. FOR THAT REASON WE
RECOMMEND ADOPTING THIS
PROPOSAL AS EARLY ACTION ITEM.
REVISITING THE FUNDING LEVEL IN
THE NEAR VISION ONE UPDATED
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE ON
COMPACT CASE AND WEBER. THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU SENATE
COMMISSION. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE CHECK FROM
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WHERE I SERVICE
RECORDS GOVERNMENT AND EXTERNAL
RELATIONS I'M ALL START MY
COMMENTS THIS MORNING ON BEHALF
OF THIS YOU NEED COMMISSION BY
THANKING GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND
HIS STAFF FOR THEIR SUPPORT OF
OUR WORK AND COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDING STUDENTS AFFORDABLE
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION
THAT'S REFLECTED IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET DESPITE THE
CHALLENGES FACING THE STATE ON
SO MANY FRONTS THE GOVERNOR'S
DEMONSTRATED IN THIS BUDGET THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT FINANCIAL
AID AND OUR WORK TO KEEP
COLLEGE AFFORDABLE INVITED THIS
PANDEMIC IS MORE IMPORTANT NOW
THAN EVER. ON THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL ON CAL GRANT A
RESTORATION WE APPRECIATE THE-
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
ACTION I WOULD POTENTIALLY BE
STUDENTS ARE NOT FURTHER
IMPACTED BY CODE NINETEEN THE
COMMISSION'S REMAINED IN
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR STATE
PARTNERS REGARDING THIS AND
OTHER ISSUES CREATED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND WE WOULD LOOK
FORWARD T WORKING WITH THEM TO
ENSURE THAT SHOULD THIS WILL BE
PROVIDED TO STUDENTS WE
COLLABORATE TO RESTORE THE
IMPACTED STUDENTS FINANCIAL AID
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. AS WITH
THE NOTED BY- LA YELLOW THERE
HAS BEEN SOME CHANGE TO THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS ESTIMATED TO
BE IMPACTED BY THIS ISSUE OUR
CAMPUS PARTNERS AND SEGMENT
PARTNERS WOULD BE IN A BETTER
POSITION TO PROVIDE THOSE
ESTIMATES THEY INITIATE THE
PROCESS FOR CHANGING STUDENT
EXPENSE BUDGETS AND UPDATING
STUDENT INFORMATION PROVIDED ON
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATIONS
BEFORE THE COMMISSION
EVENTUALLY RECEIVE THOSE
UPDATES AND WHAT'S CALLED OUR
GRANT RECORD CHANGE FORM
PROCESS- SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE SEGMENTS AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO ENSURE
THAT THERE ARE- ACCURATE AND
TIMELY ESTIMATES ON THE NUMBER
OF IMPACTED STUDENTS AND- COSTS
ASSOCIATED. OKAY THANK AND THIS
IS AND I AN ITEM. THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING TO TAKE ACTION NOT
TODAY BUT THE NEAR FUTURE AND
EARLY ACTION ITEM. RELATED TO
CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY FOR NO
ACTION TODAY DO WE AND I DO
THINK THIS MAKES SENSE AS THE
L. A. UNNOTICED. SO HOPEFULLY
WE'LL ADDRESSES IN YOUR FUTURE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MR
MEDINA. YEAH I HEARD ALL THE
PRESENTERS SAY THAT ALL WE HAVE
IS ESTIMATES. ON HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE IMPACTED SO. MY
QUESTION PERHAPS TO ALL. OUR
WHAT IS THE DATA TRACKING
METHODS THAT ARE USED BY UC
CSU. AND C. SACK. TO DETERMINE
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS IMPACTED.
SO WHAT METHODS ARE USED TO
TRACK THE DATA. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AND I COULD SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE HOW THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION IS TRACKING THIS
DATA- AS I MENTIONED WE RECEIVE
UPDATES FROM OUR CAMPUS
PARTNERS- TO. OBVIOUSLY GRAB
RECORD CHANGE FORMS ARE WHAT'S
CALLED R. G. TWENTY ONE FORM IN
WHICH I CAMPUS FINANCIAL AID
OFFICE INFORMS THE STUDENT THAT
THERE'S BEEN A CHANGE TO THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
SUSPENDED BUT- THE OTHER FASTER.
OR THEIR- DREAM ACT- SO THIS
PROCESS IS INITIATED AT THE
CAMPUS LEVEL FIRST- BEFORE WE
ULTIMATELY RECEIVE ABOUT
SUBISSION AS- G. TWENTY ONE
FORM. AND THAT'S THE DATA THAT
WE CAN UTILIZE THAT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION- I'M TO ASSESS
HOW MANY STUDENTS ARE BEING
SHIFTED INTO ELIGIBILITY FOR
FINANCIAL AID. FOR IN CASE HOW
MANY STUDENTS AT A CHANGE SUCH
THAT THEY WERE NO LONGER
ELIGIBLE FOR FINANCIAL AID
BASED ON- STATUTE. AND SO ARE
OUR STATEMENT PARTNERS- FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING ARE RECEIVING
UPDATES FROM THEIR CAMPUS
FINANCIAL AID OFFICES- AND
REPORTING TO US BASED ON WHAT
THEY'RE HEARING FROM CAMPUSES.
BUT FOR THE COMMISSION WE'RE
TRACKING THIS VEHICLES. GRANT
RECORD CHANGE FORMS THAT ARE
SUBMITTED. IT IS THERE ANYTHING
ELSE YOU CAN TELL US ABOUT. THE
METHODS USED AT UC AND CSU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA I THINK
THAT THE OTHER SEGMENTS COULD
COULD BEST PROVIDE YOU THAT
UPDATE BUT FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING IT'S A PROCESS OF
COMMUNICATION WITH THEIR CAMPUS
FINANCIAL AID PROCESS THE
PRODUCT CAMPUS BENTLEY OFFICES%
AND BY WHICH THE SEGMENTS ARE
UNDERSTANDING HOW THOSE
CAMPUSES ARE ESTIMATING THE
NUMBER OF POTENTIALLY IMPACTED
STUDENTS AND THEN TAKING THAT A
LITTLE FOR THE SYSTEM- AND
PROVIDING THAT TO A TO THE
COMMISSION AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT- WE
HAVE A SOMEWHAT LAGGING
INDICATOR ON THIS METRIC
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO WITH THE
COMMISSION. WAIT FOR THIS GRANT
RECORD CHANGE FORMS TO BE
SUBMITTED TO US. AND WE DON'T
HAVE THE SEGMENTS HERE TODAY.
CORRECT DO WE DO WE HAVE CSU
AND WE GOT OUT OF NOW ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. I FOR THE QUESTIONS
AN ITEM NUMBER ONE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN CRESSMAN MISTER DONALD
AND IT THIS IS PRETTY COMPLEX
THERE'S A LOT OF ACRONYMS HERE
A LOT OF PROGRAMS MY SON ONE OF
THE REPORTS THAT. SOME PEOPLE
THINK WE NEED TO SIMPLIFY THIS
AS A PARENT OF ONE IS HEADING
INTO COLLEGE I THINK THAT'S-
PROBABLY A GOOD THING- BECAUSE
EVEN SITTING HERE I GET.
CONFUSED ON ALL THESE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AND GEE IF I WERE. A
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT I WOULDN'T
KNOW WHERE TO GO MY COUNSELOR
WOULD MOST LIKELY HELP ME BUT
EVEN THEN I'M SURE CANCERS GET
CONFUSED. SO I HAVE A QUESTION
I DON'T KNOW WHO PERTAINS TO
THE TOPIC ONE NOW THAT'S OKAY
AND THAT IS THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP WHEN HE WAS A
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE IT IS
THAT. ON LEGISLATIVE SIDERS
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL NO
THERE'S NO PROPOSAL IN THE-
GOVERNORS BUDGET AND- OUT THIS
FAR AS THE CAL GRANT REFORM.
THAT MR MEDINA AND OTHERS KNOW-
ALTERATION I WANNA DROP IT
WHICH IS ACTUALLY GETTING RID
OF YEAH I KNOW AND SO. ARE
PROPOSAL JUST YOU KNOW NOT
DEBATING TODAY WE DO NOT GET
RID OF THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP EITHER PUT. YOU
OKAY THIS. BUT THERE'S NO
PROPOSAL YOU WANT TO DROP IT
APPARENTLY WHICH TO ME IS
GETTING RID OF IT BUT EITHER
WAY NO I DON'T NOT. WHAT THE
TOPIC AT HAND THE ONLY JUST BE
STRAIGHT. THIS NOT DEBATING
TODAY BUT OUR PROPOSAL WHICH IS
A BILL DOES NOT DROP IT NOR GET
RID OF IT. OKAY WE LOOK AT JUST
SOME OF THE INCOME LIMITS.
THAT'S PROBABLY WHERE I'M
COMING FOR THE UPPER UPPER IN
BLACK PEOPLE MAKE UP UP TO LIKE
TWO HUNDRED GRAND- AND THEN. WE
RE DIRECT A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT BUT THAT'S NOT PROPOSAL
BEING THAT BEING DISCUSSED
TODAY THE GOVERNOR'S RACE ONE
OF OKAY OF THAT PLAN THAT
REALLY WAS MY QUESTION. YEP
WHEN IT DOES COME UP THOUGH YOU
CAN. BE SURE YOU. WILL HEAR
FROM ME BECAUSE I THINK. WE
NEED HELP THE MIDDLE CLASS IN
CALIFORNIA TOO. IN A LOWER
INCOME FOLKS. NEED HELP FOR
SURE AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
PROGRAMS IN. EVIDENCE TODAY
IT'S RIGHT HERE. THEY WERE
HELPFUL AND GETS KIDS THAT WENT
TO MY HIGH SCHOOL THAT I TAUGHT
IN. THE WE NEED TO TAKE CARE OF
THE MIDDLE CLASS TO. AN OLD
DISCUSS THAT WHEN THE TOPIC
COMES WERE. THEY GONNA. OKAY
FOR THE QUEST OF THE ISSUE ONE.
SWIMMER VITAS. EVERYONE IS
MEMBER HOLD ON THAT WOULD HAVE
TO IN THE MIDDLE PROSPERITY AT
THE POLICE THAT SIX BY THE- I
DO HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT
PROGRAM B. OR C. WILL IS THERE
POTENTIAL THAT. THAT STUDENTS
WILL ALSO BE FELT ABILITY DO
YOU LIKE CHIANG HOUSING
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS. THE PART OF FINANCE
ONE OF. THAT. KAMALA CHAMBERS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- DURING
THE FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY THANK
YOU SEE CSU NCCC INDICATED THAT
KALRA NAY WEST OF IT- A COUPLE
THERE WAS A PROBLEM WITH IT
LEAVING STATUS CHANGED HOWEVER
THE SEGMENTS DID NOT MENTIONED
REGARDING CALL GRAHAM B. OR C.
I CAN GET BACK TO YOUR OFFICE-
WE CAN COOK- CONTACT THE
SECONDS. THANK YOU. FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON MR GALLAGHER. I
THINK THE QUESTION YEAH- IF YOU
NEED. THAT THE FINANCIAL NEWS
PER SE. EVEN THOUGH THE
SITUATION MIGHT HAVE OKAY-
WHAT'S REALLY THE BASIS FOR
THAT BECAUSE I MEAN AS ALWAYS I
THINK WE HAVE TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THAT WE DO HAVE. WE
HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES- AND
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS ALL THE
LEGITIMATE NEEDS THAT EVERYBODY
HAS- AND THERE'S AND THERE
CERTAINLY ARE A LOT OF THEM.
BUT SORT OF ASSUMING THAT
WITHOUT REALLY. AND IN THIS
BUDGET. I GUESS I WOULD JUST
ASK WHAT KIND OF THE BASIS FOR
THAT AND HOW DO WE DETERMINE
THAT. THAT FINANCIAL NEED IS
STILL THE SAME EVEN THOUGH
SOMEONE'S. MAY NOT HAVE TO PAY
FOR HOUSING FOR INSTANCE- SO
MAYBE IF SOMEBODY COULD JUST
RESPOND TO THAT. SORRY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION BRIANNA
BRANDS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU KNOW I WOULD NEVER
TO THE CHANGING LIVING STATUS
WE SEE IS A REALLY TECHNICAL
ISSUE HERE- THE STUDENTS WHO
ARE LOSING THEIR ELIGIBILITY
BECAUSE OF THIS CHANGE-
WHATEVER OTHERWISE QUALIFY FOR
AN AWARD AND WHAT THEY HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO. TO STAY LIVING ON
CAMPUS- BUT DUE TO THAT YOU
KNOW UNFORESEEN CIRCUMSTANCES
THE COMPANY TEAM THEY'RE NO
LONGER ABLE TO DO SO YOU KNOW
FROM THE MINISTRATIONS
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS REALLY JUST
A TECHNICAL. ISSUE TO RESTORE
ELIGIBILITY. YEAH I WILL NOT
SAY THAT THE MAJORITY OF CALVIN
AND I'VE CRACKED IF I'M
MISTAKEN CAL GRANT EIGHT. IS
COVERS TUITION ANYWAY SO IT'S
NOT YOUR YOUR HOUSING COSTS SO
I THINK IT'S A DIFFERENCE
WITHOUT A DISTINCTION. OKAY SO
LET'S GET INTO THE MEAT OF THE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SO
LET'S CONTINUE NOW WITH THE
OTHER. ISSUES NOW ISSUE TOO.
THE PROPOSAL CHANGING FOR NON
PROFITS- ISSUE THREE THE
INCREASE. IN COMPETITIVE.
GRANTS ISSUE FOR THE NEW
ACTRESS AWARD FOR FOSTER YOUTH
SO. LET'S PROCEED WITH ISSUE.
WITH THOSE ISSUES. BERMAN A
FINANCE. CORRECT WITH THE
COMING OF FINANCE. FOR A YEAR
CONGRESS FOR NON. AS IN IN THE
AGENDA OUR CURRENT LAW REQUIRES%
PRIVATE NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS
TO OFFER ADMISSION TO AT LEAST
THREE THOUSAND. IT'S A GREAT
TRANSFERRED. BY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN AT THE MAXIMUM AGR IN
TUITION AWARD FOR STUDENTS
ATTENDED A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
INSTITUTION. EVERY SEED. NINE
THOUSAND EIGHT FOUR DOLLARS
ASSET FOR CARBON THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES TO AMEND THE
STATUTE. THE LATEST REQUIREMENT
FROM APPLYING IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO TWELVE POINT
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. THIS
REPORT WILL PROVIDE INSTABILITY
TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
CONTEMPLATING ATTENDING A
PRIVATE AND NONPROFIT PRIVATE
INSTITUTION. AND THOSE CONTINUE
AND THEIR EDUCATION. IS THE
KING OF LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. PRIVATE NONPROFIT
UNIVERSITIES HAVE EXPERIENCE IN
A MOMENT DECLINES DURING THE
PANDEMIC I WAS SCARED AND
INOTES IN PAGE FIVE YEAH I SEE
A MEMBERS HAVE REPORTED A
MEDIAN DECLINE OF ABOUT 7%
FROM. TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY. AND I DID THESE TRENDS
THERE IS THE REST OF THE SECTOR
COULD MESSAGE EDT ADMISSIONS
TRGET IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE YEAR. BUT COULD
RESULT IN A REDUCTION AND CAL
GRANT COVERAGE FOR INCOMING
STUDENTS IN THE BUDGET. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD
PREVENT THIS POTENTIAL
REDUCTION AWARD AMOUNTS FOR
INCOMING STUDENTS OF FINANCIAL
AID. I THINK NEARLY ACTION THE
PROPOSAL. AS CHáVEZ NOTED. BUT
PROVIDE THE STUDENTS MORE
PREDICTABILITY REGARDING THE
FINANCIALLY COVERAGE AS THE
MAKING MORE DECISIONS THIS
SPRING. PLEASE REFERENCE THE
RECOMMENDED OPTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
OKAY L. A. O. THAT WAS SELLING
AT ONE. SENATE COMMISSION. J.
PARTNER ON BEHALF OF THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION THE
COMMISSION WOULD AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS YOU'VE HEARD FROM
REPRESENTATIVES FROM DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND ALEJO WE BELIEVE
THAT IT WOULD NOT BE HELPFUL TO
OUR STUDENTS TO SEE ANY
DISRUPTION TO THEIR ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL AID DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND A PERIOD OF SUCH
UNCERTAINTY FOR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES. OKAY SO BEFORE WE GET
ON TO THE TO THE COMPETITIVE
HOWEVER IF HE'S REALLY GOT- IS
EXPECTED TO HAPPEN. JUST SOME
OF THE ICC YOU THE TOP OKAY
YEAH WE HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE INDEPENDENT CALLED
UNIVERSE. OUR GREAT. SURE IN
THE MORNING ALEX GREAT THAT
THEY ARE CEO I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRIEFLY
DISCUSS THIS ITEM AND HAVE NOT
PROFIT SECTORS ARE TO TRANSFER
FOR STUDENTS WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL PUSH
OUT THE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
THIS YEAR GIVEN THE HISTORIC
DISTRACTIONS WE'VE SEEN OUR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES FOR
INSTITUTIONS IN THE STATE. OF
THE BACKGROUND INFORMATION IN
YOUR AGENDA GETS A GOOD
SYNOPSIS OF THE ISSUE- I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT SINCE THAT
AGREEMENT WAS SIGNED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THIRTY NINE
ACC INSTITUTIONS HAVE
ARTICULATED TO AT LEAST ONE
EIGHTY PATHWAY SO THIS MEANS
THAT THE MAJORITY AT FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE
EXCEPT AT T. ARE PRIVATE
NONPROFIT COLLEGES. AS OF LAST
ACT YEAR WE NOW. FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN ARTICULATED AT T.
PATHWAYS AND THREE ARE
INSTITUTIONS HAVE ARTICULATED
TO EACH AB T. PATHWAY. I'M IS
YOUR ITEM NOTES LAST YEAR OVER
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
STUDENTS WERE ADMITTED TO A
PARTICIPATING INSTITUTION
EXCEEDING. OUR STATUTORY TARGET
TWO THOUSAND. AT THIS PAST
NOVEMBER WE SURVEYED OUR
ADMISSIONS OFFICE SAID IT IS.
WITH FIFTY SIX INSTITUTE
RESPONDING TO COLLECTIVELY
ENROLL ABOUT 91% OF OUR
UNDERGRADUATES. THOSE SURVEY
FINDINGS REVEALED A 7% DECLINE
IN ENROLLMENT OVERALL AND A 6%
DECLINE IN TRANSFER STUDENTS. I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT WE ALSO
LOOKED SPECIFICALLY AT THE
RESPONSES OF AT T.
PARTICIPATING INSTITUTIONS. AND
FOUND THAT THE DECLINE FOR
THEIR TRANSFER STUDENT ROMAN
WAS ABOUT SIX AND A HALF
PERCENT- SO WELL WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE DATA
COLLECTION. AND ANALYSIS
PROCESS FOR THIS ACADEMIC
YEAR'S AT T. ADMIT NUMBERS. OUR
SURVEY FINDINGS CERTAINLY LEAD
US TO BELIEVE THAT THE PANDEMIC
MAGGIE ADVERSELY IMPACT OUR
EIGHTEEN NUMBERS THIS YEAR. WE
NOW BELIEVE THIS WOULD BE AN
ACCURATE REFLECTION OF THE
SECTOR'S COMMITMENT AT T.
STUDENTS SEEKING TO TRANSFER.
SO AGAIN IT'S SUPPORT
ADMINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL
BECAUSE IT RECOGNIZES THAT
COMMITMENT REMAINS. WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING EARLY INSURANCE TO
STUDENTS AS WELL AS
INSTITUTIONAL AID OFFICES WERE
PACKAGING EIGHT. BETWEEN NOW
AND WHEN STUDENTS HAVE TO MAKE
A DECISION THIS SPRING. THANK
YOU BE HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
DO WE HAVE QUESTIONS ON THIS
ISSUE RELATES TO OUR NONPROFIT
COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VITAS. THANK YOU SO THIS
PANDEMIC THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE
GOING ON ELEVEN MONTHS ALMOST A
YEAR OF DESTRUCTION FOR
STUDENTS THAT AT EVERY LEVEL-
THERE'S NOT FOR VARIOUS
INDUSTRIES IN SCHOOLS IS NOT
REALLY CLEAR PATH FOR RE
OPENING A LOT OF OUR STUDENTS
LIVES CALLED STUDENTS LIVES
HAVE BEEN UP ROOTED AND THERE'S
NO CLARITY OR PATH BECAUSE
WE'RE STILL KIND OF IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS PANDEMIC I'M
EVEN CONSIDERING THAT WE HAVE.
VACCINATIONS THAT ARE BECOMING
MORE MORE READILY AVAILABLE
WHILE WE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
INCREASE BUT WOULDN'T IT BE OR
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDER A TWO YEAR EXTENSION
OF AT T. GOALS THIS WOULD ALLOW
STUDENTS IN THE SEGMENTS TO
MORE TIME TO RECOVER FROM THE
IMPACTS OF COAL BED AND GET
BACK ON TRACK WITH THEIR
EDUCATION IS THIS IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD BE OPEN TO.
HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR QUESTION- THIS
PROPOSAL IS THAT SPECIFIC
ORDER- THIS YEAR. AS A RESULT
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
HOWEVER I'M HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
FEEDBACK TO THE ADMINISTRATION.
YEAH I MEAN WE DON'T
NECESSARILY KNOW WHAT YOU KNOW
HOW LONG THIS IS GOING TO
CONTINUE SO I THINK AS WERE
STARTING TO APPROACH THE NEXT
SCHOOL YEAR IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE SHOULD CONSIDER BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW EIGHT IT'S A YEAR LATER
IT'S GOING TO TAKE US SOME TIME
TO RECOVER AND STUDENTS AND WE
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED OF THAT
BUT- THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REST THANK. YOU
FOR THE SURVEY OF. DEFENSE
EARLIER BY THE INDEPENDENT.
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES SHOWS
THE SURVEY BY THE INDEPENDENT
COLLEGES UNIVERSITY SHOWS THAT
6% DECLINE IN ENROLLMENT FOR
COMMUNITY CALL AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. IT IS ALTHOUGH THIS
MAY NOT BE THE RIGHT FORUM BUT
STILL HAVE QUESTIONS WHAT ARE
THE FACTORS. THAT YOU BELIEVE
ARE INVOLVED AND DRIVING THIS
DECLINE AND HOW IS THAT GOING.
FIRST OF THESE. I'M SORRY WAS
THAT QUESTION FOR ME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I YES IT'S HARD TO GET
OKAY DIRECTED TO THE
ASSOCIATION CORRECT THANK YOU
BODIES UP TO GIVE HIM I THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- YOU KNOW
I THINK. I THINK YOUR QUESTION
AS WELL THE POINT MADE BY YOUR
CALL LIKE PREVIOUSLY ABOUT- ONE
ZERO THAT OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE
TRYING TO GRAPPLE WITH I MEAN
CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW D. E. SHAW
IMPACTS THE PANDEMIC ARE STILL
NOT. ENTIRELY RELIES- AND
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW THIS
PANDEMIC WILL IMPACT NOT JUST-
YOU KNOW THIS YEAR'S CLASS BUT
IT ALSO IMPACTS THE BROADER
PIPELINE RIGHT OF STUDENTS
COMING INTO AB OR OR TWO YEAR
AND FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITIES- YOU
KNOW I. WE ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF DOING A FOLLOW UP SURVEY- TO
SEE HOW IT MISSION MEMBERS ARE
LOOKING FOR. THIS COMING YEAR-
AND CERTAINLY WITH YOU KNOW
VACCINE ROLL OUT IN OTHER
THINGS THAT OCCURRING- YEAH WE
CAN HAVE SOME OPTIMISM THAT
PERHAPS THAT ENROLLMENT WILL
WILL STABILIZE BUT AT I JUST
DESTRUCTION LAST YEAR WAS WAS
MASSIVE NOT JUST FOR NEW
INCOMING STUDENTS WERE TRANSFER
STUDENTS BUT THERE WAS ALSO.
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER IN
OFTENTIMES UNPRECEDENTED-
SUMMER MELT WHERE STUDENTS YOU
KNOW BETWEEN THE TIME THEY
DECIDED WE'RE GONNA GO- IN THE
SPRING WHEN THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO JUMP FONG- CHANGE THEIR MIND
SO I THINK THERE'S A LOT STILL
TO BE DETERMINED THAT IS TO YOU
HOW. THIS WILL PLAY OUT IN THE
LONGER TERM. AND JUST AS A
QUICK FOR UP ON AGREE WITH THE
MY- MEDINA. IN THE COLLECTION
OF THIS DATA. IT'S SO IMPORTANT
FOR US MAYBE IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE AS IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE WE'RE TAKING EARLY
ACTION. TO TRY TO TAKE CARE OF
THE ISSUES BUT FOR THE FUTURE
IT WILL BE IMPORTANT AS WE MAKE
THE ADJUSTMENTS. SO I WANT TO
ECHO WHAT MY- MY COLLEAGUES
TALKED ABOUT- BUT COLLECTING
THIS DATA. THANK YOU AT AND I
THINK OVERALLTHAT HIS POLICY
WAS BORN OUT OF OUR DESIRE TO.
INCREASE TRANSFER
OPPORTUNITIES. WHICH WE HAD
BEEN DOING AT THE UC AND CSU.
AND DRAMATICALLY INCREASE
OPPORTUNITIES THE UC AND WE
WANTED TO WITH OUR INVESTMENT
THAT WE MAKE FOR INDEPENDENT
CALLS UNIVERSITIES WOULD SAY
NOW. WE KNOW THERE A PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE TO MAKE SURE WE GET
ENOUGH. STUDENTS EDUCATED WITH
A HIGHER EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA WE JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE THAT
OPPORTUNITY THAT THAT. THAT
INVESTMENT TO HELP. A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRANSFERRED OPPORTUNITY
SO BUT WE ARE IN A PANDEMIC AND
I THINK THIS PROPOSAL HAS
MERIT- WE WILL DELAY ACTION ON
THIS- FOR THE TIME BEING SEEN
FOR THE QUESTIONS ON. THIS
ISSUE WILL PROCEED NOW WITH THE
NEXT ISSUE. RELATED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
THE COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
AWARDS. THE COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS SUPPORT
FINANCIAL AID AWARDS. WHAT IS.
ADMINISTRATIVE FINANCE. BUT DID
NOT MEET ALL THE CRITERIA TO
RECEIVE AN ENTITLEMENT A WORK.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
AN INCREASE OF APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY FIVE MILLION I'M GOING
GENERAL FUND. TO LACK NINE
THOUSAND COVERING COMPLETED
ABOUT WHAT'S THIS WILL INCREASE
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE
AWARDS. TWO THOUSAND. OKAY NEXT
L. L. THANK YOU THE TABLE IN
THE BOTTOM OF PAGE SEVEN IF
YOU'RE CARRYING A GUN THAT
PROVIDES INFORMATION ON THE
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. FROM THIS
TABLE THE DEMAND FOR
COMPETITIVE OR ITS FAR EXCEEDS
SUPPLY. WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
WERE ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM
THAT YOU'RE NOT RECEIVING A
LARGE. FOR THE DATA FROM THESE
ACCIDENTS THAT THE STUDENTS WHO
ARE NOT CURRENTLY RECEIVING
AWARDS HAVE HIGH FINANCIAL
NEED. WITH AN AVERAGE INCOME OF
ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. BUT ALSO INCREASE THE
SUPPLY OF THESE AVAILABLE WHERE
IT'S- AN EXPECT ALSO THAT THE
AWARDS TO BE ALLOCATED A LARGE
PART ACCORDING TO STEPHEN. THIS
IS BECAUSE THE SCORING MATRIX
THAT THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
USES TO PRIORITIZE COMPATIBLE
WHAT RECIPIENTS PLACES THE
GREATEST WEIGHT ON MEASURES
SUCH AS HOUSEHOLD INCOME THAN
EXPECTED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION.
DOES THREE IS ONE IMPORTANT
FISCAL CONSIDERATION WHICH IS
THAT THE COST OF EXPANDING KIND
OF WORDS TO INCREASE NOTABLY IN
THE OUT YEARS. THIS IS A
PATTERN WE COMMONLY SEE WITH
BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT ONE NEW
COALPART OF CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS AT A TIME. IT'S AN
EXTENSIVE. NEED THE COSTS OF
THIS PROPOSAL COULD ROUGHLY
DOUBLE BY THE TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY FIRST LEGISLATURE TO
KEEP THE STATE'S PROJECTED
OPERATING DEFICIT IN MIND AS IT
CONSIDERS ANYHOW CAN EXPANSION
BUT PARTICULARLY ONES LIKE THIS
THAT HAVE ESCALATING COSTS.
THAT SAID IF THE FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE WE DO THINK THIS
PROPOSAL IS WORTH CONSIDERING.
I KNOW THAT IT ALIGNS CLOSELY
WITH RECENT LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS
TO EXPAND HOW CAN ELIGIBILITY
ACCORDING TO STUDENT NEED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATE
COMMISSION. MCCARTY A TAPE
RUNNER UP AFTER THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE THAT GOVERNOR
NUISANCE PROPOSED AN EXPANSION
OF THE NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT WORDS AVAILABLE FOR
THE UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR THIS
WILL ALLOW US THAT THE
COMMISSION TO SERVE MORE OF THE
ELIGIBLE BUT UNFUNDED STUDENTS
THAT WERE JUST REFERENCE BY L.
A. L. AS A NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA
MATERIALS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY THERE ARE OVER TWO
HUNDRED NINETY THREE THOUSAND
APPLICANTS REFERRED TO THE
<c.green>OMPETITIVE CAL GRANT POOL. YET</c>
ONLY FORTY ONE THOUSAND AWARDS
OF THE COMMISSION WAS
AUTHORIZED TO PAY JUST STUDENTS
SO AFTER THE LARGEST INCREASE
IN THE HISTORY OF THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
ENACTED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
STATE BUDGET ONLY ONE FOR EVERY
SEVEN STUDENTS IN THE
COMPETITIVE POOL RECEIVE THE
GRANT OR PUT ANOTHER WAY 86% OF
STUDENTS AND A COMPETITIVE
PROGRAM DESPITE HAVING
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL. NEED
WILL NOT RECEIVE A CALTRAIN
WORK. WHAT THE COMMISSION IS.
FOR THIS PROPOSED AND VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ADDED
INVESTMENT- WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THIS WOULD STILL LEAVE. MANY
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS WITHOUT
EIGHT NOR WOULD IT PROVIDE ANY
PREDICTABILITY FOR CERTAINTY TO
THE STUDENTS WHO MIGHT
EVENTUALLY. RECEIVE AN AWARD.
SO THAT NINE THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL COMPETITIVE AWARDS
ARE CERTAINLY A WELCOME
INVESTMENT IN THE PROPOSED.
TWENTY TWENTY IN THE PROS
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
STATE BUDGET- BUT AS YOU NOTED
EARLIER- YOUR COMMENTS JOHN
MCCARTY. WE DO HOPE THAT MOVING
FORWARD UNDER CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION WE CAN ELIMINATE
THE ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS THAT
RESULT IN ANY GIVEN IN PLACE.
IN THE COMPETITIVE PROGRAM IN
THE FIRST PLACE AND PROVIDER
MOST FINANCIALLY VULNERABLE
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA WITH
MORE PREDICTABLE ACCESS. TO
STATE FINANCIAL AID. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OKAY I WANT TO START
TALKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE- FIRST
OF ALL THIS IS IT'S A IT'S A
PLUS THAT WE'RE DRAMATICALLY
INCREASING THE CAL GRANT
COMPETITIVE AWARDS BY NINE
THOUSAND AND AS YOU SAID LAST
YEAR- LAST YEAR WAS THE BIGGEST
INCREASE SO. YOU KNOW FIVE TEN
YEARS AGO YOUR ODDS OF GETTING
AT COMPETITIVE WARD I THINK
LIKE ONE AND FIFTEEN NOW WITH
THIS THERE WOULD BE ONE AND
FIVE SO THAT'S A DRAMATIC
IMPROVEMENT. BUT I THINK THE
BIG PICTURE IS THAT WE HAVE
THESE- CAL GRANT PROGRAMS WHICH
YOU KNOW REWARDS INDIVIDUALS TO
FILL OUT THE FACT THAT WHEN
THEY'RE IN HIGH SCHOOL BUT THEN
IF YOU LET'S SAY DURING THIS
PANDEMIC IT SO YOU'RE NOT GONNA
GO TO SCHOOL FOR A YEAR YOU'RE
GOING TO WORK HELP YOUR FAMILY.
YOU'RE STILL A GREAT STUDENT
AND THEN YOU APPLY FOR THE
CARAVAN A COUPLE YEARS LATER
AND YOUR YOUR YOUR ELIGIBILITY
IF YOUR INCOME IS HASN'T
CHANGED THEIR GRADES WERE THE
SAME AS IN HIGH SCHOOL THEN
YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE IN THIS
COMPETITIVE POT AND SO IT'S NO
LONGER AN ENTITLEMENT YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE TO GO IN THIS
COMPETITIVE POTTON COME AND
COMPETE WITH. YOU KNOW TENS OF
THOUSANDS IN YOUR ODDS OF
GETTING OUT ARE ONE IN FIVE AND
SO- THERE'S NOTHING CHANGE WITH
THAT STUDENT THERE'S STILL A
QUALIFIED STUDENTS ARE STILL
READY TO LEARN BUT WE JUST
TREAT THEM DIFFERENTLY AND SO
THIS IS ONE OF- I THINK THE
MISTAKES WHEN WITH THE CAL
GRANT- PROGRAM WHEN WE CREATED
IT ABOUT TWENTY ONE YEARS AGO.
SO WHAT WE WOULD WE WOULD HELP
AND I KNOW THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN TO LOOK AT MODERNIZING
AND ELIMINATING BARRIERS AND
SIMPLIFYING- ELIGIBILITY- AS
AS- AS MR O'DONNELL SAID AND WE
THINK IT'S EASY YOU JUST HAVE
TO DO ONE THING FILL OUT THE
FORM AND THE STATE WILL TELL
YOU WHICH ONE YOU'RE ELIGIBLE
FOR GRANT THERE'S TWO FORMS IF
YOU'RE- A DOCUMENT IN
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION BUT- YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT IT'S THE CHANCE TO.
TO MAKE THIS EASIER AND TAKE
CARE MORE STUDENTS NOT THE
OPPOSITE BUT ALL THIS COSTS
MONEY AND THE GOOD NEWS OF THIS
DOES PUT IN THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS MORE. INTO FINANCIALLY
IN CALIFORNIA PLUS WE'VE GOT A
PROPOSAL SO THAT IS IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION CERTAINLY WE
COULD ALWAYS ATTEMPTED. TO TAKE
TO GO MORE- YOU KNOW- WILL GET
THAT BITES. IS CERTAINLY. GET
STRONG SUPPORTER THIS IS ALWAYS
BEEN A PRIORITY OF A BILL OF
THE ASSEMBLY TO INCREASE THE
COMPETITIVE AWARDS- BUT AGAIN I
THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS IN
A LARGER CONTEXT MR MEDINA. ALL
RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR- IT
IS SO COMPLICATED AS MR
O'DONNELL SAID AND THAT SEEMS
LIKE THE CHANCES OF GETTING ONE
OF THESE COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS
ARE SMALLER THAN THAN WINNING
THE LOTTERY AND SHOULDN'T BE
THAT WAY SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING. WITH YOU TO SIMPLIFY-
THE WHOLE SYSTEM. OKAY MISTER
O'DONNELL IN MR GALLAGHER. YEAH
I JUST WANT TO. HELLO WHAT DID
THE TWO OF YOU STATE IS IF
THERE'S A WAY THERE'S SOME
PROCESS TO MAKE THIS EASIER IT
WOULD BE MUCH BETTER AND WHY
NOT WHEN STUDENTS FALL THE FAST
WITH A HIGH SCHOOL CLASSROOM
WHICH WE DID MY CLASSROOM MANY
TIMES. CAME HAVE ANOTHER
DOCUMENT AT THE SAME TIME THEY
FILL OUT. FOR CALAVERAS EXCEPT
AROUND THAT SEEMS O ME TO BE A
NO BRAINER- NOW WE NEED TO ALSO
KNOWN AS I'VE HIGHLIGHTED IN
THE PAST. THERE WE HAVE A VERY
WE HAVE A LOT OF UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA WHO
DON'T FIND OUT TILL THE DAY OUT
THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO FELT A
FASTER. THEY ARE NOT DOCUMENT A
GO HOME. ONE DAY AND SAY I NEED
MY NUMBER. AND THEY COME BACK
THE NEXT DAY. WITHOUT A NUMBER.
LEARNING FOR THE FIRST TIME.
THAT THEY ARE NOT DOCUMENTED
RIGHT AND IT'S A- LOT OF LOT OF
LOT OF STUFF GOING ON THERE HAS
BEEN THOSE THINGS OCCUR. TO ME
TO ACCOMMODATE THAT TO THE AB
FIVE EIGHTY STUFF FOR. MATURE
WAS EIGHTY SOMETHING OUT THERE
WITH THE STUDENTS FELT YOU KNOW
THE- ACT BY FORTY SB FIVE FORTY
Và. SO I JUST THINK THERE'S A
WAY TO MAKE THIS PROCESS EASIER
I'LL BET. IT WOULD SAVE ON A
LOT OF ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AS
WELL. BECAUSE THERE'S GOT TO BE
YOU KNOW. PROBABLY MULTIPLE
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE WORKING
FOR MULTIPLE PROGRAMS OF
SOMEHOW WE COMBINE THESE
EFFORTS STREAMLINED THEM. AND
BRING IN SOME TECHNOLOGY MY
GUESS. I'M WILLING TO HEAR
DIFFERENT. IS THAT THIS WOULD
SIMPLIFY THE PROCESS ON BOTH
SIDES THANK YOU. MR GALLAGHER.
SO KIND OF GOING BACK TO THE
FIRST ISSUE AND RELATED TO
THIS- YOU KNOW WE'RE CHANGING
THE CRITERIA FOR CAL GRANT NAY
AS I UNDERSTAND IT FROM STUDENT
AID COMMISSION THERE'S ONLY
ABOUT ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT STUDENTS.
THAT THAT. AND I THINK WE COULD
ADDRESS. I THINK WE COULD
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM WITH- THE
STUDENTS POTENTIALLY LOSING
FUNDING WITH FEDERAL FUNDS ARE
CA AS YOU'VE AS YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT MISTER CHAIRMAN- YOU KNOW
WE HAVE MORE FEDERAL FUNDS
COMING IN THOSE FUNDS COULD BE
USED TO HELP SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS WHO MIGHT BE LOSING.
MONEY BECAUSE THAT IS AN
ELIGIBILITY AND THEN USE THIS
YOU ARE OUR OUR STATE BUDGETARY
FUNDS TO ENHANCE CAL GRANT
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS WHICH WE
KNOW THERE'S NOT ENOUGH I MEAN.
15% LOW INCOME STUDENTS WHO ARE
APPLYING FOR THESE- GRANT SAYS
THAT'S ALL THAT ARE GETTING THE
COMPETITIVE GRANT RIGHT NOW.
THIS PROPOSAL'S GREATEST NINE
THOUSAND MORE. BUT WHAT IF WE
COULD BUMP THAT UP EVEN MORE
AND INCREASE MORE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PEOPLE IN THESE AREAS ORDER
DRESS YOU KNOW- YOU KNOW MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP. I MEAN
THERE'S- I THINK WE COULD
PROBABLY. BETTER UTILIZE THIS
MONEY TO INCREASE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR EVEN MORE STUDENTS I GUESS
IS WHAT I'M GETTING AT- BY
LEVERAGING OUR OUR STATE
DOLLARS- TO THESE TO THESE
OTHER PROGRAMS. THAT I THINK
KIND OF A REALLY HIGH NEED. K.
IN THIS RACE NOT ALL COME
ADDRESS YOUR ISSUE AFTER AFTER
THE FINISHED MR GALLAGHER SURE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THINK
THAT IT'S CLEAR FROM WHAT WE'RE
HEARING THAT THIS IS JUST WERE
MAKING A COMPLICATED SYSTEM
EVEN MORE COMPLICATED BUT I
THINK THAT- ONE OF THE GOOD
THINGS ABOUT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE IS THAT. MOREOVER
FOSTER YOUTH ARE ARE GOING TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS AND THEY HAVE
TO BE PRIORITIES WHAT NEXT-
VERY GOOD OF BUT- I WILL SAVE
MY QUESTION FOR THE NEXT FOR
THE NEXT PANEL. OKAY FINE SO
WE'LL GET TO THAT FOSTER YOU
THEY WILL HAVE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE GO OVER THAT
PROPOSAL IN ONE SECOND. BUT FOR
THIS ONE- I MISTER GALLAGHER I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE STATE THE
ISSUE THEY WERE CHANGING IN THE
ELIGIBILITY- THAT'S JUST ONE
TIME FOR THIS COHORT IT'S NOT
ON IT'S NOT ON GOING MONEY
CHANGE SO THAT'S JUST DURING
THIS PANDEMIC FOR THIS LIVING
SITUATION AND SO. WE DO SO IN
THE NEXT YEAR THAT THAT
WOULDN'T. BE THE CASE SO
THERE'S NOT ANY NEW MONEY THAT
WE COULD EXPAND WE'RE JUST.
ALLOWING PEOPLE WHO ARE
POTENTIALLY SLIPPING THE CRACKS
TO KEEP THEIR MONEY- TO PAY FOR
THEIR FOR THEIR TUITION IF
THEY'RE CAL GRANT THE RECIPIENT
SO. I DO SHARE YOUR YOUR
OPTIMISM AND DESIRE TO EXPAND-
COMPRESS QUALIFIED OPCODES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR QUALIFIED
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. AND YOUNG
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WHO PLAYED
LIKE THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM AND
THE COMPETITIVE SLOT WHO YOUR
ODDS ARE HE THEY WERE ONE AND
SEVEN NOW WITH THIS WHEN THEY
BE ONE OF FIVE BUT STILL- WE'RE
MISSING OUT SO WE'LL GET TO
THAT LATER IN THIS THERE'S A
PROPOSAL BY ESTIMATE
COMMISSION. WHICH HAS SOME.
COMPANION LEGISLATION THAT MR
MEDINA I WORK ON WE'LL GET TO
THAT IN A LITTLE BIT LATER-
BUT- AT THIS ISSUE WE WILL WE
WILL HOLD OPEN- NO ACTION TO
GIVE QUESTION. YEAH SOMEONE
REVISED S. ASSEMBLY WOMAN. I
SHARE YOUR INTO. TO TALK ABOUT
R. FIVE YOUTH SO I'M MY MIND
THERE WITH. MICHAEL IS THAT
RATHER MORE OF A- QUESTION FOR
STACK- YOU LOOKS. THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE CALL- IS
IDENTIFYING THE NUMBER PAID.
VERSUS AWARDS. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND- THIS GETS INTO THE
COMPLEXITY OF OUR FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM- YOU YOU YOU'RE CALLING
SEVEN REFERENCING THROUGHOUT
THIS MORNING'S CONVERSATION. SO
THE COLUMN DESIGNATING AWARDS
OF OUR THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WHO WERE OFFERED A COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT ABOARD AT SOMETIME.
THE PAID COLUMN ARE THE
STUDENTS WHO ACTUALLY RECEIVED
A GRANT- SO FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS- PARTICULARLY AT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THERE ARE
MANY STUDENTS WHO APPLY FOR
FINANCIAL AID. AND I BELIEVE IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SPOKE TO THE
SUMMER MELT ISSUE- THAT WE
WE'VE SEEN THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS- BUT A NUMBER OF THE
STUDENTS WERE OFFERED AN AWARD
MAY NOT ULTIMATELY CLAIM THAT
AWARD. SO WHEN OUR OMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO
ENSURE. THE MAXIMUM NUMBER OF
STUDENTS CAN RECEIVE- THIS FORM
OF STATE SUPPORT FOR THEIR
PURSUIT OF HIGHER EDUCATION IF
THE STUDENT DOESN'T CLAIM I
DON'T LORD THAT AWARD IS.
RECYCLED AND OFFERED TO ANOTHER
STUDENT PRISON THAT COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS POOL IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO THEN CLAIM
THE AWARD AND FOR US TO UTILIZE
THE FULL NUMBER OF AWARDS THAT
WERE AUTHORIZED TO PAY OUT TO
STUDENTS UNDER STATUTE. ENACTED
IN FUNDED BY THE BUDGET. SO
YOU'LL SEE THAT THERE ARE. YOU
KNOW A LARGER. OF AWARD AND OF
COURSE THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WERE ACTUALLY PAID AND IN SOME
INSTANCES WE ACTUALLY
ULTIMATELY PAY OUT MORE
STUDENTS THAN. YOU WOULD SEE
YOU KNOW IT AND THE AWARD OF
POLITICS FOR THAT PARTICULAR
SEGMENT. AND THAT'S A FRACTION
OF THIS RECYCLING PROCESS.
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THE
EXPLANATION AND- I'M JUSTICE
SACK HAVE. CERTIFICATE
COMPLETION OF GRADUATION DATA
FOR THE COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS. COMPARED TO THE
ELIGIBLE BUT NON RECIPIENTS.
QUESTION THANK YOU FOR THAT
THAT QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS A
LIMITATION WE HAVE AND STATE
DATA AND- I KNOW THERE ARE
OTHER CONVERSATIONS TAKING
PLACE THROUGHOUT THE BUDGETING
PROCESS AROUND A STATE
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM I'M
WHAT WE GET THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION COULD IDENTIFY- THE
NUMBER OF ACADEMIC TERMS FOR
WHICH IS STUDENT RECEIVE
FINANCIAL AID OR WHETHER THEY
ALTERNATELY UTILIZED ALL OF
THEIR ELIGIBILITY THERE FOR
YEARS A FULL TIME ENROLLMENT
ELIGIBILITY FOR RECEIPT OF
STATE AID WE DON'T ULTIMATELY
RECEIVED ANY DATA BACK FROM OUR
SEGMENT AND CAMPUS PARTNERS
ABOUT THE COMPLETION RATES OF
STUDENTS AND THEIR PERSISTENCE
RATES- SO WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THAT WOULD BE A WORTHWHILE.
DATA POINT FOR OUR POLICYMAKERS
AND EDUCATION LEADERS AS WE
CONTINUE TO BUILD OUT THAT
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM
AND BETTER CONNECT THE EXISTING
DATA SOURCES IN CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION SO THAT WE CAN ANSWER
THOSE KIND OF QUESTIONS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE A
CLEAR- DATA POINT THAT WE COULD
SHARE WITH YOU ON COMPLETION
RATES FOR OUR- RECIPIENTS AS A
RESULT OF THAT. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU I NOW WILL GO TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR THIS IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. RELATED TO
THE CAL GRANT ACCESS AWARD FOR
FOSTER YOUTH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HI OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A TWENTY
MILLION ON GOING GENERAL FUND
TO INCREASE THE ACCESS AWARD
FOR FORMER OR CURRENT FOSTER
YOUTH STUDENTS. ELIGIBLE NEW
ALREADY- COVER NAY STUDENTS
WILL RECEIVE AN AXIS OF WORK A
FIVE TO SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS AN
ELIGIBLE NEW ALREADY- KALRA BE
STUDENTS WILL SEE THEIR ACCESS
AWARD INCREASED FROM ONE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT TO SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AN ELIGIBLE CONCORD NC STUDENTS
WILL SEE THEIR BOOK AND SUPPLY
WERE INCREASED FROM ONE
THOUSAND NINETY FOUR DOLLARS TO
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
L. A. L. THANK YOU THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THE TARGET
ADDITIONAL NON TUITION INTO A
GROUP OF STUDENTS THAT HAS
DEMONSTRATED HIGH NEED BASED ON
DATA FROM THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION THEIR VAST MAJORITY
OF AUSTRIANS ABOUT 93% OF THEIR
EXPECTED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION
THAT'S A MEASURE OF THEIR
FINANCIAL RESOURCES BASED ON
FACTORS SUCH AS FAMILY INCOME
ASSETS INSIDE. WE'VE ALSO SEEN
AN STUDENT SURVEYS THAT
PHOSPHATE ELEVATED RATES OF
BASIC NEEDS INSECURITY
ESPECIALLY THAT COMES HOUSING
AND SECURITY. IN ORDER PRO
CHINA DOES HAVE A DOWNSIDE AND
TACKLE COMMON MADE BY MEMBERS A
MOMENT AGO ADDING IN YOUR TYPE.
RISKS MAKING A COMPLICATED
SYSTEM MORE COMPLICATED. WE DO
THINK THAT IN THE LONG TERM
LEGISLATURE MAY HAVE
ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS EXPANDING
ON TUITION AID THAT DON'T RELY
ON THE SUPPLEMENTAL WORDS
APPROACH. SO MOMENT AGO I AND
MENTION THE MEASURE OF EXPECTED
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION ESP
SOMETHING UNLIKELY CARE MORE
ABOUT LAST ISSUE ON TODAY'S
AGENDA AS WELL. THERE'S BEEN
SOME RECENT FEDERAL CHANGES
THAT YES THE MEASURE THAT ARE
INTENDED TO REFINE IT AND MAKE
IT MORE USEFUL FOR STATES
IDENTIFYING STUDENTS WITH THE
VERY HIGHEST NEED. ONE THIS NEW
MEASURES INTRODUCED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
WARD HERE WE THINK IT'LL OPEN
UP THE POSSIBILITY OF USING
THIS REVISED FEDERAL MEASURE.
AS A WAY TO PRIORITIZE STUDENTS
FOR ADDITIONAL AID. WITHOUT
RELYING ON CREATING THE
SUPPLEMENTAL. AWARDS FOR
VARIOUS GROUPS OF STUDENTS. TO
RECOMMENDATIONS. ULTIMATELY
IT'S UP PARTS. AS WITH THE
PREVIOUS ISSUE AWARDS ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO KEEP THE
STATE'S PROJECTED OPERATING
DEFICIT IN MIND AS IT CONSIDERS
**** AND EXPANSIONS BUT IF THE
LEGISLATURE TO GET HIGH BUDGET
PRIOR TO TALKING EXTENSION. WE
THINK THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
AS A REASONABLE NEAR TERM
OPTION TO EXPAND ON TUITION AID
TO A GROUP OF STUDENTS WITH
VERY HIGH NEED. IN LONGER TERM
WE THINK THAT THE NEW FEDERAL
STUDENT AID IMPACTS COULD
PRESENT A MORE SYSTEMATIC
OPTION FOR ACCOMPLISHING A
SIMILAR CALL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SOON A COMMISSION. ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION THE COMMISSION IS
GRATEFUL FOR THE RESOURCES
IDENTIFIED TO SERVICE STUDENT
POPULATION THAT WE KNOW CASES
SO MANY ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES
AND THEIR PURSUIT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION INCLUDING A LACK OF
FAMILY RESOURCES TO DRAW UPON
AS THEY TRIED TO PAY FOR
COLLEGE. KEEP THAT EXPANDING
ACCESS TO AID FOR CURRENT AND A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH HAS BEEN A
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE AS
WELL EVIDENCED BY SEVERAL
EFFORTS IN RECENT YEARS TO
EXPAND ELIGIBILITY PERIODS FOR
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. AND WE'RE ALSO VERY
PROUD OF THE COMMISSION TO
ADMINISTER ARE CHEAP THE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING DR GRANT
PROGRAMS. FEDERALLY STATE AND
FUNDED PROGRAM THROUGH WHICH WE
PROVIDE FINANCIAL AID TO
ELIGIBLE FOSTER YOUTH. BY
TARGETING THESE RESOURCES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH WE CAN HELP MORE
BE STUDENTS AFFORD HIGHER
EDUCATION WITHOUT THE SAME.
LEVEL OF RELIANCE ON STUDENT
LOAN DEBT OR WORKING HOURS
BEYOND WHAT THE ADVISABLE FOR
STUDENTS A SUCCESS
ACADEMICALLY. AS IT RELATES TO
IMPLEMENTATION OF WE AT THE
COMMISSION WOULD KNOW THAT.
ABDICATE MASSE PROP HAT
TOPPLED DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES OUR PURPOSE IS. FIND
AN APPLICANT ALLEGED. FOR THE
CHEAPER PRO THAT I JUST
REFERENCED. THIS WOULD HELP US
IN THE PROCESS OF ALSO
CONFIRMING A FINANCIAL AID
APPLICANTS POTENTIAL
ELIGIBILITY FOR THIS PROPOSED
ENHANCE ACCESS AWARD WITHOUT
CREATING AN ADDITIONAL PROCESS
FOR STUDENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OKAY GET TO THE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS STARTING WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RACE. HERE WE GO.
SO WHAT THE QUESTION HAS TO DO
WITH AND IT WAS THE COMMENT WAS
MADE EARLIER BY HELLO THAT IT
IS MAKING A COMPLICATED SYSTEM
EVEN MORE COMPLICATED BUT AGAIN
IT IS SOMETHING THAT IS GOOD
FOR FROM FORMER FOSTER YOUTH SO
THE QUESTION IS HOW CAN WE
ENSURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
SIMPLIFY THE CAL GRANT SYSTEM.
WHILE MAINTAINING OUR FOCUS ON
GROUPS THAT DESERVE THE EXTRA
SUPPORT AND RESOURCES LIKE OUR
FOSTER YOUTH AND FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT MAJORITY LEADER- THE
PROPOSAL SKEWS ME ALSO I WANTED
TO SAY IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AS
TRAVIS. IT'S REALLY NICE YES
WELL I YOU'RE A LEADER- THIS
PROPOSAL IS BUILDING TO AN
EXISTING- AND AN EXISTING
NETWORK OF WILL WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THE COMPLEXION OF THE
SYSTEM. THIS PROPOSAL WAS
SIMPLY INCREASE THE MONEY THAT
STUDENTS HAD ALREADY RECEIVING
ANY SOME CASES IT'S CREATED IN
THE L. A. GRAN. ALREADY IN A
EXIST FROM SO LIKE COCHRAN
STUDENTS THERE WAS EVEN ACCESS
AWARD ALREADY THAT WOULD JUST
SEE THEIR AMOUNT INCREASED HIRE
SOMEONE WOULD CALL AND SEE
STUDENTS AND COMPANIES
STUDENTS. LET'S SEE- AND YOUR
WHAT UP TO SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THANK YOU. MR MEDINA THANK YOU
MR REPORT- BASED ON DATA FROM A-
I SEE SEE YOU THAT THEY HAVE
RECEIVED FROM C. SAID THERE ARE
CURRENTLY TWO HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE. CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH ATTENDING PRIVATE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS. WHO
WON'T QUALIFY UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL SINCE
IT'S OF LIMITED IN SCOPE OF
STUDENTS ATTENDING. UNITY
COLLEGE THIS OR THE UC THIS
PROPOSAL MERITS LAST YEAR'S.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT IT FROM THE
PROPOSAL EXCLUDING THE
OTHERWISE I STUDENTS WHO ATTEND
A PRIVATE A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
AND- WHY HAS IT BEEN A- DECLINE
TO INCLUDE. THE STUDENTS IN THE.
SURE MAKING YOUR QUESTION BROWN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO I
NEEDED TO AS A MY COLLEAGUE
FEDERAL THIS A AND EXPAND OF
EXISTING- THAT WE SEE AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE EXIST STUDENTS
WITH DEPENDENTS ACT PRO. SO I
DID INDICATE THAT THEY JUST
YEARS AFTER FOR ON THAT AND TO
NEARING PROGRAM EXIST- AS A
SIMPLE IN THE NINETEEN BUDGET.
ANY ANY OTHER CRIME. FROM
ANYONE ELSE. IT IS NOT AYE I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT I
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CONTINUED PRIVATIZATION AND
FOSTER YOU BUT THE PROPOSAL
WHICH EXCLUDES STUDENTS
ATTENDING PRIVATE NONPROFIT
INSTITUTIONS- TO ME IS
CERTAINLY NOT EQUITABLE AND I
BELIEVE THAT IF WE WANT TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS IN THE HIGHEST
NEED WE MUST DO SUIT DO SO
CONSISTENTLY ACROSS THE BOARD.
THANK YOU YEAH. AND I WOULD
JUST ADD- MISTER MEDINA THAT
EARLIER WE TALKED ABOUT TWO
THINGS ONE WE'RE LEAVING IT TOO
MANY STUDENTS WHO ARE QUALIFIED
ELIGIBLE IN THE DARK BECAUSE
THE COMPETITIVE ONE AND THEN
IT'S SUPER COMPLICATED AND SELL
THIS JUST I KNOW FOSTER YOUTH
ARE NEAR AND DEAR TO OUR HEART
JUST LIKE STUDENTS WITH PARENTS
ARE BUT FOR TWO YEARS IN A ROW.
WE'RE MAKING THE COMPLICATED
CAL GRANT SAYS EVEN MORE
COMPLICATED AND NEXT YEAR IT
WILL BE ANOTHER FOR THE STUDENT
STUDENTS YOU KNOW- YOU KNOW WHO
HAVE COME FROM A DIFFERENT
BACKGROUND OR DO YOU KNOW WHAT
WHATEVER WE WANT TO FOCUS ON
OTHER LCF PLUS TYPE STUDENTS-
AND SO YOU KNOW WE CAN CONTINUE
TO DO THIS OR WE CAN JUST I
THINK CO MINGLE THIS MONEY AND
GIVE AND HAVE A SIMPLER SYSTEM
AND PICK YOU KNOW MORE WINNERS
THROUGH THE TRIED AND TRUE
PROCESS WHICH IS. INCOME YOUR
GRADES AND YOUR YOUR YOUR YOUR
ABILITY TO IT TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN HIGHER EDUCATION
SO I THINK THAT WE SHOULD TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT AT THAT FOCUSING
ON CONSOLIDATING ALL THESE-
POTS OF MONEY SO WHILE I DO
HAVE THAT BIG PLACE IN MY HEART
FOR FOSTER YOUTH I DON'T KNOW
IF THIS MAKES SENSE WITH THAT.
ARE SCARCE GENERAL FUND-
RESOURCES SO. FURTHER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BY ABOUT US. YEAH HAVING
GROWN UP- NEXT TO- FOSTER YOUTH
THEY ARE MY NEIGHBORS TOOK ON
FOSTER YOU THREE YEARS- I
UNDERSTAND THEIR DIFFICULTIES
OR FINANCIAL DIFFICULTIES ONCE
YOU KNOW THEY TURN EIGHTEEN
YEARS OLD- THEY DON'T HAVE
PARENTS AND WE- AS A SOCIETY AS
CALIFORNIA NEED TO STEP UP TO
THE PLATE TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING THEM WITH THE
FOUNDATION. WITH THE TOOLS-
WITH THE RESOURCES TO BE
SUCCESSFUL I WOULD AGREE WITH
MR MEDINA AND NOT- IT I WOULD
LOVE FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO
CONSIDER EXPANDING THIS- FOR
PRIVATE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. AS A YOUTH AND
PARTICULARLY A FOSTER YOUTH
WHEN YOU TURN EIGHTEEN YEARS
OLD YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
DIRECTION AND I STILL EVEN
THOUGH OUR EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
FOSTER YOUTH ARE ADULTS I STILL
LOOK AT THEM AS GROWING
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE YOUNG. AND
THAT MAKING THAT DECISION ON
WHERE TO GO TO COLLEGE IS A BIG
DEAL AND THEY'RE LOOKING OUT
WHAT FITS THEM WHAT FITS THEIR
NEEDS AS A PERSON AND SOMETIMES
THAT'S OFFERED BY THE PRIVATE
UNIVERSITY OR NONPROFIT
UNIVERSITY SO I WOULD THINK
THAT REALLY TO GIVE THEM THE
FOUNDATIONAL START THAT THEY
NEED WE SHOULD EXPAND THE
ELIGIBILITY THERE. JUST MY
COMMENT THERE. I DO HAVE A
QUESTION WHAT ABOUT CAL GRANT
ELIGIBILITY FOR FOSTER YOUTH-
WHO THE ONES ARE NOT SUCCESSFUL
IN SECURING COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT AWARDS WOULD THEY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS AWARD OR IS
IT LIMITED TO THOSE WHO RECEIVE
A CAL GRANT A. B. OR C. MMHM.
I'M A STUDENT WHO RECEIVED A
CARBON ABC EITHER AT THE
COMPETITIVE OR THE ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAM WILL QUALIFY FOR THE
SOMEONE. SO I CAN I JUMP IN
YEAH I THINK THAT AISES YOUR
ISSUE BECAUSE SO MANY OF OUR
FOSTER YOUTH HAVE. COUNTLESS
CHALLENGES WHEN THEY'RE
EIGHTEEN SO ARE THEY GOING TO
AS MR O'DONNELL SAID NO AND
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL CLASSROOM TO
FILL UP THAT FAST SO WHEN
THEY'RE SEVENTEEN. THIRD
FOCUSING WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO
SIX SURVIVING WHEN THEY TURN
EIGHTEEN AND AGE OUT. SO THE
ODDS ARE THE STUDENTS. MAYBE A
COUPLE YEARS LATER FIGURE IT
OUT OKAY I WANNA APPLY FOR A
CAL GRANT NOW THEY GET IN THIS.
POOL WHERE THERE ARE CHANCES
ARE ONE IN FIVE AND SO THE
STUDENTS WHO WE THERE'S A FEW
STUDENTS TO GET IN. WE'RE
GIVING THEM MORE SUPPORT WHICH
THEY DESPERATELY NEED BECAUSE
THEY'RE THERE FOR THEIR NEED TO
PAY FOR HOUSING AND EVERYTHING
ELSE IS TREMENDOUS WE GET THAT.
BUT BY DOING THAT YOU'RE GIVING
THE FEW. BUT A GREATER
OPPORTUNITY BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE
LEAVING OUT THE MASSES WHO
NEVER EVEN GOT THEIR FOOT THE
DOOR IN THE FIRST PLACE SO.
IT'S A IT'S A BALANCING ACT AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK THAT WE NEED
TO DO WE HAVE YOU KNOW UP
SCARCE RESOURCES WE CAN MAKE
THAT THE WISEST CHOICE. AND SO
I THINK THAT THAT BRINGS UP THE
POINT THAT WE NEED TO EVALUATE.
SO JUST TO CLARIFY THAT MR
GALLAGHER. RIGHT SO IT'S IF
YOU'VE GOTTEN IS THE BEST A
GOOD GALLOP MAKE. SO JUST TO
CLARIFY IT ON THAT IS ONLY IF
YOU AB SEE THE UROLOGY FOR THIS
RIGHT YOU CAN'T OR COMPETITIVE.
OUR COMPETITORS RIGHT. YES
THAT'S CORRECT THE STUDENT
NEEDS TO GET A CALL GRANT IN
ORDER TO GET AN ACCESS SOMEONE.
WE JUST POINT OUT THAT- FOSTER
AND KAREEM ALLSTATE GRAHAM. THE
FORMAT GRANDFATHER YOU'D
STUDENTS- HAVE ADDITIONAL TIME
TO APPLY FOR AN ENTITLEMENT
COCHRAN- AND WE UNDERSTAND WE
RECOGNIZE THE MANY STUDENTS TO
STRUGGLE TO WALK TOWARDS THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE. I AM
SO THIS ADDITIONAL GRANT WILL
SERVE THAT PURPOSE. AND I DID
HAVE ONE ONE LAST QUESTION- ARE
ADOPTED FOSTER YOU INCLUDED AN
EXPANDED CAL GRANT AND TRY TO
MELD ABILITY AUTHORIZED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN.
FOR THE COPPER THEY ACCESS OUR
WATER. I'M SORRY IF I DON'T
UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION I
REMEMBER SO I'M IF YOU'RE IN
ADOPTED FOSTER YOUTH DO YOU
STILL QUALIFY. I WILL DEFER TO
MY COLLEAGUE IN C. SACK- JAKE.
THANKS THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER THERE
ARE SPECIFIC- UP FOR DATE- AND
THAT IS THAT IS HEAT WITH THE
STATUS OF THE FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH IN WHICH THEY NEEDED TO
HAVE TO BE IN THE FOSTER
SYSTEM. THAT'S THE DATA THAT'S-
THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER THIS
IDENTIFIED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND THAT WE USE
THAT THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
FOR PURPOSES OF DETERMINING
WHETHER A STUDENT MIGHT FIT-
ELIGIBILITY FOR CHEAP YOU GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT COULD ALREADY
CURRENTLY SERVES FORMER- AND
CURRENT FOSTER YOUTH STUDENTS.
SO IN THAT PARTICULAR SITUATION
IT WOULD BE DEPENDENT ON THE
AGE AT WHICH THEY WERE ADOPTED
OUT OF THE FOSTER SYSTEM. AND
WE HAVE A AND APPROXIMATELY.
APPROXIMATELY WHAT AGE. I
BELIEVE THAT IT'S EITHER THEIR
SIXTEENTH BIRTHDAY- BUT I CAN
GET BACK TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF
WITH THE- THE SPECIFIC- H. TIME
FRAMES THAT IS THE ISSUE WITH
THE ELIGIBILITY DEFINITION THAT
A DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES- VERIFIED SPORTS. I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU. WITH
YOUR HAND MISTER LEE NOW. OKAY
MISTER DONNA JUST ACAR WITH
REGARD TO THIS- FOSTER YOUTH
AND REALLY I THINK THE GOAL
HERE THIS MONIES TO ENSURE
THEIR SUCCESS. AND THIS IS
SOMETHING I SAW MY OWN
CLASSROOMS HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER
OFTEN SENIORS THE GRADUATE AND
THE KIND OF PUT ON A BOAT OUT
THERE WITH NO SALE. RIGHT AND
SO I THINK GET A MONEY IS
BECAUSE PART OF THE ANSWER BUT
IT'S ALSO STRONG PROGRAMS THAT
ASSIST STUDENTS THAT FIND
THEMSELVES IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE
HERE'S ORGANIZATIONS DOWN IN LA
UNITED FRIENDS THE CHILDREN IS
VERY ACTIVE ORGANIZATION THAT
HELPS KIDS TRANSITIONING OUT OF
FOSTER YOU. SO HOPE SOME POINT
WE WOULD ALSO HOW DO YET YOU
KNOW TO LEVERAGES. MONEY AND
ENSURE THAT HE GETS. IN THAT
GETS USERS. TO SECURE. SUCCESS
I DON'T KNOW THE JUST HANDING
IS THE STUDENT MONEY OR OR
MAYBE. IT PARTNERING WITH
CERTAIN ORGANIZATIONS THAT DO
OFFER TRANSITIONAL HOUSING WE
DON'T WANT TO LONG BEACH- AND
THEY TEACH TO NEAR THE LIFE
SKILLS OF BANKING SAID
RECEIVING- THIS IS PUT THEIR
POST HIGH SCHOOL EXPERIENCE
GETTING HIM INTO SCHOOL HAVE A
LOT OF SUCCESS UNITED FRIENDS
THE CHILDREN TO US. I'M SURE
THERE ARE OTHERS OUT THERE
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ENOUGH OF
THEM. BUT WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT MONEY TO INCENTIVIZE
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THAT. TO
PICK UP MORE CLIENTELE. TO
ASSIST FOSTER USED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL SO DID JUST I JUST
THAT'S MORE THAT'S BROADER
TOPIC THAN TODAY BUT- I THINK
PEOPLE SHOULD. BE THINKING.
ABOUT THINGS MORE THAN JUST
HANDING THEM BRANDS. BUT GEE
HOW DO WE WANT TO HANDLE GRANT
HOW THEY SUCCESSFULLY MANEUVER
THROUGH THE SYSTEM IN LIFE. AND
BUILDING THOSE THAT NECESSARY.
SKILL SET TO DO SO. BUT HE-
OKAY THANK YOU THIS ISSUE WILL
BE HELD OPEN. THING NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- NEXT
ISSUE THE CAL GRANT DELIVERY
SYSTEM. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
IS SEVEN HUNDRED NINETEEN
THOUSAND I'M GOING GENERAL FUND
TO SUPPORT THE FINAL PHASE OF
THE GRAND DELIVERY SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION PROJECT. AND I'M
GOING MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION
COSTS THIS PROJECT IS SCHEDULED
TO BE FULLY IMPLEMENTED BY
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU L. L.
LOOKING AT THE TABLE AND TO TOP
OF PAGE TWELVE OF YOUR HEARING
AND THAT PROVIDES A LITTLE MORE
DETAIL ON HOW THE ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DECIDED. TO PLAY
ONE POINT ONE MILLION WOULD BE
SPENT A ONE TIME BASIS FOR
PROJECT CONSULTANTS TO FINISH
THE MAINTENANCE OPERATIONS
PHASE OF THIS PROJECT AN
INITIAL SEVEN HUNDRED NINETEEN
THOUSAND COMBINED WOULD BE
PROVIDED AN ONGOING BASIS FOR
CERTAIN RECURRING HARDWARE AND
SOFTWARE COSTS. SINCE THE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR THIS
PROJECT THE SUBMITTED IN THE
FALL THE COMPLETION DATE HAS
CHANGED SOMEWHAT. WAS ONE FROM
NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR TO APRIL
OF THE SPRING IS YOU NEED
COMMISSION HAS RECENTLY
SUBMITTED A SPECIAL PROJECT
REPORT TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY AFTER
FLOOD SCHEDULE CHANGE. OUR
OFFICE EXPECTS TO RECEIVE THIS
SPR FROM CITY IN THE COMING
WEEKS AND ONCE WE RECEIVE IT
WILL REVIEW THE INFORMATION ME
CHAPTER STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU STATE
COMMISSION. THANK YOU CHECK-
MCCARTY JAKE BRUNNER STUDENT
AID COMMISSION AND THE
COMMISSION REQUESTED THESE
FUNDS FOR THE FINAL PHASE OF
DEVELOPMENT AND THE FOLLOWING
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS OF
OUR GREAT DELIVERY SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION PROJECT OR AS WE
FONDLY REFER TO IT GSM AND I'M
PLEASED TO REPORT THAT THIS IS
THE COMMISSION SPINAL FUNDING
REQUEST ANTICIPATED FOR THIS
PROJECT. AS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA MATERIALS THIS PROJECT
HAS BEEN A HIGH PRIORITY FOR
THE COMMISSION DUE TO THE
VOLUME AND SENSITIVITY OF THE
APPLICATIONS THAT WE PROCESS
EACH YEAR ANNUALLY THE
COMMISSION RECEIVED AS MANY AS
TWO MILLION APPLICATIONS AND
APPROPRIATES TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDS.
AND PRIOR TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE GSM OF THE COMMISSION WITH
USING A NINETEEN SYSTEM THAT
WAS MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS OLD
TO DO ALL OF THIS- SO YOU CAN
CONSIDER THAT SIGNIFICANT RISKS
THAT ARE POSED BY OUTAGES OF
THE SYSTEM LET ALONE- ANY. SORT
OF A SECURITY BREACH. AB START
HAS ALREADY SEEN MANY OF ITS BE.
THE BY. OUR CORE YOU. IN THOSE
CRITICALLY ARE STUDENTS. THE
NEW BUT GRANTS FOR STUDENTS WAS
LAUNCHED IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AND SERVICE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS APPLYING FOR IT. YOUR
CHEN DIDN'T MATERIAL
ALTERNATIVES WILL BE. PROVIDED
INCLUDING ALLOWING STUDENTS TO
USE MOBILE DEVICES AND OTHER
WEB BROWSERS TO ACCESS OUR
PLATFORM. WHICH WAS NOT
PREVIOUSLY POSSIBLE. USER
INTERFACE IS ALSO NOW MORE
INTUITIVE AND PROVIDES STUDENTS
WITH EASIER TO UNDERSTAND
DETAILS. ABOUT THE STATUS OF
THEIR CAL GRANT AND A TO DO
LIST- TO HELP GUIDE THEM
THROUGH ANY REMAINING STEPS. IN
ADDITION A WEB GRANTS FOR
STUDENTS THE COMMISSION IS ALSO
LAUNCHED WHAT BRANDS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD
PROGRAM. AND OUR CHIEF YOU
GRANT PROGRAM FOR FOSTER YOUTH
STUDENTS. THERE WAS A DELAY OF
A FEW MONTHS TO ALLOW FOR MORE
THOROUGH TESTING DURING THIS
PERIOD. TO ENSURE THAT THE
RELEASE OF THE INSTITUTIONAL
FACING A SIDE OF THIS PROJECT.
WAS AS EFFECTIVE AND BUG FREE
AS POSSIBLE. AS NOTED BY LA YOU
KNOW WE ANTICIPATE LAUNCHING
WEB GRANTS. FOR STUDENTS IN
APRIL OF THIS YEAR. AND I'M
JOINT BY VICTIMS. CHIEF AND FOR
OFFICER BERMAN- BANGING. WHO
WILL- JOIN ME IN. ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU. OKAY
MR GALLAGHER. YES SO THIS LOOKS
LIKE ONE OF THOSE UNFORTUNATELY
RARE EXAMPLES OF AID AND I. T.
PROJECT THAT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED- AND
SO I CONGRATULATE YOU GUYS-
THIS IS IT'S GOOD TO SEE THIS
IS GOING TO BE THAT LAST
FUNDING WE'RE GETTING THIS
COMPLETE- ONE QUESTION I HAD IS
SO- I BELIEVE WAS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN- YOU KNOW THE- C. SACK
WAS. IDENTIFIED AS A VOTER
REGISTRATION AGENCY BASED ON A
FEDERAL COURT RULING- AND- I
THINK LAST BUDGET YOU GUYS IT
ASKS FOR FUNDING TO HELP STATE
FUNDING TO HELP WITH. OBVIOUSLY
THE OUTRAGE AND- EVERYTHING
THAT GOES WITH BEING A
DESIGNATED VOTER REGISTRATION
AGENCY- I THINK SOME OF THE
THOUGHT WOULD BE LIKE YOU KNOW
WHY NOT SEEK FEDERAL FUNDS
SINCE THIS IS A FEDERAL ROLE IN
YOUR FEDERAL FUNDS TO COVER THE
COST OF THAT- BUT MY QUESTION
WOULD BE ARE. AS ANY OF THE ONE
TIME OR ONGOING FUNDING THAT
WORD. THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING- THAT WERE. DESIGNATING
TOWARDS THIS I. T. SYSTEM AND
FINISHING THAT IS ANY OF THAT
GOING TO BE MOVED OVER- AS
COSTS FOR THE VOTER.
REGISTRATION AGENCIES FUNDING.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER- AS
OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE L. A. O.
NOTED I'M IN YOUR AGENDA
MATERIALS THERE IS A BREAKDOWN
OF THE ANTICIPATED COSTS- THAT
ARE ALL INCLUDE THE ON GOING
EXPENSES THAT WILL OCCUR. AND
ARE JEDIISM PROJECT- HELPED US
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT ALL OF
THE STATE FINANCIAL AID-
PROGRAMS THAT WERE AUTHORIZED
TO ADMINISTER SO- I DON'T I
THINK THAT THE IT'S WOVEN
THROUGH ALL OF THOSE PROGRAMS
IS THIS MECHANISM FOR WHICH I'M
WERE CONTACTED ABOUT VOTER
REGISTRATION- BUT I'LL DEFER TO
MY COLLEAGUE- GREATER- TO SEE
IF HE MIGHT HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
INFORMATION TO SHARE WITH YOU
ABOUT HOW THAT- AND WE ARE A-
COMPLIANCE PIECE FITS IN WITH
THE COSTS ASSOCIATED HERE BUT-
I THINK REALLY THEY'RE- THEY'RE
MORE REFLECTIVE OF. HARDWARE
CLOUD SERVERS SOFTWARE LICENSES
AND THE TYPE OF THINGS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH- DELIVERY OF
ITS TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM. BUT OF
AUTHENTIC BURGER. GOOD MORNING
IN CHAIR AND MEMBERS IS BAY
CHIEF. OFFICER CALIFORNIANS IT
COMMISSION. YEAH REGARDING AND
WE ARE A I THINK RIGHT NOW MOST
OF THE COMPLIANCE IS MET
MANUALLY- BUT ONCE FULLER MAIN
CORE FUNCTIONALITY. OF GSM IS
COMPLETED. WE WILL BE LOOKING
INTO IMPLEMENTING NPR RAY BUT-
DEFINITELY AND WILL REQUIRE
SOME FUNDING. IN ORDER TO MAKE
SOME CHANGES THERE. OF THESE
FINDINGS WERE. MOSTLY FOR
UPGRADING THE EXISTING GRANTED
THE PRE SYSTEM AND MAKING SURE
THE STUDENTS HAVE PROPER ACCESS
AND DIGITAL SYSTEMS ARE WORKING
UP SYSTEM ARE UP AND RUNNING
TWENTY FOUR BY SEVEN. OKAY SO
JUST TO CLARIFY THIS FUNNY
REQUEST IS JUST FOR DOING THE
UPDATE- TO THE SYSTEM THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT AND IS NOT GOING
TOWARDS N. DRA. THAT IS CORRECT
OKAY AND THEN ARE YOU GUYS
PURSUING ANY FEDERAL FUNDS TO
MEET COMPLIANCE SO THAT. WE
HAVE NOT BEEN DIRECTLY AT THE
SKI NAY COMMISSION BUT- I DON'T
KNOW IF OUR PARTNERS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MIGHT
HAVE- ANY ANYTHING FURTHER THEY
pFEDERAL FUNDS AND CAN BE
UTILIZED BY THE STATE. HI
BRIANNA FRIENDS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THAT HAS NOT BEEN
SOMETHING THAT OUR OFFICEIS
LOOKED INTO YOU- HOWEVER TO THE
EXTENT NEEDED WE'D BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO. WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
YOU NEED COMMISSION. ON TO IT
TO ASSIST THEM THERE. SOUNDS
LIKE NOW RIGHT NOW OKAY.
FURTHER QUESTIONS ABOUT NOW
OKAY THANK YOU QUESTIONS ON
THIS ITEM. SING NINE THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE WILL ADDRESS
LATER IN THE SUB COMMITTEE
PROCESS WILL HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN A NEXT ISSUE CALFRESH
ACCESS FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS.
OKAY IN MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME MY NAME'S ALEXIS
FERNANDES AND I'M THE CHIEF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NUTRITION BRANCH
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES MY BRANCH OVERSEES THE
ADMINISTRATION OF SEVEN FEDERAL
NUTRITION PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
SEVERAL STATE FUNDED PROGRAM.
IMPORTANTLY WE OVERSEE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE STATE OF
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OR SNAP
KNOWN AS CALFRESH IN
CALIFORNIA. PUBLIC HEALTH
QUESTION NUTRITION BRANCH HAS
LONG PRIORITIZED CALIFORNIA'S
PARTICIPATION AMONG COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND TODAY I'M GOING TO
SPEAK TO A FEW OF OUR MORE
RECENT EFFORTS IN THIS AREA-
BUT FIRST I WANT TO TOUCH ON
THE POLICY CHALLENGE THAT
COLLEGE STUDENTS FACE. IN BEING
THE TRUMP ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH.
FEDERAL PROGRAM RULES GENERALLY
EXCLUDE COLLEGE STUDENTS FROM
SNAP ELIGIBILITY UNLESS THEY
ARE EMPLOYED AT LEAST TWENTY
HOURS ON AVERAGE PER WEEK FOR
ME AN EXCEPTION FROM THE RULE.
SUCH AS BEING APPROVED FOR OR
ANTICIPATING PARTICIPATION IN
WORK STUDY. ATTENDING A SCHOOL
AS PART OF AN EMPLOYMENT AND
TRAINING PROGRAM FOR RECEIVING
ANOTHER CAL WORKS WHEN THE
BENEFIT INCLUDING A CAMERA.
THIS RULE COMMONLY KNOWN AS THE
CALFRESH STUDENT ELIGIBILITY
RULE IS LONGSTANDING AND HAS
ITS ROOTS IN A NOW OUTDATED
ASSUMPTION ABOUT THE STUDENT
EXPERIENCE. MAINLY THAT
STUDENTS INCOME AND RESOURCES
MIGHT BE TEMPORARILY LOW BUT
THAT MOST HAVE PARENTS OR OTHER
RELATIVES WHO WILL ENSURE THEY
THEY DO NOT GO HUNGRY. IN AN
ATTEMPT TO PREVENT UPPER MIDDLE
INCOME FAMILIES FROM RECEIVING
THE BACK STEPS BACK IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES. CONGRESS
ESTABLISH A SPECIAL SET OF
ELIGIBILITY RULES THAT PREVENT
MANY STUDENTS FROM ACCESSING.
THE CONTROL NUTRITION BENEFITS
AND BY NO MEANS OF REPRESENTS.
THE EXPERIENCE OF MANY STUDENTS
TODAY. SO TO ADDRESS CHALLENGE
ALONG WITH OUR PARTNERS
INCLUDING CLIENT ADVOCATES
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
COUNTY AND OTHER- GOVERNMENT
PARTNERS INCLUDING AS THE SACK
WE HAVE INVESTED SIGNIFICANT
TIME AND ENERGY INTO ADDRESSING
STUDENT ELIGIBILITY AND
MAXIMIZING ACCESS. TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE WITHIN THE
BOUNDARIES OF THAT FEDERAL
RULE. AS I MENTIONED I'LL
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF OUR MORE
RECENT EFFORTS IN THIS AREA. TO
UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE OF THE
PROCESS THE PROBLEM WE RECENTLY
ISSUED IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
PUBLIC POSTSECONDARY SEGMENTS
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
ESTIMATING THE GAP BETWEEN THE
NUMBER OF LIKELY CALIFORNIA
LEGIBLE STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
ACTUALLY RECEIVING CALFRESH. WE
ALSO PUT THEM RECOMMENDATIONS
BOARD AIMED AT CLOSING THAT GAP
WITH OUR PARTNERS. WELL THERE
ARE A LOT OF DATA COPIER.
MENTION NOT THE REPORT
ESTIMATES THAT IN THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN SCHOOL YEAR THE
AVERAGE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
RECEIVING CALFRESH WAS JUST
OVER A HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND AND THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF STUDENTS LIKELY ELIGIBLE
FELL SOMEWHERE BETWEEN. JUST
OVER FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
JUST UNDER SIX HUNDRED AND
NINETY THOUSAND AND AGAIN THAT
RANGE IS LARGE BECAUSE OF SOME
SIGNIFICANT CARDIAC WITH
AVAILABLE DATA. THE BILL WORK
IN BETTER UNDERSTANDING GAP.
PARTNERED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
POLICY LATIN OR C. PL TO
CONDUCT MORE ANALYSIS BY CPR
WAS PART OF OUR REPORT
WORKGROUP AND WITNESS THE
DIFFICULTY WE HAD IN TRYING TO
ESTIMATE THE NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS. THROUGH DATA SHARING
AGREEMENTS YOU CAN TELL WILL
ANALYZE ELIGIBILITY TAKE UP AND
IMPACTS OF CALIFORNIA'S FOR
STUDENTS WILL BE LINKING DE
IDENTIFIED ADMINISTRATIVE.
ADMINISTRATIVE DATA AT THE
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT LEVEL DATA-
AND IT WILL PROVIDE MORE
TESTING OF THE NUMBERS WERE
ELIGIBLE WE ALSO THINK THIS
INFORMATION WILL BE USEFUL AND
TARGETING REACH- OUR PARTNERS
TO PROMOTE CALFRESH I TAKE UP
WE'RE WORKING WITH C. SACK THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THE UC
SYSTEM THE FINAL IDEA SHARING
AGREEMENTS AND BE ABLE TO
FACILITATE THIS PROJECT. WELL
UNDERSTANDING THAT DATA IS
IMPORTANT THE RULE ITSELF IS
THE BARRIER TO ACCESS SO
RECOGNIZING THIS CONGRESS
RECENTLY ACTED TO TEMPORARILY
EXPANDS ELIGIBILITY IN RESPONSE
TO THE PANDEMIC EMERGENCY. WE
HAVEN'T. LAUNCHED AN EFFORT TO
ROLL OUT THESE CHANGES QUICKLY.
INFORM NEWLY ELIGIBLE STUDENTS
OF THE CHANGE AND FACILITATE
THEIR APPLICATION FOR
COCKROACH. THE CHANGES EXTENDED
TO LARGE GROUPS. THOSE. WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR A WORK STUDY. AND
THOSE HAVE AN X. FAMILY
CONTRIBUTION OF ZERO DOLLARS
ASK CALCULATED BY THE FACT. WE
ESTIMATE FOR THE CURRENT
ACADEMIC YEAR THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS TO HAVE A
ZERO P. F. SEAT AND AT LEAST A
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR WORK
STUDY. AND I'LL NOTE THAT THERE
IS SOME OVERLAP BETWEEN THESE
TWO GROUPS. ARE THESE CHANGES
ARE. TO EXPAND ELIGIBILITY WILL
BE IN EFFECT AT LEAST THIRTY
DAYS AFTER THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IS LIFTED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL SO. VERY LIKELY
FOR QUITE SOME TIME. AND WE
HAVE LAUNCHED A COUPLE MAJOR
OUTREACH EFFORTS. TO REACH THEM
AND MAKE THEM AWARE OF THE
CHANGE SO IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE STOCK WE WILL BE CONDUCTING
OUTREACH TO ALL THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ZERO DOLLARS EST
STUDENTS. AND OUR INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER EDUCATION WILL BE
CONDUCTING OUTREACH TO WORK
STUDY ELIGIBLE STUDENTS. OTHER
STATEWIDE OUTREACH CAMPAIGN
STARTED THIS WEEK YESTERDAY O
BE EXACT. THE OUTCOMES OF THE
SHORT TERM CHANGE CURRENT FORM
OF COURSE LONGER. TERM CHANGES
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL. THAT'S
FROM HER CHANGE TO THE FEDERAL
STUDENT ELIGIBILITY RULES. WE
CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT EFFORTS
AIMED AT MAXIMISING
PARTICIPATION SO I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE ONE UPCOMING
EFFORT RELATED TO CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION. FEDERAL
REGULATIONS ALLOW FOR STUDENTS
WERE TAKING COURSES THAT ARE
PART OF THE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM TO BE EXEMPT
FROM THE RULE. OUR PARTNERS IN
NEW YORK STATE RECENTLY USED
THIS REGULATION TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS. AT LEAST ON
THEIR MODEL WE ARE ACTIVELY
ENGAGED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO IDENTIFY
WHICH OF THEIR PROGRAMS NEAT
FEDERAL DEFINITION. AND I WHICH
STUDENTS ARE CURRENTLY ENROLLED
SO THAT WE CAN REACH OUT TO
THEM AND LET THEM KNOW ABOUT
THIS NEW EXEMPTION- THEY MAY
HAVE ACQUIRED FOR CALIFORNIA
BEFORE AND THEN DETERMINE
INELIGIBLE THIS EXPANDED POLICY.
WORK MAY MAKE THEM ELIGIBLE NOW.
THE COMMUNITY CALL ESTIMATED
THIS CHANGE COULD IMPACT THE
MINIMUM OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS BUT
ACTUALLY UP TO A MILLION. I
WILL BE WORKING WITH THEM ON
HOW BEST TO IDENTIFY INFORM THE
STUDENTS. WILL SIMULTANEOUSLY
DEVELOP GUIDANCE FOR A COUNTY
PARTNERS TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION. AND WE'RE
HOPING THAT ARE TO BE ON TRACK
TO IMPLEMENT THIS CHANGE AHEAD
OF THE FALL TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TURN. FIVE THE LET ME JUST WRAP
UP BY THINKING THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT TO PREVENTING
EXPERIENCE OF HUNGER AMONG
COLLEGE STUDENTS. WE'VE SEEN
QUITE A FEW INVESTMENTS OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS. AND TO OUR
PARTNERS TO ENGAGE WITH US
REGULARLY- INCREASED THE
SACROILIAC FROM IN JUST A
MOMENT. AND OF COURSE MY TEAM
WAS WATCHING FROM HOME- I HAVE
DILIGENTLY FACILITATING THESE
PARTNERSHIPS AND EFFORTS. ARE
SURE TO QUITE A BIT OF
INFORMATION SO I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AS ONE OF THE-
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
MR NEED COMMISSION. OKAY GOOD
MORNING JERRY MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MARLENE GARCIA I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION THANK YOU FOR
INVITING THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING TO HELP
MORE LOW INCOME COLLEGE
STUDENTS ACCESS CALFRESH
BENEFITS ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS. CRISIS AS YOU KNOW
STUDENT HUNGER IS REAL ON ALL
CAMPUSES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
IN ANY GIVEN MONTH ONE IN THREE
STUDENTS REPORTS EXPERIENCING
FOOD INSECURITY BASED ON OUR
MOST RECENT. SURVEY AND IN THE
WAKE OF THE CODE NINETEEN
CRISIS THE PROBLEM HAS ONLY
WORSENED. NO CAMPUS IS IMMUNE
FROM THE PROBLEM OF STUDENT
HUNGER ALL THE SEGMENTS UCCS
YOU INDEPENDENT COLLEGES
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
STRUGGLING TO SUPPORT THE
GROWING NUMBER OF STUDENTS WITH
FOOD INSECURITY. THEY SET UP
FOOD PANTRIES BASIC NEEDS
CENTERS AND ARE WORKING WITH
COUNTY OFFICES TO HELP STUDENTS
APPLY FOR AND RECEIVE CALFRESH
BENEFITS. THE STATE HAS ALSO
INVESTED VITAL RESOURCES TO
HELP INSTITUTIONS SUPPORT THEIR
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS BUT THE
NEED CONTINUES TO EXCEED
AVAILABLE CAMPUS RESOURCES AND
ACCESS TO CALFRESH CONTINUES TO
BE A CHALLENGE FOR. MOST
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO ARE
POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE. THE
COMMISSION IS COMMITTED TO
FINDING NEW WAYS TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA POSTSECONDARY
STUDENTS BY IDENTIFYING
SOLUTIONS TO FILL THE GAP IN
THERE AND BETHANY. NEEDS I'M
TACKLING FOOD INSECURITY FOR
COLLEGE STUDENTS IS ESSENTIAL
TO HELP THEM PERSISTENCE.
EXCEEDING COLLEGE. CALFRESH
PROGRAM DOES ALL COULD READ
THAT CAN HELP OFFICE THE FOOD
COSTS FOR STUDENTS YET WE KNOW
THAT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
LIKELY ELIGIBLE BUT ARE NOT
APPLYING. SO IN SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY THE COMMISSION
CONVENED A CALFRESH WORK GROUP
TO EXAMINE HOW TO SIMPLIFY AND
INCREASE THE COLLEGE STUDENT UP
TAKE. A FINANCIALLY BENEFITS.
THE WORKGROUP INCLUDES ALL THE
MAJOR STAKEHOLDERS- WHO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE FROM WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE AND- POLICY
ADVOCATES OUTSIDE THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDING POLICY
EXPERTS FOR BOTH SOCIAL
SERVICES AND HIGHER EDUCATION
SECTOR. AS NOTED EARLIER BY
ALEXIS FERNANDEZ THE PROGRAM
WAS DESIGNED ORIGINALLY TO KEEP
COLLEGE STUDENTS FROM ACCESSING
FROM ACCESSING FOOD BENEFITS
WELL IT SUCCEEDED. ONLY 18%
231% BASED ON THE ESTIMATES OF
STUDENTS ARE LIKELY ELIGIBLE-
ARE ARE ARE ONLY THAT THOSE 18%
231% ARE ACTUALLY RECEDING CAL
CRAP THAT AFFECTS. SO THE
PROGRAM IS FALLING HOLY SHORT
AND IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT TAKING FULL ADVANTAGE
OF THIS FEDERAL RESOURCE THAT
IS AVAILABLE TO OUR STUDENTS.
SO THE GOAL OF THE WORKGROUP IS
TO STREAMLINE THE SYSTEM BY
WHICH STUDENTS ACCESS- CALFRESH
BENEFITS. THERE ARE NUMEROUS
COMPLEX RULES AS ALEXIS ALLUDED
TO EARLIER THAT PERTAIN ONLY TO
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND THESE
RULES WHICH DO NOT APPLY TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. KLEIST MAKE IT
CHALLENGING NOT JUST FOR
STUDENTS TO ENROLL BUT ALSO FOR
COUNTY ELIGIBILITY WORKERS TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM. AND
THIS HAS CONTRIBUTED TO THE
BOTTOM BACK AND APPROVING.
COLLEGE STUDENT APPLICATIONS.
SO THERE ARE SOME. THAT THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF COLLEGE YOU TO
APPLY CREEK FOR CAL OWN ABOUT
THREE SEVEN. ARE COMPARED 260%
FOR THE GENERAL PUBLIC. NOW AS
YOU KNOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS TAKEN A SIGNIFICANT STEP OF
TEMPORARILY EXPANDING YOU
CALFRESH ELIGIBILITY FOR
STUDENTS WITH ZERO ESC AB FOR
FEDERAL WORK STUDY STUDENTS TO
DRUM. I TRUST THE HUNGER CRISIS
EXACERBATED BY THE PANDEMIC.
BUT GIVEN THIS NEW TEMPORARY
DEVELOPMENT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE
IMMEDIATE. HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS WHO NEED
THE MONEY FOR TODAY. SO C. SACK
IS IN A UNIQUE POSITION. TO
HELP FINANCIALLY STUDENTS
ENROLLING CALPERS BECAUSE WE
ALREADY HAVE A TOUCH POINT WITH
THE STUDENTS THAT WE SERVE. WE
CAN QUICKLY IDENTIFY AND
COMMUNICATE WITH ALL THE NEWLY
ELIGIBLE THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS WITH ZERO YES SEE AND
WORK WITH OUR CAMPUS PARTNERS
TO IDENTIFY. FEDERAL WORK STUDY
STUDENTS. AS A MATTER OF FACT
NOTIFICATIONS LETTERS WENT OUT
JUST YESTERDAY AS A LEXUS-
NOTED UP TO ALL THE STUDENTS
URGING THEM TELLING THEM THAT
THEY ARE LIKELY ELIGIBLE
BECAUSE THERE'S ZERO EST. AND
URGING THEM TO GO TO THE GET
CALFRESH OUT AND SIGNED UP
IMMEDIATELY AND IF THEY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR TO CALL THE.
CALIFORNIA STUDENT BODY
CONDITION. SO THE DIFFERENCE BY
WHAT WE'RE TALKING BY THE ABLE
TO REALLY. AND TARGET STUDENTS
KNOW OUR- IT'S DIFFERENT FROM
PASSED SEPARATELY WE JUST SORT
OF BLANKETS GROUPS AND LET THEM
KNOW THEY'RE HEALTH QUESTIONS.
HOPING THAT WE WITH OUR CAPTURE
THOSE STUDENTS WENT BACK WERE
ELIGIBLE AND SAW THIS WITH YOU
KNOW TABLE SET UP ON CAMPUSES
EMAILS FLYERS AND SO FAR. SO
WHAT WE'RE ABLE DO WITH THE
STUDENT AID CAN ARE TO MANY.
PARTS OF THIS PROCESS THERE'S
THE INTAKE INVOLVEMENT PART IS
GETTING IDENTIFYING THE
STUDENTS AND GETTING THEM TO
APPLY AND THEN THERE'S THE-
BACKEND- VERIFICATION AND
APPROVAL PROCESS. WE'RE SEIZE
THAT CAN PLAY A ROLE IS IN THE
IDENTIFICATION WORKING WITH OUR
CDS ASSET OTHERS TO IDENTIFY
THE STUDENTS AND TO BE
AVAILABLE TO PROTECTION YOU CAN
REACH OUT TO STUDENTS IF IN
FACT. WE ENGAGE IN SOME DATA
SHARING WITH LOCAL COUNTIES. TO
REALLY ENCOURAGE ALL STUDENTS
WERE ZERO YES SEEK TO APPLY AND
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS.
TEMPORARY OPPORTUNITY- LASTLY I
JUST LIKE TO THANK ALL THE- WHO
HELPED US WITH THIS ESPECIALLY
THE CESS. RESPONDED IMMEDIATELY
AND WORKING WITH US- ONCE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THROUGH
THESE NEW TEMPORARY ELIGIBLE
EASING THESE TEMPORARY HOW TO
BILL AB- REQUIREMENTS. SO THAT
WE CAN HELP STUDENTS OF SIGNED
UP FOR AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE ARE RESOURCES THAT ARE SO
ESSENTIAL. TO THERE ARE SUCCESS
IN COLLEGE. SO UNLESS OR ANY.
ON MY RETURN NOW TO WELL
BARTTELOT MY STAFF FROM
CONSULTANT WILL TALK TO WALK
YOU THROUGH SOME OF THE WORK
GROUP'S RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
IMMEDIATE ACTION AS WELL AS FOR
SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM.
POSSIBILITIES THANK YOU MELISSA.
MORNING TERRITORY IN NUMBERS MY
NAME IS MELISSA HART- AND I AM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST FOR THE
COMPANIES TO EATEN CHEN I
THOUGHT WE STAFF FOR THE
COMMISSION COCKROACH WORKGROUP-
I'M GRATEFULTO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE YOU ON THE WORK GROUPS
ARE ROTH. I'D LIKE TO START OFF
BY HIGHLIGHTING THAT THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION
CURRENTLY INTERACTS WITH- HELLO
FRESH. IN IN TWO DIFFERENT
PLACES. IN MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY
AND REFER TO THE TEMPORARY
HAPPENED THE ENGINE. ZERO EST
STUDENTS. WE ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE PROCESS OF SENDING OUT
LETTERS TO THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS STATEWIDE
THAT QUALIFY FOR THE EXPANSION.
THE LIKE TRONIC LETTERS SERVE
AS PROOF OF A STUDENTS ZERO EST
STATIC AND ENCOURAGE STUDENTS
TO APPLY FOR CALFRESH. I THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN PURSUANT TO AB
TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN BY FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WATER WE HAVE
BEEN SENDING ELECTRONIC LETTERS
TO RECIPIENTS OF POWER GRANTS
FUNDED BY FEDERAL TEMPORARY
ASSISTANCE FOR NEEDY FAMILIES
OR TANF DOLLARS. QUALIFY FOR
KENNETH ARE ALSO RECEIVING A
CALGARY AB OR B. TUITION AWARD
AFTER CAL GRANT PARTIALLY
FUNDED BY KENNETH DOLLARS THUS
QUALIFYING THEM FOR ONE OF THE
STUDENTS ELIGIBLE BE MORE
CONSCIOUS. SIMILARLY BIG
LETTERS SERVE AS PROOF THAT
STUDENTS ARE IN RECEIPT OF A
CAN OF FUNDED BENEFIT FOR
VERIFICATION PURPOSES AND
ENCOURAGED ME TO APPLY TO COUGH
RASH WE FOUND OUT ABOUT A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND.
LETTERS TO STUDENTS EACH YEAR.
I ALEXIS MY EARLIER COSTUME ARE
SUBJECTED TO DIFFERENT SNAP-
DIFFERENT TOPICAL OINTMENTS DUE
TO THE FEDERAL STUDENT
ELIGIBILITY ROLE AND
CONSEQUENTLY FACE MANY BARRIERS
TO CALFRESH ENROLLMENT DESPITE
BEING ELIGIBLE AND IN NEED OF
THIS ASSISTANCE. THAT IS WHY
THE WORK GROUP IS FOCUSED ON
IDENTIFYING SHORT AND LONG TERM
STRATEGY FOR IMPROVING COLLEGE
STUDENT ENROLLMENT IN TOP RUSH.
ONE AREA THAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED FOR IMMEDIATE ACTION
IN THE WAKE OF TEMPORARY
FEDERAL EXPANSION OF SNAP IF
THE STOCK WATCHING A STATE WIDE
CALFRESH CALL CENTER FOR
COLLEGE STUDENTS AT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION. THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION CURRENTLY HAVE A
FULLY OPERATIONAL STUDENT CALL
CENTER WITH FIFTEEN EMPLOYEES
THE OPERATING MONDAY THROUGH
FRIDAY FROM EIGHT AM TO FOUR
FORTY FIVE PM. THE FACT STAFF
ARE EXTENSIVELY TRAINED TO
HANDLE SENSITIVE STUDENT
INFORMATION AND IF THE STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES DIRECTLY WITH
COMPLEX FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS. FURTHERMORE
FEEDBACK HAD DEMONSTRATED THE
CAPACITY TO ADAPT TO NEW
REQUIREMENTS THERE ARE READ THE
DEFINITION OF THE VOTER
REGISTRATION EACH WEEK. BUT OUR
CALL CENTER STAFF ARE TRAINED
AND FINANCIALLY MATTER BUT ARE
ALSO EXPERIENCING EATING
CUSTOMERS THAT WISH TO REGISTER
TO VOTE. OVERALL SEE THOUGHT
HAVE THE ESTABLISHED CALL
CENTER INFRASTRUCTURE AND IS
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO PROVIDE
TIMELY AND RELIABLE SERVICE
JUSTIN SPEAKING AT THE STINTS
WITH COCKROACH. WITH ADDITIONAL
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
OUR CALL CENTER COULD HIRE
LIMITED TERM STOCK TO EXPAND
OUR CAPACITY TO START PROVIDING
ONE ON ONE TALK FRESH APPLIQUE.
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE TO
STUDENTS. THE PROPOSAL FEEDBACK
WOULD BECOME AN OFFICIAL
OUTRAGE CONTRACTOR WITH YET
ALLOWING US TO GET THE PROPER
TRAINING FOR OUR STAFF. AND
ALSO DRAW DOWN MATCHING FEDERAL
DOLLARS FOR SNAP OUTREACH. CALL
CENTER COULD IF THE STUDENTS
WITH COMPLETING THE CALFRESH
APPLICATION AND ASSISTANCE WITH
THE MANDATORY VERIFICATION
PROCESS AND PREPARING FOR THE
INTERVIEW. THE COMMISSION AND
ALSO ANY. POSITION TO CONDUCT
DIRECT AVERAGE JUST UNIONS THAT
ARE LIKELY ELIGIBLE FOR
CALFRESH. FOR EXAMPLE IF THEY
HAVE A ZERO EST OR IF THEY
RECEIVED A CHECK FROM THE
TELEGRAPH. IDEALLY THIS STATE
WHY CALL CENTER WOULD BE
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH A WARM HAND OFF TO THE
COLLEGE TO THE COUNTY
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROCESSING CAL
FASHION APPLICATION. COMPLETING
THE MANDATORY VERIFICATION AND
CONDUCTING TOP RUSSIAN
INTERVIEWS. OVERALL THE
COMMISSION AND THE WORKGROUP
BELIEVES THAT SYSTEM TAILORED
TO THE COLLEGE STUDENT
EXPERIENCE IS CRITICAL TO
MAKING MEANINGFUL PROGRESS
TOWARDS COLLEGE STREET IN
MOMENT AND CONFERENCE. AND IT
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT THIS WOULD
BE THE FIRST STATEWIDE OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN. THAT CAN ASSIST IN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
ESTABLISHING A STATE MY CALL
CENTER. AIMED AT CALFRESH
OUTREACH TO COLLEGE STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WOULD BE
COST EFFECTIVE METHOD OF
IMPROVING STUDENT INVOLVEMENT
CALFRESH AND THAT'S DRAWING
DOWN MORE FEDERAL DOLLARS TO
ALLEVIATE FOOD INSECURITY.
CALFRESH WORKERS HAVE ALSO
IDENTIFIED SEVERAL SHORT AND
LONG TERM STRATEGY AIMED AT
IMPROVING THE UPTAKE OF
COMMERCE BENEFITS AMONG COLLEGE
STUDENTS. THE SHORT TERM
STRATEGIES WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
REVOLVE AROUND THE IMPORTANCE
OF JUDICIARY PARTICULARLY
SHARING INFORMATION WITH COUNTY
ELIGIBILITY WORKER THAT DO THE
WORK OF VERIFYING STE YOU DON'T
SEE ME AN EXEMPTION TO THE
STUDENT ELIGIBILITY WILL. FOR
HEATING DATA SHARING BETWEEN
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION-
SECONDARY INSTITUTION I LOCAL
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES COULD
AFFECT COUNTY ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS WITH. WITH ONE OF THE
BIGGEST BARRIER IN THE
CONFERENCE APPLICATIONS FOR
STUDENTS. FURTHERMORE IF
CALIFORNIA COULD CONSOLIDATE
VARIOUS DATA SOURCES TO CREATE
A STUDENT ELIGIBILITY WILL
VERIFICATION HOW. THE
VERIFICATION PROCESS COULD BE
MUCH EASIER FOR BOTH STUDENTS
AND ELIGIBILITY WORKERS. THE
WORK GROUP HAVE ALSO BEEN
EXPLORING THE FEASIBILITY OF
USING CANNOT FUNDS FOR OTHER
FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS SUCH AS
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE
GRANT. TO SPEND ON THE POSSIBLE
STUDENT EXEMPTIONS AND
THEREFORE DRAW DOWN MORE
FEDERAL SNAP DOLLARS. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE STATE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM IS PARTIALLY
FUNDED BY KENNETH DOLLARS
MEANING THAT RECIPIENTS OF
KENNETH FUNDED CAL GRANT.
QUALIFY FOR AN EXEMPTION TO THE
STUDENT ELIGIBILITY RULE AND
CAN QUALIFY FOR CALFRESH.
HOWEVER IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
CANNOT BENEFIT FROM FUNDED CAL
GRANT TUITION AWARD. BECAUSE TO
ME IN COLLEGE STUDENTS ONLY
RECEIVE CALGARY AID WHO THE
CALL GRANT ACCESS TO WORK. THIS
IS WHY WE ARE. OPPORTUNITIES TO
REPLICATE THIS MODEL WITH OTHER
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS BUT THE
FACULTY TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. THE WORKER BUT ALSO
EXPLAIN STRATEGIES TO INTEGRATE
INFORMATION FROM THE FREE
APPLICATION FOR FEDERAL STUDENT
AID OR FAST. WITH THE CALL
FRESH APPLICATION OR CREATE
SOME SORT OF WARM HAND OFF
BETWEEN THE TWO APPLICATIONS.
THE PATH APPLICATION ASK
STUDENTS OVER HUNDRED QUESTIONS
INCLUDING DETAILED INFORMATION
ABOUT FAMILY INCOME. AMERICANS
NEED FOR FINANCIAL AID.
RELEVANT DATA POINTS IN THE
FAST THE APPLICATION BUT
AUTOMATICALLY PRE POPULATE
CAUCUS APPLICATION MAKING IT
EASIER FOR STUDENTS TO COMPLETE
THE CALFRESH APPLICATION
PROCESS. LASTLY MANY HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE SERVED BY
THE FREE OR REDUCED PRICE MEAL
PROGRAM WHILE IN SCHOOL
HAVANESE INTEREST IN A SYSTEMS
DOES NOT NECESSARILY AND WHEN
THEY ENROLL IN COLLEGE. THE
WORK GROUP IS EXPLORING MATHIS
TO TRANSITION STUDENTS FROM THE
BRING REDUCED PRICE MEAL
PROGRAM CALFRESH IDEALLY BEFORE
THEY EVEN HIGH SCHOOL. COOL
STUDENTS APPLY FOR THE PATH
THAT HE THAT CAN ENCOURAGE THEM
TO APPLY FOR CALFRESH EVEN AT
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. EARLY
EXPOSURE TO THE CALPERS
APPLICATION PROCESS BEFORE A
STUDENT EVEN ENROLLED IN
COLLEGE MY INCENTIVIZE STUDENTS
TO STAY ENGAGED EVEN WHEN THE
STUDENT ELIGIBILITY WILL TAKE
SEVEN. THE SHORT TERM STRATEGY
FOR THE WORKGROUP HAS
IDENTIFIED WILL HOPEFULLY
PROVIDE INSIGHT ON HOW THE
STATE CAN MAXIMIZE COLLAGEN
INVOLVEMENT IN CONTRAST WITHIN
THE EXISTING FRAMEWORK A
FEDERAL AND STATE SAMPLES.
HOWEVER THERE ARE SOME
FUNDAMENTAL FLAWS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE FEDERAL RULES FOR SNAP
ELIGIBILITY PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO COLLEGE STUDENT
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE REASONS
THAT ALEXIS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY. THIS BRINGS ME TO
THE LONG TERM STRATEGIES WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED WHICH INVOLVED
ADVOCACY AT THE CONGRESSIONAL
LEVEL. ONE PRIORITY FOR THE
WORKGROUP IS TO SEE THE
TEMPORARY EXPANSION OF STUDENT
ELIGIBILITY RELATED TO ZERO EST
STATUS AND WORK STUDY POSITION
MADE PERMANENT. TO TAKE A STEP
EVEN A STEP FURTHER THE WORK
GROUP ADVOCATES FOR THE
ELIMINATION OF THE FEDERAL
STUDENT ELIGIBILITY MORE EARLY.
ELIGIBILITY WILL PREVENT
UNNECESSARY ELIGIBILITY
MINISTRY TO BARRIER THAT
PREVENTS STUDENTS FROM THE
SCHOOL A SERVICE THAT THEY NEED.
GIVEN THE- RIGHT THE STUDENTS
ARCS NATIONWIDE ELIMINATION OF
THE SNAPS ELIGIBILITY WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY ENHANCE THE
COOPERATION WOMAN EXPERIENCE
FOR STUDENTS ALLOW MANY
STUDENTS TO QUALIFY.
FURTHERMORE THE COMMISSION
ENVISIONS BEING ABLE TO
DETERMINE A STUDENT'S
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY FOR
CONTRAST USING INFORMATION FROM
THE FACT THAT WITHOUT REQUIRING
STUDENTS TO GO THROUGH AN
ADDITIONAL BURDEN SOME
APPLICATION OR INTERVIEW
PROCESS. COLLECTS DETAILED
INFORMATION ABOUT HOUSEHOLD
INCOME AND COULD ACT AS A PROXY
GERMAN NEED FOR OTHER FEDERAL
BENEFITS LIKE FRESH. RATHER
THAN RELYING ON THE STUDENT TO
AGAIN PROVE THEY HAVE FINANCIAL
NEED. THE WORK GROUP WILLCONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADVOCATE FOR
THESE CHANGES AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. THE BASIC NEEDS
CHALLENGES THE STUDENTS ARE
FACING PARTICULARLY IN MEXICO
BUT NINETEEN CRISIS ARE DRIVING
THE PROGRESS OF THE WORKER. IT
IS CRUCIAL THAT EXAMINE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE SUDENT
ENROLLMENT AND HOW FRESH
BECAUSE AS MENTIONED EARLIER
THERE ARE A LOT OF STUDENTS
THAT ARE LIKELY ELIGIBLE BUT
NOT APPLYING. WE WILL BE
RELEASING A REPORT SUMMARISING
OUR FINDINGSAND POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS LATER THIS
SPRING I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
EFF AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. TO
IDENTIFY WAYS THAT THE
COMMISSION CONNECT US WITH
IMPORTANT CALFRESH EFFORTS.
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
AND I JUST I DIDN'T QUITE FRAME
THIS ISSUE BEFORE SO THERE IS
NO BUDGET PROPOSAL RELATED TO
CALFRESH FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS.
THIS IS JUST A LINGERING ISSUE
THAT IS YOU KNOW DEBATED IN
THE- SOCIAL SERVICES COMMITTEE
IN THE HIGHER COMMITTEE AND WE
DO KNOW THAT. TWO THINGS FOR
CERTAIN PEOPLE WHO. GET
FINANCIAL AID BY DEFINITION ARE
LOW INCOME. AND THESE REPORTS
OVER AND OVER TALK ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF FOOD INSECURITY AT
OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND SO.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE THIS
COMPLICATED I THINK THE THING
THAT DISTRICTS TRACKS IN THE
MOST IS THAT. THE STUDENTS WHEN
THEY'RE IN HIGH SCHOOL THEY
GET- THEY GET FREE LUNCH AT- AT
HIGH SCHOOL AND THEN THEY GO TO
COLLEGE THEY HAVE THE SAME
INCOME AND IT'S LIKE. THE
INQUISITION TO GET THEM TO FILL
OUT THE FORMS TO GET CALFRESH
YOU RETHINK THE STATE
COMMISSION FORMS ARE
COMPLICATED THIS IS WAY MORE
COMPLICATED SO. WE WANTED TO
JUST AGENDA IS THIS TO LOOK AT
SOME OPTIONS TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR STUDENTS AND- THERE'S JUST
NOT ONE EASY THING THERE'S
QUITE A FEW THINGS THAT THAT WE
CAN DO- I KNOW THAT EVERY YEAR
PEOPLE AUTHOR BILLS ON THIS
TOPIC AND- WE SEEM TO. NOT BE
MAKING MUCH PROGRESS ON THIS
AND IT'S VERY VERY FRUSTRATING
AND SO I WE WOULD JUST WANTED
TO BRAINSTORM TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO- TO
MAKE IT EASIER- CERTAINLY THIS
THIS WE KNOW THERE'S FEDERAL
MONEY WOULD LEAVE ON THE TABLE-
THE OF THESE MONIES HELPS.
AGRICULTURE HELPS YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WHO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
PROGRAMS AS WELL. SO- WITH ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS MR MEDINA
YEAH. NO BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BECAUSE YOU. DEFINITELY
CORRECTED THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING A LOT. ABOUT
IN HIGHER EDUCATION AND A LOT
OF FRUSTRATION. THE STUDENTS
NOT BEING ABLE TO. ACCESS
CALFRESH. SO JUST A QUICK
QUESTION- A PRESENTATION THAT
THE CHALLENGES THAT EXIST
BETWEEN THE COUNTY. AND C.
SACK. TO COLLABORATE WITH WITH
EACH OTHER. TO IMPLEMENT THESE
REFORMS IF YOU COULD JUST
ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT ON ON
THOSE CHALLENGES PLEASE. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA. FROM THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION'S
PERSPECTIVE- THERE'S A LOT OF
CHALLENGES AND WORKING WITH THE
COUNTY- HOW FRESH OFF WITHIN
THE VERIFY STUDENT ELIGIBILITY
OUT WE HAVE STUDENT PRIVACY
ISSUES TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT IN
TERMS OF SHARING STUDENT DATA
OUT WITH COUNTY ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS. SO WE HAVE TO GET
PERMISSION FROM STUDENTS TO
SHARE THAT INFORMATION. I WILL
LIKE I MENTIONED WE ARE AT THE
WORKGROUP EXPLORING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DATA SHARING.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
EXISTING LOCALIZED EFFORTS
BETWEEN- LOCAL CAMPUSES ROUTE
FOR EXAMPLE WITH BASIC NEEDS
CENTERS THAT ARE WORKING WITH
THEIR COUNTY OFFICES TO- JUST
ABOUT FIVE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS AND THE ENROLLMENT
PROCESS. OUT WE'RE LOOKING AT
HOW THOSE EFFORTS CAN BE
REPLICATED STATEWIDE- BECAUSE-
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
BURDEN OF PROVING THAT STUDENTS
ARE LOW INCOME OR THAT THEY ARE
QUALIFY FOR CERTAIN EXEMPTION.
IS ON THE BACK AND NOT ON THE
STUDENTS FIRST RESPONSIBILITY
OR PART BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT
MAKES THE APPLICATION PROCESS
EXPONENTIALLY MORE CALM
COMPLICATED FIRST STUDENT. AT
SO THERE IS A LOT OF
CHALLENGES- AND I MENTIONED
WILL BE PUBLISHING REPORT LATER
THIS SPRING THAT KIND OF
SUMMARIZING THE BARRIERS JOHN
JAY THEN HOW AND POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO OVERCOME. I
ALSO TURNED IT OVER TO ALEXIS
WHO CAN PROBABLY. SPEAK MORE TO
THE COUNTY CLASS. SO THANK YOU
MELISSA YOU KNOW I WHAT I WILL
IS THAT OFTEN WE KIND. BY GIG
RULES- WE ARE FEDERAL PROGRAM
SO ME GET YOU IN AND- WE WOULD
LOVE TO USE INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY HOUSEHOLD ON THE
FACTS THAT DETERMINE HOW
FASHIONABLE DEBILITY NOT ONLY
WOULD THERE BE AN EXCHANGE OF
DATA BUT WE HAVE TO THINK
THROUGH. HOW WE DETERMINE
CALIFORNIA ELIGIBILITY BASED ON
THE MOST RECENT THIRTY DAYS OF
INCOME INFORMATION WHERE ARE
THE FACTS THAT REFLECT THE
INCOME FROM THE PAST AND SO
THERE ARE- CHALLENGES NOT ALL
OF THEM ARE INSURMOUNTABLE. UP
MANY ARE AROUND KIND OF THE
LOGISTICS OF BEING LIKE SKATE
ASSURING OTHERS ARE WORKING
WITHIN THE CONSTRAINTS OF THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM RULES AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
DETERMINING. ELIGIBILITY
ACCURATELY. THANK YOU. MR LEE
THANK YOU SEE I AM A PRIEST
THAT C. SECTORS ELEVATING THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT STUDENT
BASIC NEEDS TO THIS COMMITTEE
IT'S DEFINITELY A LONG STANDING
ISSUE WITHIN ALL OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS SEGMENTS YOU KNOW EVEN
BACK WHEN I WAS A DAVIS THESE
BARRIERS WERE SO HIGH THAT THAT
STUDENTS M. AND USING THEIR
PRIVATE MONEY ANDERSON FEES
WOULD CREATE THEIR OWN PROGRAMS
TO MEET THE NEED RATHER THAN
GOING THROUGH THESE PRO THESE
EXISTING PROGRAMS ARE LOBBYING
FOR STATE FUNDS IF WE SAID WE
DO IT THEMSELVES STUDENTS OFTEN
TAX THEMSELVES JUST TO PROVIDE
THESERVICES FOR OTHER
STUDENTS. AND IN EFFECT A LOT
OF CAMPUSES YOU KNOW PROVIDED
FREE FOOD ESSENTIALLY BASED ON
IF YOU NEED ARE NOT BASED ON
YOUR OWN INTEGRITY IS
COMPLETELY ANONYMIZED THERE
WASN'T IT OBVIOUS COLLECTED
BASICALLY ANONYMIZE IN VERY LOW
BARRIER I'M GLAD THAT ALL THESE
HE SEES ACT IS WORKING RIGHT
NOW TO- TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE-
OF THE LOWER BARRIERS RIGHT NOW
AND MAKING SURE THAT. ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS ARE NOTIFIED I THINK
THAT IS INCREDIBLE THAT IS A
GREAT WORK WE SHOULD BE DOING
TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE GET THAT
THE LONG TERM OBVIOUSLY I'M
WITH YOU THAT WE NEED TO BE
ELIMINATING. THE BERRIES
ALTOGETHER AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. I MEAN I THINK- CALFRESH
OR- FOOD INSECURITY OF THE
ISSUE ITSELF IS ALMOST. AN
EPITOME OF THE OR GOOD
METAPHOR. OR ELSE ARE GOOD
ILLUSTRATION OF THE PROBLEM OR
TALK ABOUT HIS COMMITTEE I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE GREAT
DIALOGUE ABOUT WE HAVE SUCH A
COMPLICATED SUCH AND TANGLED
SYSTEM OF MEANS TESTING OF YOU
HAVE TO BE THIS IF THE THAT YOU
FEEL THESE FORMS. AND THAT IS
INDICATIVE OF A LARGER PROBLEM
WE HAVE THIS COUNTRY RIGHT WILL
BE MAKE IT. ALMOST SO DIFFICULT
TO BE POOR IN THIS COUNTRY WE
MAKE IT SO DIFFICULT ACCESS THE
RESOURCES THAT WE COLLECTIVELY
PULLED TOGETHER FOR EACH OTHER.
AND THIS IS SHOWN VERY CLEARLY
JUST IN FOOD INSECURITY RIGHT.
I MEAN A LOT OF THESE. PROGRAMS
WE CREATED FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS
WAS BACK WHEN. THE BUYING POWER
OF MINIMUM WAGE IS MUCH
STRONGER THAN YOUR BUYING POWER
EVEN HIGHER YOUR- PART TIME JOB
WITH A MINIMUM WAGE OF A
STRONGER. HOUSING COSTS ARE
MUCH MUCH MUCH MORE FORMAL AND
BOXING KOSTER LEFT ARM. EVERY
DAY. SO THESE ARE THE REAL
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE BY
SINCE RIGHT NOW WHERE THEY
CHOOSE TO HAVE A MALE. BUT THEY
CHOOSE TO PAY FOR THE RENT. OR
SOMETHING ELSE THAT THEY NEED
TO SURVIVE IS SO DIFFICULT
RIGHT NOW SO I'M GLAD THAT HE'S
I GUESS TAKING THIS URGENT
ACTION RIGHT NOW NOTIFYING IT
SO. AWFUL TO BE A PARTNER IN
THIS ASPECT BUT I THINK IT IS.
ILLUSTRATIVE TO THIS COMMITTEE
AND- IN OUR FRUSTRATION ABOUT
HOW COMPLICATED THINGS ARE. AND
HOPEFULLY WE'LL KEEP UNTANGLING
AND SIMPLIFYING STREAMLINING
THINGS. IN OUR APPROACH TO MAKE
HIGHER EDUCATION FREE AND
ACCESSIBLE TO EVERYONE AND- BE
SIMPLIFIED THAT WAY. SO JUST
LIKE HOW. OKAY FOR THE
QUESTIONS. DISTRESS NOT SO MUCH
OF COURSE BUT THE COME THAT
OFTENTIMES IS LEGISLATORS WE
HEAR THE PRESENTATIONS AND WE
ARE 1100% WITH YOU. THIS IS AS
MY COLLEAGUE HAS INDICATED WE
SHOULD NOT BE TALKING ABOUT TO
FOOD AND SECURITY WHEN WE HAVE
THE FUNDING TO PROVIDE TO THE
ASSISTANCE TO OUR STUDENTS IT
STILL EXISTS SO I THINK AS
LEGISLATORS AND I APPRECIATED
THE SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM
STRATEGIES THAT THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN YOUR PRESENTATION.
I THINK THE PROPOSED
LEGISLATION THAT YOU THAT WILL
BE IN YOUR REPORT WILL BE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IN HELPING
US TO BETTER ADDRESS IT BUT-
YOU ALL ARE THE EXPERTS AND WE
DO RELY ON. THE SUGGESTIONS THE
VERY SPECIFIC SUGGESTIONS THAT
YOU ALL MAKE BECAUSE YOU'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF IT AND YOU HELP
US TO PREPARE. TO AUTHOR-
LEGISLATION THAT WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. AS OPPOSED TO
SAYING HERE'S A PROBLEM LET ME
INTRODUCE LEGISLATION. AND WE
HAVE TO HAVE THE INFORMATION
FROM THE EXPERTS ABOUT EXACTLY
WHAT IS NEEDED. IT MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ADDRESSING THIS WITH US.
YEAH SO AND I WOULD JUST NOTE
TO THAT IN THERE ARE A LOT OF
REMEDIES HERE AND IT INCLUDES-
THEY COUNTY WORKERS THE
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS AND IT AND
IT HAS MR LEE NOTED TO INCLUDES
THE SCHOOLS TO THE SYSTEMS
NEEDED TO HAVE TO HELP OUT BUT-
YOU KNOW ONE THING THAT WE
SHOULD CONSIDER DOING IS
CERTAINLY THAT. THE DATA
SHARING IS A PIECE THAT WE
SHOULD STEP UP AND DO BUT- YOU
KNOW WHAT WE HEARD FROM OUR LA
ON FINANCE AT. THAT THIS BUDGET
IS NOT YOU KNOW BLOOMING FOR
ONGOING YEARS BUT THERE IS
POTENTIAL ONE TIME- REVENUE
OPPORTUNITIES THIS YEAR SO
POTENTIALLY YOU KNOW WE SHOULD
COME BACK AND LOOK AT. WHAT IF
WE COULD DO SOMETHING AND-
MAYBE DO A- TOP UP PILOT AND
WORK AND SPEND SPEND THE MONEY
OVER THREE YEARS. AND FOCUS AND
SEE IF IT WORKS HAVING MORE-
WORKERS IN SOME OF THESE SOME
OF THE COUNTIES TO WORK IN
THIRTEEN COLLEGE. CAMPUS
SETTINGS- BUT THE NEED IS NOT
GOING AWAY. AND YOU KNOW I JUST
THINK THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THIS DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE WHAT
WE HAVE BEEN DOING.
UNFORTUNATELY IS NOT WORKING
ITSELF. AGAIN THIS IS AN
INFORMATION LINE THANK YOU FOR
THEIR PRESENTATION AND WE'LL
TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. OUT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VITAS. I'LL BE BRIEF SO
I AM DID THE COVERT NINETEEN
RELIEF BILL PASSED BY CONGRESS
IN DECEMBER. STREAMLINED
CALFRESH BENEFITS ELIGIBILITY
FOR ANY POPULATIONS BESIDES
COLLEGE STUDENTS. I CAN TAKE
THAT THIS IS A LEXUS- THE
RELIEF PACKAGE THAT WAS SIGNED
IN DECEMBER- HAD A HANDFUL OF
CHANGES RELATED TO SNAP THIS
WAS THE ONLY. EXPANSION OF
ELIGIBILITY ADDS THE USDA HAS
DESCRIBED SO I'M EARLIER ON IN
CALIFORNIA HAD ASKED TO LEAVE
THIS WORLD IN RESPONSE TO THE
CONDEMNING I'M U. S. NEWS
RESPONSE WAS THAT THEY DID NOT
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO THAT
AND SO IT DID TAKE ME AN ACT OF
CONGRESS AND SO WHAT WE SAW WAS
NOT A BELIEVER OF THE RULE. BUT
AN EXPANSION SHOULD BE TO YOU
POPULATIONS BUT YES THAT THAT
IS. THE ONLY GROUP IN THE
RELEASED BACK THAT- SAW A
CHANGE. IN ELIGIBILITY POLICY.
THANK FOR THE FOR THAT CARE
THERE AT THEN I DO WANT TO SAY
pTHAT WE RALLY LOOK AT. WHY
THEY'RE SUCH A GREAT NEED. AND
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THIS GREAT
NEED WITHOUT TALKING ABOUT. THE
FORD ABILITY CRISIS THAT WE'RE
FACING HERE IN CALIFORNIA THE
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING- THE
HIGH COST OF TAXES THE HIGH
COST OF LIVING THAT ARE DRIVING
OUR FAMILIES TO MOVE OUT OF THE
STATE. AND THESE ARE BROADER
ISSUES THAT ARE A PRIORITY FOR
ME AT LEAST I THINK A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE- BUT IT'S EXPENSIVE
TO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
STUDENTS FOR FAMILIES AND THERE
ARE A MULTITUDE OF ISSUES THAT
WE HAVE TO BE PRIORITIZING. TO
REDUCE THE COST OF LIVING FOR
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW PROCEED
WITH ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN THIS IS
OUR FINAL ISSUE BEFORE WE GET
TO PUBLIC COMMENTS THIS IS A
REPORT FROM THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND THAT THE FIX
FINANCIAL AID COALITION- MAINLY
OF STUDENTS- TALKING ABOUT WAYS
HOW WE CAN MODERNIZE AND
IMPROVE OUR CAL GRANT- SYSTEM
AND THIS GOES TO ALL THESE AS
WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER-
ASSEMBLY SUNY COMMISSIONS AND
WORKING ON FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
AND MARLENE GARCIA THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR IS GOING TO-
PRESENT TO US NOW THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN- MCCARTY
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH PROVIDING
NEED BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION- MY TEAM AND I.
ARE MY GARCIA I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COMPANY STUDENT
AID COMMISSION I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU AS WELL AS A SEPARATE
NUMBER MEDINA. FOR YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE OUR COMMISSION IS
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP
ALONG WITH SENATOR MADE BACK IN
ADVANCING ISSUES THAT IS SO
CRITICAL. TO OUR STUDENTS AND
THE STATE. I- MUST IGNORE THE
ARAB LEADERS. AND
REALLY BEING. A STEADFAST IN
BRINGING THIS ISSUE. OVER THIS
AND THIS CONVERSATION THE
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN CONSISTENT
AND CLEAR IN THE CALL FOR.
CALIFORNIA TO FIX FINANCIAL
AID- BY ADDRESSING THE GROWING
BARRIERS OF NON TUITION COSTS
AND REMOVING THE ELIGIBILITY
RESTRICTIONS ACT SO MANY
STUDENTS. OUT OF OUR CURRENT
STATE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM.
BEFORE WE SHOULD BE UPDATE I
WANTED TO GIVE YOU I WORK WITH
WITH THE LATEST ITERATION OF
OUR PROPOSAL. TO MODERNIZE THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS I'D LIKE TO
PROVIDES A BACKGROUND FOR NEW
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
THE NEED FOR TELEGRAPH. CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT BETTER
REFLECTS THE EXPERIENCES OF THE.
NEEDS OF TODAY'S STUDENTS. WE
ARE PROUD THAT. OFFERS MOST
STATE FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM IN
THE NATION THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS FUNDED BY TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS. ANSWERS
CLOSER HALF A MILLION STUDENTS
ANNUALLY. HOWEVER THE PROGRAM
HAS EVOLVED OVER THE DECADES IT
HAS GROWN MORE COMPLEX AT LEAST
CRITICAL GAPS IN CERTAIN
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO PROVIDING THE BASIC
NEEDS SUPPORT THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT. QUITE A BIT THIS
MORNING. THE OUTBREAK OF COPING.
OUR STUDENTS WORRIES TO COVER
THE BASIC NEEDS FOOD HOUSING
NOW TECHNOLOGY PARKS AND
TRANSPORTATION. AND IN THE MOST
RECENT YEARS THAT IT COMBINES
64% OF THE STUDENT RESPONDENTS
SAID ABOUT THE HIGH COST OF
COLLEGE. IN COMBINATION
BALANCING WORK AND STUDIES WAS
OUR BIGGEST CONCERN. IN WAKE OF
THE PANDEMIC MINISTER
ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM THE
LOWEST INCOME BACKGROUNDS ARE
QUESTIONING WHETHER THE COST OF
COLLEGES BEYOND REACH. AND
THESE ARE THE STUDENTS WHO ARE
MOST AT RISK OF DROPPING OUT OR
NEVER STARTED COLLEGE TO BEGIN
WITH AND WE STARTED TO SEE SOME
OF THE CRIMES IN OCCUPATIONS AT
VARIOUS. COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. BUT AT THE TIME
THE STATE NEEDS MORE HIGH
SKILLED COVERED STUDENTS IN THE
WORK FORCE TO TURN THIS ECONOMY
AROUND. WE CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE
A WHOLE GENERATION OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS. BECAUSE THE COST IS
PROHIBITED IN THE EXPENSE THAT.
SO IF YOU'RE OUT OF DIFFERENT
MATERIALS NOTED THE
CONVERSATION AROUND REMOVING
ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS OF BETTER
SUPPORTING STUDENT NEEDS ARE
NOT NEW. BUT GIVEN THE
INCREASING COST OF ATTENDANCE
AND THE COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA THESE PROBLEMS HAVE
YOU REACHED OUT TODAY TO
CREATING MAJOR BARRIERS FOR
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE COLLEGE.
SO OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
THE LEGISLATURE LED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY MEDINA AS WELL
AS SENATOR LEYVA INTRODUCE CAL
GRANT REGISTRATION AND THEN ASK
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION TO
LEAD A WORKGROUP IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY NINETEEN. TO DEVELOP A
PROPOSAL FOR MODERNIZING THE
TELEGRAPH PROGRAM TO MORE
EQUITABLY SERVE TODAY STUDENTS.
TO THE COMMISSION WORK WITH ALL
THE MAJOR STAKEHOLDERS TO
DEVELOP A PLAN FOR
RESTRUCTURING THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS BASED ON A SET OF
GOALS. AND AFTER MONTHS OF
WORKING CONSULTATION WILL WORK
WITH SUBMITTED THE CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION PROPOSAL AN
EQUITY FRAMEWORK FOR THE.
FUTURE ON MARCH SIXTH. AND THEN
OF COURSE IT GETS BUT YOU'RE OF
A THE THAT'S A PRIORITY THAT
ARE DRESSED IN EQUITY. NUMBER
IT'S SIMPLIFIED INSTREAM THE
VERY. SO PROGRAMS GRANT
PROGRAMS INTO TO PROBE HELP YOU
HELP WRAP FOR. SUPPORT FOR
BASIC NEW BYE REX YOU GOT
RECOGNIZE NON TUITION COSTS NOT
JUST TUITION CLASS. IT MAKES
FINANCIAL AID MORE EQUITABLE BY
REMOVING NUMEROUS BARRIERS SUCH
AS AGE TIME OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
R. G. COMMUNITIES- SO THAT
STUDENTS CAN MORE EASILY
QUALIFY FOR FINANCIAL AID. AND
IT ALSO REDUCES THE LEVELS OF
DEBT INCURRED BY STUDENTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR FINANCIAL AID GRANTS. AND
THEN LASTLY REALLY IMPORTANTLY
FOR THE FIRST TIME. WE LEVERAGE
ACCORDING THE OF STATE AND
INSTEAD EIGHT TO MORE CALM. AND
EFFECTIVELY SERVED IN THE
ACTIONS OF THE STUDENTS SO WE
LOOK AT ALL THESE PIECES COME
TOGETHER TO MEET THE TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE NOT JUST TOOLS.
SO THIS EQUITY FRAMEWORK
PROVIDE A COMPREHENSIVE AND
SYSTEMATIC APPROACH TO REMOVE
THE VEHICLE EQUITIES CURRENTLY
BAKED INTO THE SYSTEM. WHICH
LARGELY BEING SOME OF OUR
LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS ARE OUT
OF THE PROGRAM WHO TYPICALLY DO
ATTEND COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ONE
OF THE KEY DISPARITIES AS YOU
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER THIS
MORNING THIS MORNING. ONE OF
THE KEY. THAT THIS PLANET TENDS
TO ADDRESS IS THIS YEAR
LIMITATION OF THE COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS AS NOTED
EARLIER ONLY ONE IN SEVEN
STUDENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO
FINANCIALLY ACTUALLY GET AN
AWARD. AT MANY OF THE STUDENTS
IN FACT THAT TEN PEOPLE
COLLEGES SO THIS LOTTERY SYSTEM
THAT LEAVES THE MAJORITY OF
HIGH NEED STUDENTS WITH
NOTHING. IS NOT WORKING FOR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF OUR
STUDENTS WHO COULD OTHERWISE
PERSISTENCE. IT'S EVEN CALLED.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
WHILE THE PLAN TO BREEDERS OF
FOR BASE NEEDS FOR STUDENTS THE
LOWEST INCOME. BUT AND- APRIL
BY ASKING THAT. TO HELPING LOW
AND MIDDLE CLASS. FAMILIES WHO
THE MIDDLE CLASS- IN SUPPORTING
THEM AND GETTING FINANCIAL AID.
THIS PROPOSAL DOES NOT
ELIMINATE THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP WHAT IT DOESN'T GET
BETTER QUINCES THAT TO REALLY
BUILD. OFF OF A WEIRD CAL GRANT
AND SOFT. SO WE WILL SHARE YOU
TODAY. THE SAME PRIORITIES THAT
WE IDENTIFIED IN THE MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY REPORT AS WELL AS
OUR EFFORTS WITH OPTIONS THAT
REFLECT FUNDS AVAILABLE AS OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY
APPROPRIATIONS. AND HELP THESE
NEW INVESTMENTS CAN AND HOW YOU
INVESTMENTS IN MEANINGFUL
MEANINGFUL WE RAISE THE
DISPARITIES. INSERTED ALL
STUDENTS WITH. LAST THREE YOU
KNOW THE FEDS HAVE ADOPTED
SIGNIFICANT NEW CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY WHICH WILL
ULTIMATELY INCREASE NUMBER CAL
GRANT STUDENTS WERE ELIGIBLE
FOR PELL GRANTS THIS IS A GOOD
THING FOR OUR STUDENTS.
PARAGRAPHS WILL OBVIOUSLY DRAW
DOWN MORE FEDERAL RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT STUDENT BASIC NEEDS ARE
RELYING LESS ON THE STATE TO
PROVIDE FOR ALL OF CITIZENS.
WELL MANY OF THE FEDERAL
DETAILS ARE STILL BEING
DEVELOPED THE C. SEX STAFF HAVE
BEEN WORKING. TO ANALYZE ALL
THE DATA AND WORKING WITH
NATIONAL EXPERTS TO UNDERSTAND
THE FULL IMPLICATIONS OF THESE
CHANGES AND WHAT THEY NEED FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AFTER CAL
GRANT MODERNIZATION. SO I WILL
PARTS. AND TURNS YOU AND
WESTERN QUESTIONS I WILL TURN
THE PRESENTATION OVER TO JAKE
PRIMERICA R. C. SECTOR RECORD
GOVERNMENT EX EXTERNAL
RELATIONS WALK YOU THROUGH THE
MAJOR PROVISIONS. OF THE CAL
GRANT MODERNIZATION PROPOSAL.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR GARCIA AND
I'LL BE SHARING MY SCREEN- NOW
WITH THE WALL AS THEY BEGIN TO
PROTECT HERE ON OUR I'LL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK- SO YOU SHOULD
HOPEFULLY NOW THESE MYSTIFIED-
FOR OUR PROPOSED CAL GRANT CHU
AWARD- WORK AGAIN. THIS IS AN
AWARD THAT WOULD REFLECT THE
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY CALL
STUDENTS. AS YOU MAY KNOW THE
PROMISE GRANT FORMALLY PARTNERS
WAIVER ALREADY PROVIDES TUITION
COVERAGE FOR OVER 40% OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER THERE'S
VERY LITTLE AID FOR COMMUNITY
CALL STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS AND
AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AFTER
GARCIA NOTED VERY FEW OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. STUDENTS TO
MEET RECEIVED A TELEGRAM TODAY.
WE WOULD PROPOSE THE DEKALB TO
ALL L. COMMUTE COLLEGE
STUDENTS. WITH A ZERO EXPECTED
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION THE MOST
FINANCIALLY VULNERABLE STUDENTS
IDENTIFIED BY OUR EIGHT
APPLICATIONS. WITH THIS TYPE IN
FOR THEIR NON TUITION COSTS.
THIS WOULD ELIMINATE EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS BASED ON A
STUDENT'S AGE FOR THEIR TIME
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL. AND I'M
TRYING TO SERVE ADULT LEARNERS
WE WOULD ALSO ELIMINATE THE
NEED FOR GPA VERIFICATION. I
SECURING HIGH SCHOOL TRANSCRIPT
CAN BECOME A BARRIER TO ENTRY
FOR THE STUDENTS. AND YOU NEED
PROGRAM FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WOULD ALSO ALLOW US TO
SET AN APPLICATION DEADLINE FOR
THAT SEPTEMBER SECOND. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHEAP. RELATIVE TO
OUR OTHER AID PROGRAMS WHICH
CURRENTLY- HAVE A STATE PARTY
DEADLINE FOR MARCH SECOND. FOR
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS. THIS
WOULD REFLECT THE ROLE OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN PROVIDING
ACCESS TO STUDENTS WITHOUT THE
EARLIER ADMISSIONS DEADLINES
THAT WE SEE IN OTHER SEGMENTS.
ALTOGETHER IN DOING THIS WE
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS ELIGIBLE FOR CAL
GRANT YOU. BY MORE THAN
DOUBLING THE NUMBER OF A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
ELIGIBLE FOR CAL GRANT AWARD
FROM HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR. FOUR
THOUSAND STUDENTS I TO HOPE TO
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN JUST ONE
APPLICATION HERE. ON THIS SLIDE
WE LAY OUT PROJECTIONS FOR
PUBLIC AID COULD BE PROVIDED TO
STUDENTS BASED ON AVAILABLE
FUNDS. TODAY APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND CAL GRANT. COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE NEW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
RECIPIENTS EACH YEAR. WITH
THOSEPHONES WE COULD OFFER ALL
ZERO ESE. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WITH A STIPEND OF ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS AND THAT NUMBER- WE'VE
ESTIMATED BASED ON. HISTORICAL
DATA ON THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WERE PAID AN AWARD WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT PAID RATES
EARLIER AND WE'VE ALSO
ACCOUNTED FOR THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO MIGHT BE INVOLVED
PART TIME RATHER THAN FULL
TIME. AND WOULD QUALIFY FOR THE
FULL I'M MORE. THE CURRENT CAL
BE ACCESSIBLE ONLY NON.
STUDENTS AWARD- PROVIDES ONE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED FIFTY SIX
DOLLARS ACCURATE ACCOUNT FOR
THE SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDED BY
THE COLLEGE ACCESS TAX CREDIT
REVENUE. TO MAINTAIN IN A WORD
OF THAT SIZE WILL ALSO SERVING
TO INCREASE NUMBER OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT ELIGIBLE AND
THAT WOULD REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
FORTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS AND
ONGOING FUNDS. AND YOU'LL SEE
IN THE BELOW ROW WE'VE ALSO-
CONTENDED BY THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE A TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR REWARD TO
ALL OF THE ZERO YES THE
STUDENTS. AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT WE REFERENCED.
THIS FIVE TO FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY DOLLARS YES THE- IT
OUTLINES WITH THE ELIGIBILITY
CUTOFF POINT FOR THE FEDERAL
PELL GRANT PROGRAM THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL PROGRAMS
SERVING LOW INCOME STUDENTS-
AND WE'VE OUTLINED THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY FOR CALTRAIN TO.
BEYOND THE ZERO C. MARK DELANEY
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE FEDERAL
PELL GRANT PROGRAM YES HE CUT
OFF. SO I'M ON THE SIXTH WHY I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT SOME DATA
POINTS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THE
ADDENDUM TO THAT MARCH TOLERATE
REPORT A MODERNIZATION REPORT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR GARCIA-
ACTION SO IN THOSE MATERIALS
THAT I BELIEVE MEMBERS SHOULD
ALREADY HAVE- THESE ARE- DATA
POINTS. FROM THE LAST PAGE OF
THAT ADDENDUM REPORT- WHERE WE-
I LIKE SOME OF THE KEY CHANGES
THAT WE WOULD SEE AND THE
PROFILE OF RECIPIENTS FOR STATE
AID UNDER CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION RELATIVE TO THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE ADMINISTER
TODAY. AND WHAT I WANT TO CALL
ATTENTION TO IS THAT RELATIVE
TODAY'S RECIPIENTS STUDENTS
WOULD RECEIVE A PELL GRANT TO
AWARD WOULD BE LOWER INCOME.
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF THEM WOULD
BE FIRST GOING CALLED FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE GOING
STUDENTS. THEY WOULD BE OLDER
ON AVERAGE THAN TODAY'S
RECIPIENTS AND A GREATER SHARE
OF THEM WOULD BE STUDENT
PARENTS AND ACTUALLY A THREE
TIME OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS ELIGIBLE NEARLY REAL
TIME. WILL BE STUDENT PARENTS.
HERE WE'VE ALSO- PULLED OUT
SOME HIGH FROM THE- AGAIN AND
APPENDIX TO VIEW THEM BUT- AND
WE WANTED TO FLAG FOR YOU SOME
IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE
REPRESENTATION. OF STUDENT
RECIPIENTS UNDER THE PROPOSED
CAL GRANT TO RELATIVE TO
TODAY'S MODEL SO IN THIS TOP
ROW YOU SEE THE PERCENTAGE
SHARE OF STUDENT- POPULATIONS.
BASED ON THE CURRENT CAL GRANT
THAT CAL GRANT PROGRAMS THAT WE
ADMINISTER AND HERE IN THE
PROPOSAL HELLO YOU SEE THE
SHARE OF STUDENT POPULATIONS
BASED ON. THE PROPOSED CAL
GRANT TO. BUSINESS ELIGIBLE
COLUMN REPRESENTS STUDENTS
WORKING BROUGHT IN TO THE STATE
AID A PROGRAM AND ARE BEING
MADE ELIGIBLE HI THIS PROPOSAL.
AND YOU SEE THE PERCENT FOR
EACH VERY STUDENT POPULATION I
WILL I THANK EACH PERCENTAGE
POINT HERE BUT I DO WANT TO
CALL ATTENTION TO. WHAT THOSE
PERCENTAGES TRANSLATES TO AN
ACTUAL NUMBERS OF STUDENTS TO
BECOME ELIGIBLE AND HERE YOU
SEE AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ALONE I'M MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. LATINO STUDENTS TO
BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR CAL GRANT
AWARD- UNDER DISCOGRAPHY. TWO
THOUSAND AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS. SO I WANT TO ALSO
SPEAK TO. THE IMPACT OF THESE
CHANGES WOULD BE ON THE
STUDENTS WITH DEPENDENT
CHILDREN GRANT PROGRAMS EVEN
SPEAKING TODAY JUST SOME OF
THOSE ENHANCE ACCESS AWARDS
THAT. RECIPIENTS THOSE WHO
ALREADY RECEIVE A PELL GRANT-
BENEFIT FROM AND IF THEY IF
THEY FIT BUT ST PARENT
ELIGIBILITY PROFILE OR IN THE
PROPOSAL- DISCUSSED EARLIER TO
OUR FOSTER YOUTH STUDENTS- WHAT
WE PROPOSE HERE IS THAT ALL OF
OUR ZERO E. IF THE STUDENT
PARENTS ATTENDING A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. CSU OR UC WOULD
RECEIVE- STUDENTS WITH
DEPENDENT CHILDREN GRANT AWARD-
THESE ARE THE SAME INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE FOR
THE PROGRAM TODAY. OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WE
ANTICIPATE WOULD CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THE PROMISE GRANT TO
COVER THEIR TUITION AND FEES
AND STUDENT PARENTS WOULD
RECEIVE THIS ENHANCED. STUDENTS
WITH DEPENDENT CHILDREN GRANT
RATHER THAN THE CAL GRANT TO
FOR THEIR NON TUITION COSTS.
WHEREAS AT THE YOU SEEM TO SEE
IF YOU WERE THE CULPRIT FOR
THAT WE'LL DISCUSS MOMENTARILY
WOULD COVER TUITION AND FEES
STUDENT PARENTS OUR PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES WOULD RECEIVE A
STUDENTS WITH DEPENDENT
CHILDREN GRANT. IN ADDITION
ABOUT TUITION FEES COVERAGE.
AND SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU SAW
WITH THE TELEGRAM TO. UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL COULD YOU REMOVE
THOSE ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS
NEARLY TWICE AS MANY ARE
EMPLOYING MORE THAN TWICE AS
MANY THAT SHOULD SAY STUDENT
PARENTS BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR CAL
GRANT AWARD AND WE GO FROM
TWENTY SIX JUST OVER TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS PARENTS
ELIGIBLE. UNDER TODAY'S A
CALTRANS IS DONE TO OVER. SIXTY
THOUSAND UNDER CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION. AND AS WE DID
THE CAL TO. ON THIS SLIDE WE
LAY OUT- AWARD AMOUNT BE PULSE
FOR THE INCREASE BASIS STUDENT
PARA RECIPIENTS. USE ONLY ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IT'S CURRENTLY THAT-
STATUTORY PROGRAM FUNDING CAP
FOR THIS PROGRAM. SO WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE ALL OF
THOSE- OR OFFER ALL OF THOSE
SIXTY THOUSAND STUDENTS BUT THE
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLAR.
I'M AWARD AMOUNT- USING THAT
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND YOU SEE HERE THAT
WE'VE ALSO IDENTIFIED THE FUNDS
THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED ON GOING
IF YOU WANTED TO MAINTAIN THE
MAXIMUM AWARD IT'S AVAILABLE TO
THE STUDENTS THAT SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THERE'S AND HERE WE'VE
ALSO. INCLUDED AN ESTIMATE FOR
THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH
EXTENDING. INSTITUTIONAL
ELIGIBILITY FOR THESE PROGRAMS
TO PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS AND
GOING BEYOND THE PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES- THAT
ARE ELIGIBLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM TODAY. AND AGAIN
WE'VE ALSO INCLUDED ESTIMATES
FOR THE FUNDS REQUIRED TO
EXTEND ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
BENEFIT BEYOND- ZERO EST
DISTANCE YOU MIGHT HAPPEN IF
THE THAT QUALIFIES THEM FOR THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM. NOW HERE ALL
SHIPS- THE INSTITUTIONS THAT
ARE NOT A CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. ARE CAL GRANT FOR
PROGRAM WOULD SERVE STUDENTS
OUT ARE YOU SEE ARE CSU AND ARE
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA- AND WHAT WE'VE DONE
HERE IT'S MODEL WHAT WOULD BE
POSSIBLE- BASED ON THE TWO
POINT ONE FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
IT'S CURRENTLY ALLOCATED. TO
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN THE
SECTORS- WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
OFFER A STUDENTS WITH AN EST
THAT QUALIFIED FOR THE PROGRAM
WOULD HELP GRANT FOR REWARD IT
WOULD ACTUALLY JUST TAKE TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING ABOVE
THAT TWO POINT ONE FOUR.
BILLION WHICH IS A OF A SMALL
NUMBER IN THE CONTEXT OF THAT
BROADER- TWO POINT ONE FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION- AND
AS WE- CHAIRED EARLIER WE AGAIN
PROPOSED ELIMINATING THE AGE AT
THE TIME OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
REQUIREMENTS THAT EXIST ON OUR
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS TODAY. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE THREE DIFFERENT
GPA MINIMUMS DEPENDING ON THE
PROGRAM I'M FOR WHICH YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE AND WE WOULD
CONSOLIDATE AND STREAMLINE BOWS
DOWN. TO TWO POINT OH GPA
MINIMUM. THE CAL GRANT FOR WHAT
CAN TO TUITION FEES DID YOU SEE
OR IF YOU WHILE MAINTAINING THE
EXISTING AWARD AMOUNT AVAILABLE
FOR STUDENTS ENROLLED AT
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS. THERE
WOULD NO LONGER BE A CAL GRANT
BE ACCESS AWARD- SO INSTEAD WE
PROPOSE THAT INSTITUTIONALLY
PROVIDES ZERO YES THE STUDENTS
WITH A STIPEND TO SUPPORT THEIR
BASIC NEEDS. M. ALTOGETHER BY
LIMITING VISA ELIGIBILITY
BEARERS IN CONVERTING TO
TUITION COVERAGE AWARDS WE
COULD OFFER FORTY THOUSAND MORE
STUDENTS WITH THE CAL GRANT FOR
AWARD RELATIVE TO BILLS
ELIGIBLE UNDER TODAY'S
REQUIREMENTS. EARLIER WE WANT
TO PULL OUT SOME KEY CHANGES IN
THE DISTRIBUTION OF RECIPIENTS
UNDER THE CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK SO RELATIVE TO
PROCEED STUDENTS WERE RECEIVING
OKAY. TODAY THOSE WHO WOULDN'T
BE ELIGIBLE UNDER THE CAL GRANT
FOR WOULD BE LOWER INCOME UP A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF THEM WOULD
BE INDEPENDENT STUDENTS AND NOT
A DEPENDENCE LISTED UNDER
FASTER- UNDER THEIR THEIR
PARENTS- TAX FILING- MAYBE
OLDER THAN RECIPIENTS TODAY.
AND A HIGHER PERCENTAGE. OF
THEM WOULD BE STUDENT PARENTS.
AND AGAIN WE WANTED TO SHARE-
WHAT THE IMPACTS ON THE
REPRESENTATION OF CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS WOULD LOOK LIKE AND
WILL NOT AS PRONOUNCED WE DO
THINK THAT THERE ARE STILL
SIGNIFICANT- SHIFT TOWARDS
GREATER INCLUSION PARTICULARLY
FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN. AND ARE
LOOKING OF STUDENTS. MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM I CAN
BE BRIEF ON THIS SLIDE BECAUSE
WE REALLY AS EXECUTIVE COURSE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR GARCIA NOTED
WOULD PROPOSE CONFORMING
CHANGES SO THAT. THIS PROGRAM
WOULD PICK OFF PICK UP RIGHT
WHERE THE CULPRIT FOR
ELIGIBILITY ENDS I'M AND THAT
WE WOULD AS WE MOVE FROM INCOME
ASSET FEELINGS ON OUR CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT WE WOULD DO THE
SAME FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP. AND SHIPPED BACK
TO A BASIS ON EXPECTED FAMILY
CONTRIBUTION FOR ELIGIBILITY-
SUCH THAT WE WOULD CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE A PERCENTAGE OF TUITION
COVERAGE JUST UNITS BASED ON
THEIR EFC. I'M AND WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE SOME
VALUABLE- IMPROVEMENTS WE CAN
MAKE TO ADMINISTRATION ON THIS
PROGRAM IN FUNCTIONS OF THE
LAST DOLLAR PROGRAM WHICH MEANS
WE'RE TRACKING STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGES
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE ACADEMIC
YEAR. AND ACTUALLY CREATE THE
POSSIBILITY THAT- IN THE AUGUST
FOLLOWING AN ACADEMIC YEAR
STUDENTS EITHER AWARD REDUCED
SO WE WOULD PROPOSE- PROVIDING
A DEFINED. PERCENTAGE AT THE
START OF THE YEAR. I MENTIONED
EARLIER THE ROLE OF
INSTITUTIONAL AID- THAT WE SEE
UNDER THIS FRAMEWORK- AND- WHAT
WE WOULD AGAIN PROPOSES THAT
ZERO ESE STUDENTS- AND ROLLED.
OUT ORG UNIVERSITIES BE
ELIGIBLE FOR INSTITUTIONAL AID
TO SUPPORT THEIR BASIC NEEDS.
THIS IS POSSIBLE IN PART
BECAUSE OF SIGNIFICANT
INSTITUTIONAL AID RESOURCES
PARTICULARLY AT THE CSU ARE
BEING UTILIZED TO FILL HOLES IN
THE COVERAGE OF THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS TODAY. THAT ARE
CREATED BY ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS
THAT ARE CONNECTED TO THE-
NATIONAL NEED. SO I THINK
DOLLARS BECOME FREED UP WE
PROPOSE THAT THOSE GO TOWARDS
SUPPORTING BASIC NEEDS FOR OUR
MOST FINANCIALLY VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. AND YOU SEE HERE WE
HAVE SOME OPTIONS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION REPUBLICAN
OPERATIONALIZE THIS-
EXPECTATION INCLUDING ANNUAL
REPORTING OR REQUIREMENT THAT
INSTITUTIONS ADOPT AND
PUBLICIZE. POLICIES ON USE OF
INSTITUTIONAL. AND I ON THIS
CHART WE LAY OUT. WE KNOW THAT
WE'VE THROWN A LOT AT YOU SO
FAR AND HAS WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING TODAY THIS IS A
COMPLICATED SYSTEM THAT WE
ADMINISTER- FOR CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS OR TODAY'S
REQUIREMENTS. SO WE WANTED TO
LAY IT OUT BEACH WILL BE WHAT
THIS WOULD ALL LOOK LIKE
UNDERDEVELOPMENT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK. AND HOW THESE
PROGRAMS WOULD FIT TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE A MORE COHESIVE AND
COORDINATED APPROACH TO COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY IN CALIFORNIA. SO
THESE LINES HERE REPRESENT THE
EFCC CUT OFF THAT WE'VE BEEN
SPEAKING ABOUT THIS LINE
DESIGNATES ZERO EST POPULATION
WHICH HAS A MEDIAN INCOME OF
ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS SO
THEY'RE QUITE- FINANCIALLY
VULNERABLE. AND FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS THE PROMISE
GRANT PROGRAM WOULD CONTINUE TO
COVER TUITION FEES FOR STUDENTS
WITH THIS EXCEPT BY NANCIAL
NEED. WHILE THE FEDERAL PELL
GRANTS AS WELL AS A STUDENTS
WITH DEPENDENT CHILDREN GRANT
OR CAL GRANT YOU AWARD WOULD BE
pAVAILABLE TO HELP SUPPORT THEM
IN COVERING THEIR BASIC NEEDS
EXPENSES. AND MOVING BEYOND THE
ZERO ESE- CUT OFF POINT. THE
STUDENTS WOULD CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE A PELL GRANT BUT IT
DOES TAPER DOWN AS YOU APPROACH
SHOULD BE- FIVE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX DOLLARS EST
POINT. ON THE- GIVE THE CSU
SIDE IT'S LISTED HERE YOU SEE
THAT CULPRIT FOR WOULD COVER
TO. AND FEES FOR ALL STUDENTS
ELIGIBLE FOR THAT PELL GRANTS-
YES CD. THAT HAS A MEDIAN
INCOME OF FIFTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THOSE STUDENTS ALL
QUALIFIED FOR A PELL GRANT OF
SOME KIND. AND WE PROPOSE THAT
ZERO EST STUDENT PARENTS
RECEIVE THAT STUDENT PARENTS
WITH DEPENDENT CHILDREN GRANT
AWARD FOR ADDITIONAL NON
TUITION. ASSISTANCE
INSTITUTIONAL AID WOULD THAT-
BE LAYERED OVER- THESE
INVESTMENTS TO PROVIDE GREATER
SUPPORT FOR BASIC NEEDS FOR
ZERO EST STUDENTS. ALL BEYOND
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE CALGARY FOR
INTEL GRANT THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP WOULD CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE A PERCENTAGE OF TUITION
COVERAGE. THE INSTITUTIONAL AID
COULD HELP CLOSE THE GAP. AS
WE- START TO CONCLUDE HERE JUST
A FEW OTHER QUICK NOTES- WE
WOULD PROPOSE DAY ANY STUDENT
RECEIVING A PELL GRANT UNDER
TODAY'S RULES BE GRANDFATHERED
INTO THE PROGRAM AND BE ALLOWED
TO CONTINUE TO RECEIVE. THEIR
EXISTING CAL GRANT UNTIL THEIR
ELIGIBILITY WERE TO EXPIRE. I'M
THAT DOES COME WITH A ONE TIME
TRANSITION COSTS WE CAN SHARE
MORE WITH YOU ABOUT THAT THE
QUESTIONS. AND DID MODELING-
WHAT WOULD BE A POSSIBLE UNDER
THIS FRAMEWORK AND WE KEPT
FUNDING CONSISTENT. FOR
STUDENTS ENROLLED EACH SEGMENT
AND WE'VE NOT- PROPOSED ANY
SHIFTING OF DOLLARS FROM ONE
SEGMENT. TO ANOTHER WHAT YOU
SEE HERE. WE DO THINK THERE ARE
OTHER- IMPORTANT POLICIES THAT
ARE AT THAT YOU CONSIDER AS WE-
MOVE FORWARD IN. ADVANCING CAL
GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK AND CAL
GRANT MODERNIZATION-
PARTICULARLY OF NOTE WELL THE
CALTRAIN AWARDS AT THE YOU SEE
IN THE C. IF YOU ARE CONNECTED
TO TUITION. INCREASE AWARDS AND
PROGRAM COSTS AS TUITION RATES
GO UP THERE IS CURRENTLY NO-
MECHANISM FOR OUR ACCESS AWARDS
FOR NON TUITION COSTS- TO
INCREASE AS THOSE EXPENSES DO
AS AS WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING.
I'M WITH THE COST OF LIVING-
ISSUES FACING OUR STUDENTS- SO
WE DO THINK THAT THE GROWTH IN
DEXTER OTHER METRIC TO KEEP CAL
GRANT TO. AWARD THE CONTRACT
WITH NON TUITION COSTS I'M
WOULD. HELP ADDRESS THIS
INEQUITY IN COULD. ZERO OF THE
AWARDS. POWER OVER. SIMILARLY
EXTERMINATOR HAS SUPPORTED
RESTORATION OF A FORMULA AWARD-
FOR GRANTS TO STUDENTS ENROLLED
AT A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
INSTITUTIONS. AND WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL ABILITY
OF. L. GRANT FOR SUMMER
PROGRAMS COULD REALLY BE
IMPACTFUL AND HELPING MORE
STUDENTS GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS
AND GRADUATE ON TIME- WITHOUT
REDUCING THEIR ELIGIBILITY FOR
CAL GRANT ASSISTANCE DURING THE
TRADITIONAL ACADEMIC YEAR. SO
WE THINK THAT'S ALSO A VERY
WORTHWHILE CONSIDERATION. THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF OR SEE
THAT NOTED THAT- CHANGES TO THE
FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID POLICIES-
THAT'LL BE COMING ONLINE IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AND IT AS
SHE NOTED THIS IS REALLY GREAT
NEWS FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
AND OUR STATE OF MORE STUDENTS
WILL RECEIVE A PELL GRANTS MORE
STUDENTS WERE ALREADY ELIGIBLE
FOR A PELL GRANT WILL RECEIVE A
HIGHER REWARD- IT DOES REQUIRE
US TO UPDATE OUR MODELING AT
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION- BUT
THAT BEING SAID. I'M WE DON'T
THINK THAT THEY'LL BE ANY-
SHIFT SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH THAT
WE WOULD CHANGE THE FRAMEWORK
WE GOT LIKE YEAR OF A CAL GRANT
TO AND CAL GRANT FOR AWARD.
HOWEVER WE WOULD IMPACT JUST
THAT THIS REALLY- FOR OUR
POLICY MAKERS CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSIDER HOW DO
WE BEST LEVERAGE FEDERAL STATE
AND INSTITUTIONAL AID SOURCES
IN CONCERT TO MOST. EFFECTIVELY
SERVE OUR STUDENTS. SO
TECHNICALLY I WON TO LEAVE YOU
WITH A WHAT WE GET THE STUDENT
COMMISSION E. AS THE KEY OUT.
OF THIS TELL IN EQUITY
FRAMEWORK AND IT'S A TOP- WE
WOULD STREAMLINE CAL GRANT TO
BE MORE EASILY UNDERSTOOD BY
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES AND
COMMUNICATED BY EDUCATORS AND
COUNSELORS. WE WOULD ALIGN
ELIGIBILITY FOR STATE BASED
DATE WITH FEDERAL POLICY. WE
DON'T LIMIT AB ELIGIBILITY
BARRIERS FOR STATE AID THAT ARE
NOT CONNECTED STUDENTS
FINANCIAL NEED. AND WE CAN
TARGET STATE RESOURCES TO THE
MOST FINANCIALLY VULNERABLE
STUDENTS THAT WERE CERTAIN.
NUMBER TANGIBLY AB CAL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK WOULD YOU'LL
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE RELATIVE CHIU TODAY'S
CURRENT CALIBER AND STANDARDS.
OUR STATE WOULD BE ABLE TO
BETTER LEVERAGE FEDERAL
FUNDING- AS WE WERE DISCUSSING
EARLIER WITH THE TUITION FEE
AWARDS- BY OFFERING MORE CAL
GRANT FOR AWARDS COVER TUITION
COSTS. AND IN OFFERING FORTY
THOUSAND MORE CAL GRANT FOR
WORKS TO COVER TUITION FEES
THAT MEANS FORTY THOUSAND MORE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS COULD
RECEIVE THAT LETTER THAT LETS
THEM KNOW THEY'VE RECEIVED A
TENANT FUNDED BENEFIT. AND ARE
ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR CALFRESH.
THERE WOULD ALSO BE HIGHER
NUMBERS OF STUDENT PARENTS
ADULT LEARNERS AND CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT FILERS WHO BECOME
ELIGIBLE FOR STATE AID UNDER
THE CALTRAIN EQUITY FRAMEWORK
AND I KNOW THESE ARE ALL
STUDENT POPULATIONS THAT ARE OF
PARTICULAR CONCERN TO FIX
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND WE WOULD
ALSO- CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK- MAKER SYSTEM MORE
INCLUSIVE PARTICULARLY FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO
STUDENTS. SO I'M- INCLUDING
JUST LIKE TO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
TODAY I KNOW THIS IS A LOT OF
INFORMATION BE PROVIDED SO-
AFTER YOU HEAR OUR- STUDENT
PARTNER OF MR LEWIS SPEAK. A
MORE CERTAINLY I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS AND
I'LL BE JOINED BY PATRICK PERRY
OUR DIRECTOR OF DATA ANALYSIS
AND RESEARCH WHO OVERSAW THE
DATA MODELING- UNDERLINED THIS
PROPOSAL AND CAN HELP ANSWER
ANY MORE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ON
THE DATA. THANK YOU. THE STATE.
OKAY YEAH. PLEASE PER STATE.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU ALL TODAY MY NAME
IS JOSH LEWIS I'M A JUNIOR AT
UC BERKELEY I'M HONORED TO
SERVE AS THE CHAIR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENT ASSOCIATION TO YOUR
BEFORE YOU ON BEHALF OF THE FIX
FINANCIAL AID COALITION FORMED
JUST UNDER THREE YEARS AGO BUT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION THE STUDENT SENATE
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION. TOGETHER
REPRESENTING THE STATE'S THREE
MILLION STUDENTS OF PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION EXPONENTIALLY
IS ABOUT BRINGING OUR STUDENT
LEADERS TOGETHER AROUND COMMON
PRINCIPLES FOR FINANCIAL REFORM
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS THOSE
PRINCIPLES TO YOU ON BEHALF OF
OUR THREE ASSOCIATIONS AND TALK
ABOUT OUR ASPIRATION FOR REFORM
ONE THAT ADDRESSES THE EQUITY
AND AFFORDABILITY CAPS FACING
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE. I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST THANK YOU FOR THE WORK OF
THE ASSEMBLY AND THIS COMMITTEE
OUTLINING A STATE BUDGET
BLUEPRINT THAT CENTRALIZES
STUDENT MATTERS AND PRIORITIES
AND FUNDING FOR OUR THREE
SEGMENTS AND THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION TO MEMPHIS WORKING
WITH STUDENT LEADERS
PARTICULARLY THOSE MOST
IMPACTED BY TODAY'S CHALLENGES
OR SOMETHING WE ARE INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL FOR US THIS COMMITTEE
DISCUSSES FUNDING FOR THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND
EQUITY. SENATE MODERNIZATION OF
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS. THE
ELEVEN MONTHS PRESENTED SOME OF
THE- INTENSE. CHILD THAT
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
FACED IN RECENT HISTORY. AS AN
RA AT UC BERKELEY I WAS OUT OF
HOUSING WITHOUT WARNING BY THE
BEGINNING OF APRIL. WITH THE
LOSS OF MY CAMPUS JOB NO CAMPUS
HOUSING OR ACCESS TO MY CAMPUS
MEAL PLAN. I WAS FORCED TO MOVE
ON. MY ROLE COMMUNITY IN AMADOR
COUNTY HAD INCREDIBLY POOR
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
WE'RE NOT FOR THE ADVOCACY OF
STUDENTS LIKE ME SECURING
ACADEMICALLY NANCY. MY AGE
ELIGIBILITY WOULD HAVE
SUFFERED. I WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT MY STORY REPRESENTS THE
BEST CASE SCENARIO FOR STUDENTS
OVER THE PAST YEAR. SOME LOSS
OF HOUSING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES COMBINED
PHILOSOPHY TO ELIGIBILITY. AND
ALL OF THE OTHER EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC RESULTED IN AN
UNPRECEDENTED BASIC NEEDS
INSECURITY. UNABLE TO ACCESS
RELIABLE INTERNET STUDENTS
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE COULD NOT
BE MAINTAINED. BEARING THE
WEIGHT OF EVERYTHING I JUST
DESCRIBED STUDENTS MENTAL
HEALTH SUFFERED GREATLY. AND
PERHAPS WORST OF ALL STUDENTS
RELYING ON AID DISBURSEMENTS
WERE DENIED THAT IT DID BECAUSE
OF A CHANGE IN LIVING
CIRCUMSTANCES. ECONOMIC
BARRIERS BEING THROWN UP AT
EVERY TURN COULD NOT BE
OVERCOME BY THE LEVELS OF EIGHT
AND PROGRAMMATIC. RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO OUR STUDENTS. WELL
THE PANDEMIC SEARCH EXAM. THE
DEEP EQUITIES IN OUR FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEMS. AND PUSH. EQUITIES
ARE NOT NEW TO US. FIRST THE
AMOUNT OF STUDENTS THAT ARE
TRULY IN NEED OF FINANCIAL IT
HAS ONLY GROWN. AS THE COST OF
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA INCREASE
WITH TIME AND WE STRIVE TO MAKE
ACCESS TO OUR INSTITUTIONS MORE
EQUITABLE. NATURALLY MORE
STUDENTS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
BE AFFORDED ACCESS ARE DENIED
IT BASED ON THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY. FOR THE RELATIVE SIZE OF
DIFFERENT POOLS OF H. SHRINK.
MORE AND MORE STUENTS ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THE DEBT FREE
HIGHER EDUCATION PATHWAY. THE
DECISION THAT STUDENTS APPLYING
TO CCC CSU AND UC HAVE TO MAKE.
IS WHETHER OR NOT THEIR
FAMILIES CAN AFFORD THE SHORT
TERM BUT DRAMATIC COSTS OF
SEEKING HIGHER EDUCATION. AND
THE LONG TERM COSTS OF ITS
ASSOCIATED DEBT. BURDEN OF THIS
DEBT IS HELP DRASTICALLY
DISPROPORTIONATELY WITH BLACK
AND BROWN STUDENTS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE LIKELY TO
SEE ADVERSE EFFECTS. THERE IS A
PRESSING NEED FOR STUDENT AID
TO BE GRANTED YEAR ROUNDS WERE
INCREASINGLY RELYING ON GREATER
ACADEMIC AND FINANCIAL
FLEXIBILITY. FULLY FUNDING OUR
STATE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEMS ALL
HOPING TO ENSURE A COHESIVE AND
HOLISTIC INVESTMENT. INTO
FINANCIAL AID FROM OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS OF PARAMOUNT
IMPORTANCE. SECOND THING CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS NEEDS TO BE
REFORMED TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
EVER INCREASING TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE. BUT STUDENTS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION FACE.
POLITICIAN AND FEAST CERTIFIED
AND ECONOMIC OBSTACLE TO MANY
STUDENTS. AND MUST CONTINUE TO
BE COVERED BY FINANIAL AID.
ADDITIONAL COST OF ATTENDANCE
PRESENTS AN EQUALLY LARGE IF
NOT LARGER HERBAL. PERSONALLY
THE ONLY REASON MY NON TUITION
COSTS OF ATTENDANCE DO NOT
EXCEED MY TUITION. IT'S BECAUSE
I WORK AS AN RA TO SECURE
HOUSING AND FOOD. ALL TOO
FREQUENTLY THESE COSTS ARE ON
ANTICIPATED AND IMPOSSIBLE TO
PLAN FOR. THE MOST OBVIOUS OF
THESE ADDITIONAL COSTS OF
ATTENDING A COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY TO CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING INCLUDING HOUSING
FOOD AND OTHER BASIC NEEDS.
HOWEVER RECOGNITION OF THE
ADDED ECONOMIC PRESSURES OF
TRANSPORTATION MENTAL HEALTH
CARE AND TEXTBOOKS. TO NAME A
FEW IT IS CRITICAL TO ENSURING.
THAT STUDENTS DON'T JUST HAVE
THEIR NEEDS MET ON PAPER BY
COMPARING TUITION AND FEES. TO
A PROPOSED AID PACKAGE BUT ARE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO AFFORD
ATTENDANCE. HOLISTIC
REIMAGINING OF THE TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE OF OUR STATE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES. IS
REQUIRED ON AN INSTITUTIONAL
AND STATE. LEVEL TO MAKE THIS
RECOGNITION HAPPEN. THE CURRENT
COVERAGE SYSTEM PRESS A NUMBER
ARTISTS. YET REMOVABLE. TO
STUDENT HOW THEIR NEEDS. BY
SIMPLY NOT A KALRA IT'S NEED TO
COMES. THE URGENT NEED TO
STREAMLINE THE CAL GRANT
APPLICATION PROCESS IS KEENLY
FELT. STUDENTS ARE REGULARLY
DENIED ACCESS SEATING EIGHTY
TWO TO MISUNDERSTANDINGS OF
APPLICATION PROCESS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT. ACCESS ADDITIONALLY
ENSURING THAT THE CULPRIT
APPLICATION IS PROPERLY
INTEGRATED TO THE APPLICATION
PROCESSES. OTHER POOLS OF STATE
ESOURCES LIKE CALFRESH WILL
MEAN THAT NO STUDENT MISSES OUT
ON HELP THEY QUALIFY FOR. THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS THE
CAL GRANT THEMSELVES REPRESENT
A SEEMINGLY ARBITRARILY DENIAL
OF ECONOMIC ACCESS AS WELL.
RESTRICTIONS TO CALTRAIN ACCESS
BASED ON AGE TOTAL TERMS IN
ATTENDANCE TIME OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL AND GPA SERVE TO STOP
OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE PEOPLE
WISHING TO SEEK HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR BEING ABLE TO DO
SO. BESIDES EXTENDING TO LIMIT
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF STUDENTS
RECEIVING AID THESE
REQUIREMENTS ARE NEEDLESSLY
CONVOLUTED. PRESENTING EVEN
ANOTHER LAYER OF
INACCESSIBILITY. THIS
RESTRICTIONS ALSO CREATES SELF
PERPETUATING LOSSES OF EIGHT. I
SPEAK FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WHEN I SAY THAT ECONOMIC
INSECURITY BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
JUST A PERSONAL CHALLENGE BUT
AN ACADEMIC ONE. RIGHT TO BE
STRIPPED OF MY EIGHT BECAUSE OF
THE RESULTS OF THESE ACADEMIC
CHALLENGES NOT ONLY WITH MY
ABILITY TO FINANCIALLY ACCESS
YOU SEE BE THREATENED. BY
ECONOMIC MY ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE WOULD CERTAINLY
SUFFER AS A RESULT. THESE
ARBITRARY METRICS BY WHICH
EIGHT ELIGIBILITY IS DETERMINED
NEED TO BE REMOVED IN ORDER TO
ADVANCE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO OUR
INSTITUTIONS. OF THE COALITION
REPRESENTING STUDENTS THE
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION WE'VE
BEEN INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COLLABORATE WITH C. SACK ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE CAL RANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND C. SACK TO MEET
THE AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES.
OF CODE NINETEEN AND REMOVE THE
LONGSTANDING INEQUITIES
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA FACED.
THANK. YOU AND I'M I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIS IS A
AND IN ITEM. THERE IS-
COMPANION LEGISLATION THAT WE
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I'M A DENIER ARE WORKING
ON BUT THIS IS A BUDGET ISSUE
AS WELL REALIZE THAT IN ORDER
TO IMPLEMENT THIS WE WOULD
NEED. TO RAMP UP- COMMITMENT IN
THE STATE BUDGET SO- IS A MULTI
YEAR PROCESS AND FIRST OF ALL
MISS MEDINA LIMITED THANK THE
STUDENT COMMISSION AND- MARLENE
GARCIA AND THAT THE TEAM WHO
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
US FOR SEVERAL YEARS- WE THINK
WE HAVE A SOLID PLAN OF WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO DO A ROAD MAP IS
WE SHOW THAT COMMITMENT. TO
MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS- I DO I
DO KNOW THAT THE OVERALL
PICTURE THIS IS TO HELP. MORE
NEEDY STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA-
AND I THINK IT'S WITH THE GOAL
TO SIMPLIFY IT SO I LIKE.
HAVING THAT THE TO IN THE FOR
AT FIRST GLANCE YOU LIKE WHAT
YOU HAVE FOR NEW CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS BUT NOW IT'S FOR ONE
FOR TWO YEARS STUDENTS AND ONE
FOR. FOR YOUR STUDENTS I THINK
THAT'S- THAT'S THAT SIMPLIFIES
AS WELL AS WELL AS- THE
CORRESPONDING ON MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP WHICH I KNOW MY-
COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH HAS
SOME. COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
ABOUT IN IN IN A FEW MOMENTS
BUT- I JUST WANNA KNOW THAT
WERE CONTINUE CONTINUALLY
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE- TO HOPEFULLY. PUTTING A
DOWN PAYMENT. INTO IN IN
SPENDING- THE CAL GRANT
FINANCIALLY SYSTEM CALIFORNIA.
ARE FOCUSING ON ON NON TUITION
COSTS I THINK THAT'S THE- AT
THE CRUX HERE IS HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE- FOCUS ON THE
REALITY OF THE COLLEGE STUDENTS
TODAY. IT'S YOU KNOW. THE CAL
GRANT IS A GREAT- SYSTEM WE'VE
HAD FOR DECADES HERE WHO MADE
ENTITLEMENT TWENTY ONE YEARS
AGO. BUT THE COST OF COLLEGE OR
ARE GENETICALLY CHANGED BY THE
HOUSING COSTS IN TRANSPORTATION
IN BOOKS AND- FOOD AND SO FORTH
SO THE QUESTION IS VERY
DIFFERENT AND SO. ARE OUR VIEW
IS- HOW YOU COULD MAKE COLLEGE.
MORE AFFORDABLE AND FRANKLY
DEBT FREE IN CALIFORNIA SO.
THERE'S ANOTHER LIGHT
CONVERSATION ABOUT FREE COLLEGE
ACROSS OUR NATION BUT- I THINK
THE REAL EQUATION IS HOW WE CAN
FOCUS ON MAKING IT A DEBT FREE
SO. OF COURSE THE STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES DEPEND ON THEIR
INCOME HAVE SOME EXPECTED. THAT
CONTRIBUTION COUPLED WITH.
FINANCIAL AID FROM THE FEDERAL
STATE GOVERNMENT WE REALLY
COULD MAKE IT. FEASIBLE FOR
STUDENTS TO GRADUATE WITH
MINIMAL DEBT AND I THINK YOU
KNOW THAT. WOULD BE A BIG. BIG
WIN HIM CALIFORNIA SO. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS BUT WE
WANT TO GET. THE THE COMMISSION
AS WELL AS THE COALITION
OPPORTUNITY TO. TO TESTIFY HERE
THIS MORNING- I KNOW- MISTER
MEDINA HAD TO STEP OUT FOR A
BIT BUT HE WANTED ME TO SHARE
THOSE COMMENTS. I MAY COME BACK
WITH SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES BUT
ALL START OFF WITH- MISTER
O'DONNELL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
PRESENTATIONS AND- TRYING TO BE
AS CREATIVE AS POSSIBLE. TO
SERVE STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
AND ULTIMATELY ENSURE THEM
SUCCESS- AND OUR ECONOMY
SUCCESS- JUST MY CONCERNS- YOU
HEARD HIM EARLIER WITH REGARD
TO THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
FROM THEM COS- HOW WILL THE
PROPOSED CHANGES IMPACT THE
NUMBER. OF PARTICIPANTS IN THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP. I
DON'T KNOW WHO THAT WHO WOULD
BEST BE. PREPARED TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL AND AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR GARCIA NOTED IN HER
REMARKS- WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO
HAVING- CAL GRANT PROGRAMS AND
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAMS THAT WORK IN CONCERT
TO SUPPORT. BOTH OUR LOW INCOME
AND OUR MIDDLE INCOME UPDATE
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES SO. IT'S
PRESENTED TO YOU TODAY WE
DIDN'T INCLUDE ANY SPECIFIC-
EFCC LAME OR CUT OFF POINT FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM THAT'S WHAT WE WOULD
NEED TO- IN ORDER TO. GET BACK
TO AND IDENTIFY HOW MANY
STUDENTS THAN WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
AWARD OR ENROLLED AT THE- YOU
SEE IN THE CSU- BUT WE WOULD-
PROPOSED IT IT BEGIN WHERE THE
CAL GRANT FOUR ENDS. TODAY THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP IMPACT
FILLING HOLES- FURTHER DOWN THE
INCOME LADDER IN FACT THAT ARE
CREATED BY THE LACK OF
ELIGIBILITY FOR CALIFORNIA WORK
THERE'S NO. INCOME FLOOR ON
THIS PROGRAM SO TO SPEAK SO-
IMPACTED WE WOULD SEE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP DOLLARS BE
SHIFTED TO FOCUSING ON THOSE-
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WHO.
THOUGHT THAT TELEGRAM- CUT OFF
POINT AND- ALL MAYBE BECAUSE
THERE TO SEE IF MY- COLLEAGUE-
PATRICK PERRY I'M HAS ANYTHING
PROPONENTS YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE
OUR DATA- QUESTION THAT YOU
PASSED. THANK YOU JACK UP
PATRICK PERRY DIRECTOR PA. RE
INTO STUDENICA. SO WORK MAKING
A- HUGE PROPOSED CHANGES TO M.
C. S. OTHER THAN JUST ALIGNING
IT WITH THE PROPOSAL FOR CAL
GRANT FOR. ME IN DFAR
NUMBER OF MCS TOWARDS- I
WOULDN'T EXPECT THAT TO CHANGE
FROM WHERE WE'RE AT NOW. MCS
THIS LIMITED BASICALLY BY THE
AMOUNT OF THE PROGRAM- AND WE-
SPLIT IT UP. YOU KNOW STARTING
BASED UPON WHERE WHERE IT
BEGINS IN THE INCOME LEVEL AND
MOVING TO THE RIGHT UNTIL WE
EXHAUST ALL THE MONEY. SO I
WOULD ANTICIPATE THERE BEING
ANY. DRAMATIC CHANGES THE
NUMBER OF AWARDS. GREAT THANK
YOU. WELL OF THE FEEDBACK I'VE
HEARD IS THAT THERE IS I HAVE
HEARD CONCERNED THAT THIS IS
KIND OF THE SLOW KILL. ARE YOU
KNOW AN ATTACK ON THE MISSION
OF THE LITTLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
SO- I'LL BE WATCHING THIS CLOSE
AND TWO OTHERS WILL. APPRECIATE
YOUR FEEDBACK ON T. BUT I
THINK IT OUT OF THE GATE DOES
STRIKE ME AS A CUT TO THE
PROGRAM. OR AN IMPACT IN THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WILL SERVE.
LISTEN TO THE PERSPECTIVE I
HAVE AS CALIFORNIA DOES LITTLE
VERY LITTLE FOR THE MIDDLE
CLASS AND THIS IS ONE PROGRAM.
ACTUALLY DOES HELP THE MIDDLE
CLASS. SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME THAT WE SUSTAIN IT. AND
THAT IT NOT BE TAMPED DOWN-
CUT. OR OR JUST- YOU KNOW. NOT
MEET ITS ORIGINAL INTENT OR
MISSION. SO I THANK YOU FOR THE
FEEDBACK ON THAT I'LL BE
WATCHING THIS ISSUE AND OTHERS
WILL. VERY CLOSELY BECAUSE I
THINK THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP SOMETHING WE NEED
TO EXPAND ON. NOT CONTRACT WITH
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU THE
CAN WE JUST DIG IN A LITTLE BIT
DEEPER ON THIS MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP ISSUE. COM IT'S NOT
JUST- MISTER O'DONNELL I AM
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE I THINK
IT WAS A GREAT IDEA LAUNCHED BY
OUR FORMER SPEAKER JOHN PEREZ
NOW ARE CHAIR THE UC REGENTS.
AND I THINK IT DOES ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE ARE STUDENTS WHO IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU YOU KNOW PEOPLE
MAKE OVER A HUNDRED. RAND ARE
ARE SET BUT WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
NOT TRUE YOU CAN BE A TEACHER
AND A NURSE OR FIREFIGHTER- YOU
KNOW PUBLIC SERVICE WORKER. AND
LIVE IN A HIGH COST AREA AND
YOU CERTAINLY ARE NOT ARE NOT
RICH AND SO- AND I THINK THAT
IT WAS A FAIR PROPOSAL THAT
DOESN'T COVER. THE FULL TUITION
UNDER THE CAL GRANT BUT IT
COVERS- A SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF
THE TUITION FOR UC AND CSU. SO
CAN YOU WALK THROUGH A BIT MORE
AS FAR AS WHAT YOU'RE I KNOW
IT'S NOT YOU KNOW A PLAN HERE
TODAY BUT WHAT YOUR BIG
PICTURE- IDEAS ARE ON
MODERNIZING- THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP n
OVERALL. I REFORM. THANK YOU
CHAIR MCCARTY AND I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE SOME MORE DETAILS ON WHAT
WE'RE ENVISIONING- FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP. UNDER
THIS PROGRAM WE FRAMEWORK- SO
THIS PROGRAM WOULD AGAIN PICK
UP WHERE ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA OR WOULD AND- THAT-
CLIMATE. THAT IS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT YES THE POINT OF FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX. THE WAY THE PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED TODAY THERE ARE
VARIOUS INCOME POINTS THAT
CORRESPOND TO A PERCENTAGE OF
TUITION AND FEES COVERAGE. THAT
IS OFFERED TO THAT STUDENT AT
THE UC OR THE CSU. WE WOULD
PROPOSE ESSENTIALLY
SUBSTITUTING EST FOR INCOME SO
THAT WERE USING THE SAME
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA AT THAT
WE'RE USING- FOR CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS UNDER THE
MODERNIZATION PROPOSAL- BUT WE
WOULDN'T CHANGE THE REMAINING
ASPECTS OF THE- THE FINANCIAL
STRUCTURE OF THE PROGRAM. IT
WOULD CONTINUE TO PROVIDE A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF TUITION
FEE COVERAGE JUST STUDENTS
WITH. GREATER FINANCIAL NEED
AND LESS FAMILY SUPPORT SO
STUDENTS WITH A LOWER ESP. AND
ADDS WE MOVED UP THE EST A
SPECTRUM YOU WOULD SEE THAT
PERCENTAGE TAPER DOWN UNTIL THE
MINIMUM TEN PERCENT. OF TUITION
AND FEES THAT THE PROGRAM
CURRENTLY COVERS. SO NUMBER YOU.
THERE WOULD BE FEWER. MULTIPLE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP BUT IF
YOU'RE THE UPPER END OF THE END.
YOU WOULD GET LESS AS A REBATE
FOR YEAR UC TUITION ESSENTIALLY.
WHICH YES YESFOR SURE THAT'S
EXACTLY HOW THE PROGRAM WORKS
TODAY AND AS HE SPOKE TO THE
ONLY CONSIDERATION FOR POLICY
MAKERS WOULD THEN BE WHERE DO
YOU WANT TO DEFINE THAT- YET
SEE A CEILING IN THIS CASE- AND
IF THAT INCOME CEILING HAS
INCREASED OVER TIME TO NEARLY
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AS
YOU NOTED IN YOUR OPENING
REMARKS- AND THOSE ARE THE
STUDENTS WHO WERE SEEN AT TEN
PERCENTAGE- A TUITION FEE
COVERAGE. OKAY. I'LL COME BACK
A BIT MR GALLAGHER. SO ONE OF
MY CONCERNS WITH BECAUSE THIS
PROPOSAL IS. I THINK WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO GET OUT THE RIGHT THE
SAME THING WHICH IS HOW DO WE
BEST SUPPORT STUDENTS. I WANTED
TO OBTAIN EDUCATIONAL GOALS-
AND WE WANT TO SIMPLIFY THE
PROCESS EVERYBODY'S BEEN SAYING
THAT TODAY LIKE MAKE IT- MORE
UNDERSTANDABLE AND EASIER. FOR
STUDENTS- BUT I WORRY ABOUT YOU
KNOW WE'RE ALMOST CREATE
ANOTHER ALMOST SAFETY NET
PROGRAM AND AS- THE- WHERE
WE'RE GONNA COVER THINGS THAT
AREN'T NECESSARILY RELATED TO
LIVING EXPENSES YOU KNOW.
EDUCATIONAL LIVING EXPERIENCE
EXPENSES SO WE'RE WE'RE BASING
EVERYTHING ON A- TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE- MOST OF WHICH THE
REPORT EVEN ACKNOWLEDGES ARE
NON EDUCATIONAL LIVING EXPENSES.
WHICH I THINK COULD HAVE THE
INCENTIVE OF PEOPLE THE SAME
WAY I WANT TO GET SUPPORT.
MAYBE THEY'RE NOT EVEN DOING IT
FOR SCHOOL BUT HEY I'LL SIGN UP
FOR THIS PROGRAM. AND AL GET
ME- COVERAGE ACCORDINGLY- I
DON'T THINK THAT'S WHAT WE WANT
TO DO I DON'T WANT TO CREATE
THAT KIND OF INCENTIVE THE
INCENTIVE IS HEY I WANT TO GET
SUPPORT FOR GOING TO SCHOOL AND
MEETING EDUCATIONAL GOALS IT
NEEDS ANOTHER WORDS. THEY
SHOULD BE MORE OUTCOME BASED.
IN OUR LOOKING AT THIS AS
OPPOSED TO JUST BASING IT ON
INPUTS. OF BETTER ADMITTEDLY
VERY EXPENSIVE- SO I GUESS
THAT'S MY KIND OF CONCERN WITH
OUR WHERE WE'RE KIND OF GOING
WITH THIS RIGHT NOW- AGAIN THE
PROPOSAL IS NOT WITHOUT MERIT.
STREAMLINED ACCESS FOR
QUALIFIED STUDENTS- BUT I THINK
WE BEST SERVE THE STUDENTS AND
TAXPAYERS IF WE FOCUS OUR
RESOURCES ON OUTCOMES- AND NOT
JUST EXPENSIVE INPUTS SO COUPLE
QUESTIONS I HAVE. NO ONE IS.
HOW WE'RE ALLOCATING THIS WE'RE
WE'RE PRIMARILY TARGETING THE
MAJORITY THE CAL GRANT
RESOURCES TOWARDS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. WELL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
IN CALIFORNIA SOME OF THE MOST
AFFORDABLE IN THE COUNTRY I
MEAN WE JUST MADE TUITION FREE-
FIRST YEAR. HE ALSO FOR GONNA
FOCUS ALL THE REFORM OF A LOT
OF. MONEY THERE I DON'T KNOW
THAT MAKES THE MOST SENSE BUT
YOU KNOW PLEASE COMMENT WHY ARE
WHY ARE WE FOCUSING MOST OF.
THE CAL GRANT RESOURCES ON CCC
STUDENTS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION IS THE ONLY NUMBER AND
I THINK. WE SHARE YOUR CONCERN
AND YOUR FOCUS ON STUDENT
OUTCOMES AND I THINK OUR OUR
WORK IS I'M IN LARGE PART
MOTIVATED BY- WHAT WE HEAR FROM
STUDENTS ABOUT THE BARRIERS
THAT CAN BE CREATED BY THOSE
EXPENSES. I'M AS WE'RE OFFERING
THEM ASSISTANCE FOR TUITION AND
FEES SO MANY OF THEM ARE
TELLING US THAT THEIR CALLS FOR
BUT IT LOOKS HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION. ARE THEN-
REALLY MAKING IT CHALLENGING
FOR THEM TO FOCUS ON THEIR
STUDIES THEIR WORKING HOURS
THAT DOWN AND SAYS HE EIGHT-
WITH ACADEMIC SUCCESS BEYOND-
YOU KNOW FIFTEEN OR TWENTY
HOURS THE MOST RESEARCH WOULD
SUCCESS IS HELPFUL. I'M JUST
USE POST GRADUATION- YOU KNOW
THAT BEING SAID IN TERMS OF THE
ACTUAL FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS- THE
VAST MAJORITY OF DOLLARS WOULD
ACTUALLY CAN WOULD CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE TUITION FEE COVERAGE AT
THE UC AND CSU. WE DIDN'T HAVE
THIS LISTED ON A SLIDE BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT- THE FUNDING
CHANGE- THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH
THE OPTIONS WE'VE LAID OUT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA. COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAM BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY CHEAPER ONE FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WOULD BE
GOING OUT AS- A COUPLE GRAND
FOR AWARD TO STUDENTS AT THESE
INSTITUTIONS WHEREAS IN A ONE
YEAR APPLICATIONS NEW
RECIPIENTS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- UNDER CURRENT PLANS
WOULD RECEIVE SOMETHING CLOSER
TO ONE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. SO WE SPENT THE TIME
I'M TALKING ABOUT THIS COST
OPTIONS FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS I'M OUT OF RECOGNITION
THAT THOSE ARE THE STUDENTS
THAT ARE STATE OR THE LEAST
LIKELY TO RECEIVE THE SUPPORT.
FOR THE NON TUITION COSTS THAT-
I'VE CREATED SO MANY BARRIERS
FOR THEIR PERSISTENCE AND THEIR
COMPLETION AND IT ALSO MEANT WE
MEANS- YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
MAKING THE BEST. A WE'RE NOT
DRIVING THE BEST RETURN ON OUR
INVESTMENT IN OUR POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION PROGRAMS
AND ARE I'M TUITION FEE
COVERAGE IF WE CAN. HELP THE
STUDENTS ULTIMATELY COMPLETE.
RIGHT ARE WE GET A FOR THE
OTHERS TO SAID THIS POINT IN
TIME BECAUSE SOUNDS TO ME LIKE
WE I HEAR IS THAT WE'RE NOT
EVEN REALLY GET IT DONE. TO
HELP. YES STUDENTS AT OTHER.
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS. SO
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO ON FOCUS AND
PUT A BUNCH OF RESOURCES AND-
HERE. AND WE'RE NOT REALLY. SO
MADE I GUESS MY NEXT QUESTION
IS DO WE WHEN WE LOOK AT
STUDENT LOAN BALANCES RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW EXISTING STUDENT LOAN
BALANCES DOES THAT GIVE YOU ANY
INSIGHT INTO WHERE. YOU KNOW
THE FINANCIAL NEED OF STUDENTS
ARE WHETHER IT'S IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CSU OR UC. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT
RESEARCH HAS DEMONSTRATED THAT
THE YOU SEEM TO SEE IF YOU IT'S
VERY OFTEN IN FACT OUR LOWEST
INCOME STUDENTS WERE ALREADY
RECEIVING SOME FORM OF NEED
BASED FINANCIAL AID WE STILL
ENCOURAGE THE LARGEST LEVELS OF
STUDENT DEBT. UPON GRADUATION
THE PICTURES A LITTLE BIT LESS
CLEAR AT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
MANY OF WHICH WERE NOT OFFERING
STUDENT LOANS TO OUR STUDENTS
THAT THEY WERE SURVEYING-
BEFORE THE- ENACTMENT OF AB
NINETEEN IN THE COLLEGE PROMISE
PROGRAM. I'M SO THERE'S LESS-
STUDENT LOAN DEBT INCURRED A ON
AVERAGE BY A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT- BUT THERE ARE STILL
SIGNIFICANT SOURCES OF- DEBT
AND COST THAT THE STUDENTS ARE
FACING INCLUDING OF COURSE
CREDIT CARDS- AND OTHER FORMS
OF AND THINGS THAT DON'T HAVE
THE SAME I'M HOPEFUL INTEREST
RATES TO STUDENTS OF THE LOANS
DO- WE ACTUALLY AT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION WE RECEIVED
FUNDS. TO CONVENE IN A STUDENT
LOAN AND DEBT SERVICE REVIEW
WORKER WHERE THESE QUESTIONS
ARE BEING EXPLORED THAT IS
ACTUALLY BEING- CHAIRED BY MY
COLLEAGUE PATRICK HE'S ON THE
LINE TO HELP ANSWER SOME
QUESTIONS ON THE DATA SO- I'LL
PAUSE HERE AND BE PATRICK MIGHT
HAVE SOME. ADDITIONAL INSIGHT.
IN YOUR QUESTION ON STUDENT
LOAN DEBT- THANKS JAKE- I
ACTUALLY. HAVE A NEED FOR.
READILY ON STUDENT LOAN
BALANCES BY SEGMENT. ON THE
GENERAL NATIONAL TRENDS ARE-
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
YOUR HAVE A LARGER NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WITH LOANS BUT THEIR
LOAN AMOUNTS WILL BE SMALLER.
AT FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS
YOU'LL HAVE FEWER STUDENTS BUT
THEIR AVERAGE LOAN AMOUNTS WILL
BE LARGER ACROSS TE ACTUAL
LARGEST LOAN AMOUNTS OF TEND TO
BE ON THE BOOKS FOR STUDENTS
WHO ARE GRAD STUDENTS WHO
CUMULATE A LOT OF GRADUATE
STUDENT DEBT SO. THERE'S A
DIFFERENT BALANCE BETWEEN A LOT
ALONG WITH A SMALL AMOUNT AND A
FEW WITH A VERY LARGE AMOUNT.
RIGHT RIGHT BUT BOTTOM LINE
WHAT WE ARE SEEN AS A THERE'S A
LOT OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS AT.
WHAT ARE THE SE NON SI NON-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE INSTITUTIONS
WITH REALLY HIGH LOW ABOUT LOAN
BALANCES RIGHT NOW THAT WHICH
GOES TO MY POINT. I REALLY GET
IT DONE FOR THOSE STUDENTS
RIGHT NOW. AND IF WE START
ALLOCATING RESOURCES MORE. AND
I'M NOT PICKING ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COMMITTEE COLLEGES IS A
GREAT SYSTEM OF BUT AGAIN I
THINK THE POINT IS IT IS THE
MOST AFFORDABLE- SYSTEM RIGHT
NOW- WITHOUT GETTING A CALL
LIVING WHICH I KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S I'M SORRY IT'S A
HIGH COST STATE TO LIVE IN AND
THAT'S A WHOLE NOTHER
DISCUSSION THAT WE CAN GET INTO
AND EVERYBODY FACES THOSE
LIVING COSTS- BUT IN TERMS OF
THE COST OF THE EDUCATION
ITSELF IS THE MOST. MOST
AFFORDABLE IS MY POINT- I EXAM.
AND GO AHEAD. RESPOND TO YOUR
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAHER. YES THIS IS REALLY A
COMPLEX ISSUE AND HOW WE
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS WITH A
VARIETY OF NEEDS THEY HAVE TO
PERSIST AND GRADUATE FROM
COLLEGE ONE OF THE KEY
PROVISIONS OF THIS. FRAMEWORK
IS TO BETTER LEVERAGE ALL THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF RESOURCES TO
SERVE STUDENTS WHO DO HAVE
THOSE BASIC ME CHALLENGES
WHETHER THEY'RE AT THE FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTIONS OR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THIS
PROPOSAL DOESN'T ONLY FOCUS ON
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IT LOOKS AT
THE WHOLE PICTURE SO FOR
EXAMPLE WITH FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS WE'RE LOOKING AT
INSTITUTIONAL A FEDERAL AGENTS
STATED WORKING IN CONCET. TO
SUPPORT ALL THE TUITION COSTS
AND FOR THOSE STUDENTS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING THE MOST TO PROVIDE
BASIC NEEDS SUPPORT. ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SITE THAT'S
PROBABLY THE AREA THAT THERE'S
BEEN THE GREATEST CENTER
INVESTMENT COMPARED TO THE FOR
YOUR SITE WHICH IS WHY IT
SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE FOCUSING
ATTENTION ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. WE'RE FOCUSING
ATTENTION ON COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BECAUSE THEY PRIMARILY ARE THE
ONES WHO ACCESS IT THROUGH THAT
COMPETITIVE. GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH IS THE LOTTERY PROGRAM SO
MANY OF THEM GET LEFT OUT BUT
WE'RE NOT IGNORING THE NEEDS OF
FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS AS A
MATTER OF FACT A CRITICAL
COMPONENT. OF THIS PROPOSAL IS
HOW WE'RE WORKING WITH
INSTITUTIONAL FINANCIAL AID TO
BACK FEEL TO MAKE SURE THAT
STUDENTS. ESPECIALLY ON THE
LOWER INCOME SIDE GET SOME
SUPPORT IN ADDITION TO JUST
THEIR TUITION BECAUSE TUITION.
COSTS ASIDE THE LIVING EXPENSES
WHETHER YOU GO TO A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OR FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION BASED ON WHERE YOU
LIVE DETERMINES LIVING
EXPENSES. SO EVEN THOUGH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS GET
THEIR FEES WAIVED IN LARGE
PART- OF THE LIVING EXPENSES
REMAIN THE SAME AS THE WORK
PERSON WHO GOES TO YOU SEE. SO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE REALLY LOOKING
AT LIVING EXPENSES- NON TUITION
COSTS IS A KEY COMPONENT OF
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT IS THAT
STUDENTS NEED. TO ACTUALLY
SUCCEED. IN GRADUATE AND
HOPEFULLY IN FOR YOU HERE'S
BECAUSE APPS WE NEED THEM TO
GET THE WORK. AND THE- AN EXAM-
CAL GRANT AFTER YEARS. SO WE
ARE MAKING EVERY EFFORT TO TRY
TO ACCELERATE GRADUATION AND
COMPLETION SO STUDENTS CAN MOVE
ON INTO THE WORKPLACE. OKAY AND
THEN JUST FOLLOWING UP ON WHAT
YOU JUST SAID THERE WERE KIND
OF LEVERAGING FEDERAL AND OTHER
YOU KNOW INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT.
DO WE EXPECT THAT STUDENT MORE
STUDENTS WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
PELL GRANTS. AND CAL GRANTS
BASED ON THE RECENT CHANGES TO
FASTER. WELL THE RECENT CHANGES
ARE PROPOSED FOR FASTER AND
THAT WOULD TAKE PLACE UNTIL
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR BUT WE
DO THINK BY MAKING IT EASIER TO
APPLY MORE STUDENTS WILL LIKELY
APPLY THE MORE IMMEDIATE
CHANGES THAT WILL SEE- IN THE
NEXT- THE NEXT- ACADEMIC
FINANCIALLY CYCLE ARE THE
CHANGES TO THE PELL GRANT
ELIGIBILITY RIGHT AND THAT'S
WHERE MY STAFF ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY RIGHT NOW TO FIGURE
OUT EXACTLY WHAT THAT IMPACT
IS. WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT
MORE STUDENTS WILL BE ELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERAL AID AND THERE IS
THE POTENTIAL TO EVEN INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF PELL GRANT AID
WHICH CURRENTLY IS ABOUT. SIX
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND A YEAR FOR A VERY LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND THERE IS
THE POTENTIAL FOR THAT TO
INCREASE THE FOR EVERY STUDENT
THAT QUALIFIES FOR PELL GRANT
AID THAT'S LESS THAT THE STATE
NEEDS TO PROVIDE BASIC NEEDS
SUPPORT AT THE STATE LEVEL. ARE
YOU HOPEFUL THE NEW CHAIN TO
THE FEDERAL. ARE GOING TO DRAW
MORE RESOURCES TO CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. OKAY AND THEN DOES
THIS PROPOSAL CHANGE THE TOTAL
YEARS OF CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY.
FOR STUDENTS TO START AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. NO IT
DOESN'T WE WE'VE STEP WE STICK
WITH THE SAME OUT FOR YOUR
ELIGIBILITY LIFESPAN OF THE
CALDERON AWARDS CAL GRANT AWARD
DOES LAST FOR SIX YEARS BUT THE
CAL GROUNDWORK CURRENTLY LAST
FOR FOUR YEARS. AND IT'S PRO
RATED IF YOU GO PART TIME.
THAT'S ALL THE QUESTIONS I HAD
MISSED YEAH. THANK YOU I JUST
WANT TO NOTE MR GALLAGHER THAT-
I DON'T THINK IT. IT IT FOCUSES
MORE ON COMMUNITY COLLEGE PER
SE IT'S JUST IT'S BY DEFINITION
THERE ARE WAY MORE. COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
YOU KNOW THERE ARE- THERE ARE
YOU KNOW TWO MILLION COMMITTEE
CALLS TO INVENTING RESEARCH HAS
BEEN DONE THAT SAYS IF YOU LOOK
I KNOW YOU WANT TO CAL. AND IF
YOU LOOK AT WHAT IT COSTS TO GO
TO UC BERKELEY VERSUS BERKELEY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. YOU WOULD
THINK OUT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THAT'S THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
CHEAP CHEAPER OPTION BECAUSE-
ONE HOUR THREE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE OF BACK THEN WE HAD
THAT. THE BOG WAIVERS. BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE FINANCIAL AID
THAT CAL GRANT RECEIPT GETS.
FROM THE STATE PLUS PELL PLUS
INSTITUTIONAL AID- IT'S WAY
BETTER OFF TO GO TO UC BERKELEY
THAT IS FOR GOING TO COMMIT
BECAUSE WAY MORE FINANCIAL AID
AND SO. AND THE INCOME OF THAT
STUDENT IS TEN TIMES GREATER
SOMETIMES IN THE KID IN THE-
COMMUNIQU ALSO AND SO I THINK
THAT THAT'S- WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS IS THAT- NOT. NON
TUITION AND NON HOUSING COSTS
IT IS REALLY THE HOUSING COSTS.
OF YOUR FULL TIME STUDENT
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE WE WANT TO. HELP YOU
SUCCEED AND GET YOUR DEGREE AND
TRANSFER AND MOVE ON SO. SO
THAT THE NOTION OF THIS AND
THAT'S WHY IT IS WAY MORE MONEY
FOR THAT COHORT BECAUSE- THERE
ARE WAY MORE STUDENTS AND
THAT'S- THAT'S THAT'S THE
POPULATION HAS THE HAS THE
GREATEST NEED SO. YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
AT BOTH AT BOTH- SEGMENTS AND
IT'S WE HAVE A- KEEP A COLISEUM
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS TWO YEARS
AND FOUR YEARS AND THAT'S PART
OF IT SO. I THINK THAT THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S THE NOTION OF
WHAT- WORK WE'RE LOOKING TO DO
IS- THE MOST IMPORTANTLY JUST
MAKE IT EASIER. WE HAVE THE CAL
GRANT AA THE V. IN THE SEA AND
THEN ALL THESE OTHER PIECES
JUST LIKE ONE WITH THIS ONE
SIMPLE APPLICATION TO PASS A-
YEAR AGO TWO YEARS AGO TO FOR
YEARS AND SO- I THINK THAT
SOMETHING THAT THAT- THAT WE-
MAKING PROGRESS WITH BUT YOU
KNOW NOT NOT DONE JUST YET SO.
I KNOW EACH OF US HAVE TO GET
TO OUR RESPECTIVE CAUCUSES IN
ABOUT TEN MINUTES SO- LET'S
LET'S I DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON THIS ISSUE. WE'LL
KEEP WORKING ON THIS THERE ARE
BILLS IN THE POLICY PIPELINE AS
WELL WE WILL NOW GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IF ANYBODY IS HERE. ARE
YOU HERE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT NOW
NOW OKAY NOBODY IN THE AUDIENCE
HERE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT WE DO
HAVE. THE TOLL FREE NUMBER YOU
CAN CALL AND IT'S I THINK IT'S
UP ON THE SCREEN. BE WATCHING
FROM HOME- IT'S EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. MODERATE DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY QUEUED UP TO US
SPEAKING PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE AND THE OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU YOUR LINE
NUMBER WHEN YOU'RE LINE NUMBERS
CALLED PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION FOR THE RECORD.
OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM
MINE NINETEEN MY NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS A MUCH MORE THEIR
RIO WAY THAT YOUNG INVINCIBLES.
AND I WANTED TO. SORRY ONE
MOMENT YES PLEASE PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR WE CAN HEAR
YOU CAN YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE BY
THE WAY. SEVENTEEN YEAH GO
AHEAD. WE LOST YOU WILL COME
BACK TO YOU MODERATOR NEXT
BAKER PLEASE. NINE FORTY ONE
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SO MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA TORY. AND I
AM CURRENTLY A STUDENT AT
BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE I SPENT MY
CHILDHOOD IN AND OUT OF THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AND DON'T
HAVE THE SAME. THE FAMILY
SUPPORT THAT MANY OTHER
STUDENTS OUT. WELL BACK ON OPEN
CHALLENGES ARE. I STRONGLY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OFFER
AGAINST COOK FUNDING FOR. IN MY
COMING CALL I HAD REPUBLICAN
HAVING ENOUGH MONEY FOR. THE
DECORATIVE PAINTER IN
MEDICATION FOR MANY INCLUDING
END. PARTIALLY EXPERIENCING
PARK FAR BEYOND THOSE OF OTHERS.
EXPLODED TRAUMA THE IN. MOVING
AROUND TOO MUCH COULD NOT HAVE
A FAMILY TO FALL BACK ON YOUR
HELLO THERE DOUBLE WHAT LIKE
HAVE YOU. PLEASE SUPPORT
STUDENTS LIKE ME BUT PROVIDE
FEEDBACK. THANK YOU. MY TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS TERRY
ROZIER I'M WITH JOHN BYRNE
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH I'M ALSO
HERE TO A FOR THE GUY FOR TO
PROVIDE TO MILLION FOR
AUGMENTED CAL GRANT AWARD TO
FORM FOSTER YOUTH. JOSH YOUTH
COLLEGE CAN LIKE SICK BEHIND
THAT OF THEIR PEERS IF THAT OF
OTHER LOW INCOME STUDENTS MORE
GENERALLY ONE STUDY TO FOR
UNIVERSITY FOUND THAT 40% OF
FOSTER GRADUATED COMPARED 274%
OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS. A
RECENT ANALYSIS HOWEVER FOUND
AT FAULT SHE RECEIVED AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN AID WERE THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO PERSIST FOX YOU
DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO FAMILY
SUPPORT THAT MANY OTHER
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO. STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS REMOVED THESE
CHILDREN FROM THEIR HOME DUE TO
SEVERE ABUSE AND NEGLECT TAKING
ON THE ROLE OF PARENTS IN SUCH
AND SUCH AS THE UNIQUE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ALL THE
THINGS REASONS WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDE. THESE
FUNDS IN THE STATE BUDGET THANK
YOU. NINE FIFTY YEAR IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHEN REGARDING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MANY OF UP TO GET ON
BEHALF EDUCATION TRUST WEST.
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE TOO
EARLY AFTER A COUPLE OF YEARS
YOU DISCUSSED EARLIER TODAY
THOSE ARE TO RESTORE CALDERON
ELIGIBILITY TO STUDENTS-
POUTING WITH IMPACTED BY
COLGATE AND EIGHTY TWO
EXTENSION FOR NONPROFIT
COLLEGES- SO THAT LOW INCOME
STUDENTS TO KEEP THEIR WARDS
DURING COMBAT KOBE IMPACTED
TURNS. OUT WE STAND WITH THE
GROWING COALITION OF FORTY
EIGHT ENTITIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL TO
ENSURE ELEAZAR OTHER TWELFTH
GRADE PLEASE COMPLETE THE
FASTER CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT YOU
CAN GET PREVIEW CHANNEL CARDS
COMMENTS AT THE OPENING OF THIS
HEARING CALLING THIS VERY
PROMISING OPTIMISTIC- LASTLY-
WE SUPPORT THE INCREASING
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT UNDER OUR
CURRENT FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM.
WE ALSO NEED TO KEEP OUR EYE ON
THE LONG GAME WITH THE NEED TO
MODERNIZE OUR CAL GRANT SYSTEM
TO ENSURE GREATER EQUITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY WE LOOK FORWRD
TO ENGAGE WITH THE EFFORTS
BEING LED BY A FEDERAL MEDINA
AND TRIM. THE CAR THE ON THIS
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO. THANK YOU
MR CARE NUMBERS THIS IS I MEAN
YOU CAN'T GIVE THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
I'M ADDRESSING NUMBER SEVEN ON
YOUR AGENDA REGARDING CALPERS
ACCESS FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS WE
APPRECIATE YOU SHARING THIS
ISSUE TODAY. WE SUPPORT HAVE
ADVOCATED FOR ELIMINATION OF
THE FEDERAL SPECIAL STUDENT
ROLES AND WE SHARE THE
FRUSTRATION NOTICE YOUR ABOUT
GETTING BOTH COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND K. TWELVE STUDENTS IN OUR
PROGRAM IN GREATER NUMBERS. THE
DATA PRIVACY LIMITATIONS NOTED
BY THE PARK SPEAKERS ARE VERY
REAL WE COSPONSORED LEGISLATION
CARRIED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH
TO TRY TO GET THIS ISSUE PER K.
TWELVE STUDENT IN ADDITION TO
PARTICIPATING IN THE FEEDSTOCK
WORKGROUP AT THE MENTION. THE
RULE CHANGES BEING IMPLEMENTED
NOW ARE CERTAINLY A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AS WE NOTED IN
THE AS NOTED IN THE HEARING
AGENDA COUNTY WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO ABSORB THE INFLUX OF
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF NEW
RECIPIENTS WITHIN OUR EXISTING
STATE FUNDING. WE THINK STEEP
INCREASES IN PROGRAM DEMAND
OVERALL DURING THE PANDEMIC
ALREADY AND THIS WOULD BE
ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT JUMPING
CASELOADS CERTAINLY A WELCOME
ONE BUT A LARGE ONE AND ONE
THAT WE WOULD NEED ADDITIONAL
ONE TIME FUNDING IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO PROPERLY SIR. WE'LL BE
PUTTING FORTH REQUEST FOR ONE
TIME FUNDING IN THE CURRENT
YEAR BUT YEAR TO COVER THE FEW
CASES WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TO REFINE OUR ESTIMATES I WILL
BE CIRCLING BACK YOU'RE SUCH AN
IDIOT IN AFFORDABLE TO PROVIDE
A DETAILED ESTIMATE MEET. THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERATION AND WE'RE
VERY EXCITED TO PROVIDE YOU. TO
DETACH BENEFITS TO THE STUDENTS.
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY- INSERT
LINE FOR FIVE PER LINE IS A-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING-
JOSH WHAT ON BEHALF OF THE CAMP
FOR CALL OPPORTUNITY. WE ARE
GRATEFUL THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL PROVIDES CRITICAL
INVESTMENT EMERGENCY EIGHT
INCREASING COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT AWARDS IN THE ARTS THE
LEGISLATURE TO BUILD ON THIS BY
ENSURING EQUITY AT THE CENTER
OF OUR FINANCIAL AID. POLICY
THIS YEAR TO LAY THE FOUNDATION
FOR THE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN HAD
SPECIFICALLY URGED TO PARK THE
PROPOSED INCREASED COMPETITIVE
CALTRAIN AWARDS A MERGING G.
EIGHT FUNDING FOR STUDENTS AND
WITH THE FACT CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION PROPOSAL. WE
APPRECIATE THE INTENSITY WITH
WHICH THE NEW SPECTACLE POSTAL
ADDRESSES THE REALITY THAT THE
COKE AT NINETEEN. INCLUDING THE
NEED FOR A COST NEUTRAL
APPROACH THAT HELPING REPORTER
BUT WITH INCOMES STUDENTS. THE
PROPOSAL REFLECTS THE
ADAPTABILITY REQUIRED TO
DEVELOP AN EQUITY FOCUSED PLAN
TO REDEFINE THE CAL GRANT
DELIVERY SYSTEM WHICH AND
RECOGNIZES THE FISCAL
CONSTRAINTS ON STATE REVENUE
THAT ARE PROJECTED TO
MATERIALIZE OVER THE COMING
YEARS. THE CAMPAIGN OPTIMISTIC
THAT THE PROPOSAL FOR THE CAL
GRANT MODIFICATION TO THE
MEANINGFUL. STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING A STRONG STUDENT
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT PLACES
STUDENTS WITH THE GREATEST.
NEED A CORPORATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS ARE NOT ABOUT THE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION HERE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE CAL
GROUNDWORK. THIS INCREASE IS
CRUCIAL AND WILL WITH THE
THOUSANDS OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND ADULT LEARNERS IN
RESPONSE TO THE UPDATED CAL
GRANT DETECTABLE THE WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF REMOVING
BARRIERS TO LEGIBILITY LIKE THE
AGE REQUIREMENT HI MY TO HIGH
SCHOOL. AND GPA VERIFICATION
THESE CHANGES MOVE US AWAY FROM
PENALIZING ADULT LEARNERS AND
LIKELY TO BE BENEFICIAL TO
STUDENTS PURSUING TECHNICAL
SKILL AND OPPORTUNITY FOR
REEMPLOYMENT HOWEVER WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE LACK OF
THE FUNDING WE UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT YOUR REALITY ALSO BELIEVE
NINETY FUND IS A CHOICE
ESPECIALLY DUE TO THE LEFT AND
DRAMATIC HIT. TO THE STATE
BUDGET THAT WE HAD EXPECTED WE
RECOMMEND BUILDING AND
PROTECTION SO THAT ALREADY
INADEQUATE AMOUNT GOING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
NOT REDUCE FURTHER AND TO SEE
SOME ASSURANCES THAT THE ACT OF
THE WORK INCREASES OVER TIME.
OVERALL VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
ATTENTION ON THIS ISSUE AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK OF THE
STATE THAT GETTING US THIS FAR
THANK YOU. SO MUCH I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ALL.
THE YOU CONNECT MY TO. YEAR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HE HONORABLY AND I AND THE
GUARDIAN RETENTION AT CAL
MONTEREY BAY I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE-CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
THE SUPPLEMENTAL CAL GRANT
AWARD. EVERY DAY I WORK WITH
CURRENT OR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
OVERCOME EXPOSURE TO TRAUMA
LACK OF FAMILY SUPPORT AND
HOUSING INSTABILITY NONETHELESS
THEY HAVE PERSEVERED IN PLACE
TO GET THEIR KIDS GREEN AND
MAKE A BETTER LIFE FOR
THEMSELVES. AS A RESULT OF
COLBERT MANY GUARDIAN SCHOLARS
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED FINANCIALLY
AND ARE STRUGGLING TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS TO FOCUS ON
THEIR EDUCATION THEREFORE
DISPONIBLE POPULATION NEEDS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO THRIVE
AND NOT JUST SURVIVE WONDERING
WHERE THEIR NEXT MEAL. WILL
COME FROM THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. NINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME WITH MY LOOK MODERN
BACK HAPPENED YOU KNOW I COULD
NOT MY ON THE PROPOSAL TO LOOK
LOCAL. AGENCIES COME THAT ALL
HIGH A COMPLETE UP TO FOR
FEDERAL COULD EIGHT OTHER
DEMOCRAT. I'VE BEEN ABOUT THE
BEEN IN MY FAULT THAT WOULD BE
GREAT FROM OTHER THE COMMITTEE.
I CAN'T THAT THE PASSENGER
FOURTH GREATLY MY ABILITY TO
PURSUE HIGH- I COME A LOW
INCOME WHO WERE THE HELP TO
MAXIMIZE EDUCATION ACT TO HELP.
AND EVERYTHING MY HAVE PUT UP
BUT IF COULD TO KNOW HOWEVER IS
GOING TO WANT ABOUT THE THAT
CURRICULA DOCKING. WITHOUT OF
BLOOD WITH THE I'M GOING ON
STREAM FINGERS OPENED UP A
HEALTH DEMOCRAT REGION I GOT
HELP FROM AND HE CLOUT THE
PROBLEM IS THAT A WAS NOT FAULT
THAT TO MY- ON THE BECAUSE THE
AVAILABLE. IF YOU ARE IN FAVOR
THE RESPONSE OF MY COUNTY
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL. PERSONNEL
TO DO SO WELCOME TO HAVE A
HANDFUL OF INITIATIVES THAT TO
A THE FUTURE ABOUT TO COMPLETE
ONE. NO THE MOTHER CALLED E. L.
A. SHARE THE FIFTEEN YEARS OUR
COMPLETING AND SUBMITTING THE
PROPER ON YOUR BACK UP HE
CHECKS IT SHOULD BE THE
LIVESTOCK. BECAUSE.
TO ADOPT A
POLICY THAT WILL MAKE HIGHER
EDUCATION MORE AFFORDABLE AND
PROCESS CREATION. BUT MUCH
NEEDED COLLEGE GOING CULTURE
AGAIN CALIFORNIA. ARTIST NOT
LACTIC ECONOMIC ABILITY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN COLLEGE BUT
RATHER FIND DIFFICULTIES IN
APPOINTING COLLEGE. AND
CONNECTION PUTS PROVIDING
GUIDANCE TO ALL STUDENTS
PROPERLY COMPLETING THE
PROSPECT CALIFORNIA CONNECT
APPLICATION CAN GO A LONG WAY
IN THE CLEANING EDUCATION
EQUITY. THIS REQUIREMENT WOULD
REQUIRE THE MOST MARGINALIZED.
AND UNDERSERVED. IN BEING ABLE
TO AFFORD TO GO TO A POOR POST
SECONDARY INSTITUTION. THE LACK
OF KNOWLEDGE AND GUIDANCE IN
APPLYING FOR FINANCIAL AID HAS
RESULTED IN THE MORE HALF A
MILLION STUDENTS BEING EXCLUDED
FROM FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
COLLEGE. IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
OF THE MONSTER POP ME FIFTY
FIVE MILLION. IN EIGHTEEN
ELEVEN PEOPLE EVERY YEAR. WITH
THE KNOWLEDGE OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION IS THE BIGGEST THE
COLLECTOR PRODUCTION ABILITY IT
IS SHAME BAPPA BILLION DOLLARS
GOING TO WASTE. BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT. POOR ENOUGH FILLING OUT A
FORM. MY PARENTS WANT THE BEST
OF US YEAH EDUCATION IN THE
BEAR THAT PREVENTS THEM FROM
NOW GETTING THE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM AND THE RESOURCES NEEDED
FOR YOU. AS A PERSON- HE
STUDENTS PARENTS COME FROM
IMMIGRANTBACKGROUNDS THAT HAVE
LITTLE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT HOW
EXPERIENCE APPLYING FOR
FINANCIAL AID IS COMPLICATED
EVEN APPEARED INTO MY UNDERGRAD
CAREER. I FOUND MYSELF AND ELP
COUNTERTOP RETURNED OR THE
AMOUNT OF STRENGTH TO RECEIVE
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATION-
EIGHT. SIX PARENTS TO COME.
THAT EQUITIES PRINCE PRINCE.
PART OF SCHOOL YOU DON'T
INCREASE DIGITAL BEARS MAKING
EVEN MORE. TO POST. UP FOR THAT
REASON I AM HERE ARJUN YOU ALL
OF- ABOUT POLICY. THAT REFLECTS
AND- US. ARE YOU FOR. PROVIDE
EDUCATION EQUITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN CHRIS AHEAD. BUT ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NINE SIXTEEN.
YOUR LINE IS REOPENED PLEASE GO
AHEAD- THANK YOU MY NAME IS A
DISCOUNTED JENNINGS PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO URBAN LEAGUE I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL REQUIRES
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES TO
CONFIRM THAT ALL HIGH SCHOOL
SEVEN YEARS TO COMPLETE THE
FABRICA. AND THE- GSU
ELIMINATION IS HELP AFRICAN
AMERICANS MINORITIES AND PEOPLE
IN UNDER RESULT COMMUNITIES TO
ACHIEVE ECONOMIC SELF RELIANCE
EDUCATION IS AT THE TOP OF THE
AGENDA IT IS ABILITY TO A
BETTER LIFE UNFORTUNATELY
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY IS. A
SIGNIFICANT BAY AREA FACED MANY
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND
MINORITIES AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS THEY ARE LEFT BEHIND
AND SOMETIMES LEFT OUT WHEN IT
COMES TO INFORMATION ACCESS AND
COMPLETION. OF FINANCIAL AID
EVEN IN CONSIDERING ATTENDING
COLLEGE MUCH LESS ATTENDEE.
TOLD ME IT HAS FURTHER
DISRUPTED APPLICATION RATE THE
MONEY IS THERE LET'S NOT LEAVE
ANYTHING ON THE TABLE LEFT
REQUIRE ALL SENIOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND PROVIDE THEM THE
NECESSARY ASSISTANCE TO
COMPLETE THE PATH AND THE KEY
TO. FILL THAT OUT RECOVERY IS
REAL BUT THE PLANE INTENTIONAL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. NINE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE CALL. HELLO SIMILAR. MY
NAME IS NANCY EDWARDS AND I
WORK FOR YOU COLLEGE AN ORACLE
CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD BE AN
ACADEMIC SUPPORT PROGRAM FOR
CURRENT AND FORMER BOSS YOU. I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING TO
PROVIDE FORMER BOSS USED A
SUPPLEMENTAL CAL GRANT. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE STATE'S
GROWING RECOGNITION OF THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF COST YEAR AND
THEIR DISPROPORTIONATE WELCOME
TO COLLEGE. THE TRUTH IS BY
REMOVING FOUGHT TO GET FROM
THEIR FAMILIES OF ORIGIN AND
CHILDREN. BOCKIUS BECOME THE
STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY BUT TO
MEET THAT RESPONSIBILITY AND
HELP THEM CHANGE THEIR FAMILY'S
HISTORY BY SUPPORTING THEIR
COLLEGE DEGREE. ATTAINMENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NINE FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JAMIE NEAL
I'M A JUNIOR AT YES HE WENT B.
I'M A FORMER BOXER YOU AND I'M
ALSO A PROJECT AND THE GUARDIAN
SCHOLARS PROGRAM. I WOULD LIKE
YOU EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH THE SUPPLEMENTAL
CAL GRANT WARD. MANY CURRENT
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WITH
HOUSING AND FINANCIAL AND
SECURITY FOR MOST OF THEIR
LIVES ESPECIALLY NOW DURING THE
PANDEMIC THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
OPTION TO MOVE BACK IN WITH
THEIR FAMILIES TO OFFSET THE
COST. OF PROVIDING MORE AID TO
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
IN COLLEGE WOULD PROVIDE
FINANCIAL STABILITY AND WHAT
EIGHT IN OUR SUCCESSFUL IN
COLLEGE THANK. YOU THANK YOU.
MIND COULD NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS CHIU CAN
VERY THE PRO CALL FOR YOU SEE
BUT CURRENT AND FORMER BUDGET
PROGRAM THE BOOKLET CALLER. I
GREATLY SUPPORT THE FUNDING THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET TO PROVIDE
CURRENTLY FORMER. WITH OKAY
AWARDS MANY CURRENT AND FORMER
FOX YOUTH EXPERIENCE HOW IS THE
KEY. EXPOSURE TO TRAUMA AND
HELP WALK FAMILY SUPPORT AND
MENTORSHIP MANY FOSTER YOUTH
CHU PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS BECAUSE
OF THE ADDED CAMPUS SUPPORT
PROGRAMMING THAT SERVES THE
COFFEE COMMUNITY. AND THE
CHALLENGES THEY FACE. THE GRANT
A FIFTY FIVE FORTY THEM. AND ON
IN HOUSING AS WELL THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE WALKED
QUALITY MEDICAL POINT BUT-
SERVICES NOT. HIGH THIS GRANT
SUPPORTS MORE EQUITABLE
APPROACH SERVING CURRENT FORMER
FOX IN HIGHER EDUCATION. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
MY THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
ROCHELLE I AM WITH THE DRY
BURTON FOR YOUTH PERSONALLY
WITH THE DRUG TO THE FAR CARE
SO AND I AM NOT TURN UNIVERSE.
I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE FUNDING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
CURRENT FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WITH SUPPLEMENTAL CALDERON
WORDS. I TRAVELED FOSTER CARE
HAD UNDER UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT NO CHILD SHOULD HAVE TO
EXPERIENCE I COULD UNDOUBTEDLY
SEE HOW FUNDING WOULD HAVE COME
TO COLLEGE. AND I KNOW EXACTLY
THAT IT WOULD HAVE IMPLEMENTED
IT NOT HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
POTENTIAL BONELESS SKINLESS
BASIC NECESSITIES OR HAVING TO
EXPERIENCE COULDN'T SECURITY.
WITHIN PACKED IN MY COLLEGE
EDUCATION DRAMATICALLY MANY
COLLEGES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
PROGRAMS AVAILABLE FOR FOSTER
YOUTH ARE WILLING TO HELP
SUPPORT WOULD NOT BE GETTIN
FINANCED WITH ANOTHER RESOURCES
THAT ARE MADE AVAILABLE
ADVOCATE WHO GROWS UP WITHOUT
HAVING YOUR BASIC NEEDS NOT
YOU'RE NOT WANT TO SPEND MONEY
ON THINGS THAT ARE OF NO USE
FOR OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
NECESSITIES. SUCH AS FOOD
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION AND
OTHER BASIC RESOURCES BECAUSE
YOU COULD NOT ASK FOR THE LAST
THIRTY GIVEN THE LEASTWE CAN
DO TO GIVE THE KIDS A FIGHTING
CHANCE SHOW THM SUPPORT AND
LET THEM KNOW. THAT SOMEONE
BELIEVED IN THEM THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR. YOUR LINE OPEN GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON RICHARD
MEMBERS MONEY IS EVA INTO.
FORMER NEW AN ADVOCATE FOR
GRANDPARENTS ADVOCATES FOR YOU
A MOTHER AND A STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO STATE. I HERE TO
SUPPORT OF THE BUT J. PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE. FOR THE CURRENT AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO NINE THE FIRST HAND
BECAUSE I WAS HOME BUT MY FIRST
SEMESTER AND I WAS ALSO
SPEAKING MY BASICALLY THIS WAS
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
EIGHT THEY CAN HELP OUR BASIC
NEEDS WITH TRANSPORTATION FOOD
BILLS HOUSING. BILLS
IMPORTANTLY I REALLY WANT
EVERYONE TO BE ABLE TO GO AND.
BE ABLE TO JUST GO TO SCHOOL.
WELL. GO AHEAD THANK YOU
CONTINUE. NINE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ROLAND THE BILL
I'M WITH- CREAM ACTIVE COLLEGE
NEXT THE PROGRAM I LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPLEMENTAL CAL
GRANT AWARD FOR PROSECUTE. I
BELIEVE THE OUTBOX YOU NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT BECAUSE THEY
EXPERIENCED. TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES THAT PUT AMENDED
DISADVANTAGE COMPARED TO THEIR
PEERS LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY IN REGARDS TO BASIC
NEEDS ENOUGH SOME OF THE THINGS
WE TAKE MOST FOR GRANTED ARE
SOME OF THE THINGS THEY NEED.
TO SURVIVE LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
LIKE WHEN THEY ATTEND COLLEGE
THEN THEY MOVE ON TO THEIR OWN
THEY NEED A LOT OF BEING SUCH
AS A SHOWER CURTAIN IN THE
SHOWER- DISH SOAP. POTS PANS.
CUTS THE LIST GOES ON OF THE
PAGE FEDERAL. AND SO I THE-
FUNDING WILL DEFINITELY HOW
THEM NOT TO THINK ABOUT THAT
WERE HAVE TO. IN ORDER TO PUT
THEMSELVES THROUGH AND THEIR
EDUCATION. BUT I BELIEVE IT'S
VERY VITAL FOR US TO PROVIDE.
SOME ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SO THEY
CAN. SOLELY FOCUSED ON. GETTING
THEIR EDUCATION AND BEATING THE
ODDS THANK YOU. NINE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO HOPE YOU ARE ALL
DOING WELL MY NAMEIS AN ACRE
THE ORTEGA AND I AM A FULL TIME
STUDENT CURRENTLY ATTENDING
UNIVERSITY OVERSIGHT I AM
ADDRESSING SUPPORT FOR
INCREASING THE CAL GRANT
IDENTIFIED THE STUDENT PARENT
AS WELL AS A FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENT AND A GUARDIAN
SCHOLAR AT UT ARE. EXPANDING
THE PROGRAM WOULD BE OF GREAT
BENEFIT TO MYSELF AND MANY OF
MY PEERS WHO ARE INDEPENDENT
AND DO NOT HAVE FAMILY
FINANCIAL SUPPORT. ESPECIALLY
DURING THESE UNCERTAIN TIMES
I'VE HAD PEOPLE GET ON MY SON'S
EDUCATION CARING FOR HIM AT
HOME BUT TRYING TO BE A FULL
TIME STUDENT AND BE INVOLVED IN
MY COMMUNITY AT UNIVERSITY OF
AFFECT. THE ROLE THAT I HAVE
HAD TO TAKE UPON MYSELF FACT
GREATER FINANCIAL DIFFICULTY I
NOW MUST PRIORITIZE WHAT IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT TO ME. AND LIKE
IT WAS STATED BEFORE MANY
STUDENTS ARE DROPPING OUT
CURRENTLY BECAUSE OF THE
FINANCIAL. CRISIS THAT THEY'RE
FACING. I MANY INDEPENDENT
STUDENTS ARE. FACING THIS. PAY
WE FACE DIFFICULT ON BUT BASIC
NEEDS OR ADDITION APPETITE.
CENTERS WE COVER. MY EDUCATION
SUCCESS IS CURRENT BEING IF I
BY AND INTRODUCE A- AND SO ARE
MANY. MANY INDEPENDENT STUDENTS
MUST COVER. MEANT LAST OVERCOME
MANY ADVERSITIES THAT NOT
INDEPENDENT DETAIL NOT MY GOAL
IS TO CAN CONTINUE MY HIGHER
EDUCATION. I AS I HAVE
TRANSFERRED FROM A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND NOT AND CONTINUE MY
EDUCATION. YOUR THIS FUNDING
CAN POSITIVELY IMPACT CAN GIVE
MANY MINORITY STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO CONTINUE THEIR
HIGHER EDUCATION EMPLOYEE
INSTITUTION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS DON CURRENY AND I WORK WITH
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AT CHICO
STATE I'VE BEEN A SOCIAL WORKER
FOR OVER TWELVE YEARS AND SPENT
A DECADE IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SPENDING WHAT WORKING WITH
TRANSITION EACH YEAR. WHEN KIDS
GROW UP IN FOSTER CARE TO BE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES THAT CAN HAVE
A LASTING IMPACT AS THEY HEAD
INTO COLLEGE MANY HAVE HAD
PLACEMENT MALES SOMETIMES UP TO
TWENTY HOMES MULLIN FOSTER CARE
IN OUR FORMATIVE YEARS. WHILE
THE STUDENTS ARE LIKELY TO FACE
HOUSING INSECURITY AND FOOD
INSECURITY THEY ALSO DO NOT
HAVE THE THINKING THAT THE
OTHER STUDENTS HAVE. AND ARE
MORE LIKELY TO BECOME HOMELESS
OR DROP OUT OF SCHOOL BUT
PROPER PLANNING DEPARTMENT
POPULATION OF STUDENTS CAN
BREAK THAT CYCLE OF ABUSE AND
MOVE TOWARD A BETTER FUTURE
PLEASE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH. WITH SUPPLEMENTAL
CAL GRANT AWARDS. THERE WILL BE
MONEY WELL SPENT THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY SUBCOMMITTEE TOO MANY
MANY FIFTY FIFTEEN OH FIVE I AM
A JUNIOR FIRST GENERATION
STUDENT AT THE A FEW CHANNEL
ISLANDS AND I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
MY SUPPORT FOR THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL REQUIRED EACH
REQUIRING LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY TO CONFIRM. TO MAKE SURE
BACKING YOUR COMPLETE ACOSTA OR
CALIFORNIANS REMATCH APART FROM
BEING A STUDENT- IN THE CSU I
AM ALSO AN ASSISTANT AT A DREAM
RESEARCH CENTER AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE I
AM ALSO WORKING WITH INCOMING
STUDENTS I HAVE NOTICED THAT I
HAVEN'T PERSONALLY NOTICED THE
IMPACT. OF THEM NOT HAVING THE
PROPER RESOURCES TO FILLING OUT
THE CALIFORNIA- DREAM ACT OR
THE FACT THAT DUE TO NOT BEING
AWARE OF WHEN THE DEADLINE
DEADLINE WATCH PRETTY
COMPLICATIONS ALL STUDENTS ARE
WERE UNAWARE OF THE DEADLINE
FOR THESE APPLICATIONS KIDS
FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
ARE FIRST GENERATION. COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY IS A SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER FACING LOCAL INCOMES
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA AS A
PUSH DOOR CONSIDER PURSUING
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION I
WOULD PUT IT MYSELF I HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM GETTING HANDS
ON ASSISTANCE AND RESOURCES
GOING TO PINE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT FOR THE
FIRST TIME AT THE HIGH SCHOOL
SENIOR. I KNOW THE IMPORTANCE
OF GETTING THE RIGHT HELP AND
RESOURCES IN ORDER TO FOR ALL
STUDENTS IF IT WASN'T FOR IT
BACK HELP I WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO YOU KNOW ARAMBULA TO
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT ON TIME
AND BE SUCCESSFUL IN MY
TRANSITION TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. TO THE COST OF ME
BEING A LOW INCOME STUDENTS AS
I WAS OPERATED BY A SINGLE.
MOTHER THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO. HELLO MY NAME IS CAN
WE MEN ON THE JUR OF THE
OFFICE OF POLICY COULD SERVICE.
YOU CAN REVERSE WERE AMONG
APPEAR TO BE CANDIDATE AND ALSO
IF FOX YOUTH I IN FAVOR OF THE
PROPOSAL A- FOSTER YOUTH IN
ADDITIONAL TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
GETTING FINANCIAL AID ANNUALLY
EVEN PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCES I CAN TELL YOU
FIRSTHAND FOSTER USED TO
DISPLAY UNIQUE NEEDS THAT
CURRENT. FINANCIALLY FUNDING
SIMPLY DOES NOT ADDRESS I
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL AND
SUPPORT FOSTER YOUTH WHICH IS A
VERY GLOBAL POPULATION AND IN
HIGHER EDUCATION. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NINE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING CARE MCCARTY
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY SUBMIT
A COMPLETE THAT COMMITTEE TOO
MY NAME IS TYLER WILL ACT
SERVICE CALIFORNIA POLICY
DIRECTOR ON BEHALF USE FIRE. OF
THE NATIONAL NONPROFIT FOCUSED
ON COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY WE
ADVISE OVER TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS ANNUALLY TO ACCESS
FINANCIAL AID AND MANAGE
COLLEGE COSTS. BECAUSE OF THIS
WE KNOW THAT STUDENTS EXPERTISE
MONTHS DRIVE POP IN FIFTEEN
CHANGES THAT IS WHY YOU FIRED
SUPPORTING EFFORTS TO INCREASE
CAL GRANT AWARDS INCLUDING A
GROWTH INDEX FOR CAL GRANT
WORKED AS A PART OF CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION. AND THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO REQUIRE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY TO CONFIRM
THAT ALL HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
COMPLETE. ORTEGA IT SHOULD BE
DENIED THE- TO PER A PO SECOND
AT. BECAUSE THEY WERE NEVER
PAID OR OF THE FINANCIAL AID
OPTIONS. THIS PROPOSAL WILL
INCREASE LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ACCESS TO THE IN DEPTH REPORT
NEEDED TO COMPLETE THE FORM.
THE STATE HAS MADE STRIDES IN
REPAIRING STUDENTS TO GO TO
COLLEGE BUT NOW WE MUST DOUBLE
DOWN ON PREPARING THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THE COST THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALSO
HELLO MY NAME HAVE YET OUT OF
THE LAW I AM THE COORDINATOR
FOR THE FOSTER YOUTH IN A
DISCONNECTED YOUTH PROGRAM AT
UC SAN DIEGO WERE HOPES DOLLARS
NONE HERE SUPPORT B. THE BILL
TO INCREASE FUNDING FOR BOSTON.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW INCREDIBLY
RESILIENT YOU STUDENTS ARE. AND
IT SHOULD NOT HAVE SUPPORT. FOR
BASICALLY JUST NOT HAPPENING.
THROUGHOUT THEIR TIME IN HIGHER
EDUCATION IS INCREDIBLY.
DETRIMENTAL TO THEM AND THEY
CAN FAILED IN THE SYSTEM HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE DON'T WANT
GOVERNMENT HIGHER EDUCATION
WELL HELLO. I'M HERE TO ASK FOR
THEM STUDENTS THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ARIEL I AM CURRENTLY A
SENIOR AT EVERY FISCAL STATE
UNIVERSITY I AM A PART OF THE
GUARDIAN SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM
ALSO I'M CALLING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL- TO OUR INCREASE OF
SUPPLEMENTAL- CAL GRANT FOR
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. I THANK FORMER PARKING
IN THE STUDENT ATHLETES
AND TO AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE I
DO NOT THINK I'M A COLLEGE
STUDENT BUT I HAVE TO DECIDE
BETWEEN WARREN. OR TAKING
CLASSES I ALSO KNOW THAT THIS
MONEY IS IN INVESTMENT BY THING
BUT IT'S NOT BACK YET WELL
SPENT BECAUSE MORE THAN ONE OUT
OF FIVE BOND STREET AND UP IN
THE PRISON SYSTEM AND OUR STATE
SO I FEEL LIKE INVESTING NOW
WILL SAVE US A MILLION LATER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. NINE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS A PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON LAURA
BARBECUE THAT BUT THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
AT HIGHER EDUCATION RESEARCH
AND POLICY ORGANIZATION THAT
LEADS CALIFORNIANS FOR COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY A DIVERSE
COALITION UNITED AND
STRENGTHENING STATE NEED BASED
FINANCIAL AID. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT OF COMMENTS ABOUT
IT URGE YOUR ON GOING SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT THE FIFTY
THOUSAND. THANKS YOUR PREVIOUS
INVESTMENTS OLDER STUDENTS ARE
THE PROCEEDING AND GRANT HAVE
IMPROVED FROM JUST ONE
SEVENTEEN A FEW YEARS AGO TO
ONE EIGHT TODAY HOWEVER AS
DISCUSSED HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF ELIGIBLE STUDENTS WILL GO
WITHOUT THE CAL GRANT THEY NEED
NOW TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND THE
WAR ADDITIONAL AWARDS BUT
INSURANCE DOESN'T MORE HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO THRIVE
TODAY. ADDITIONALLY AS STATED
IN THE AGENDA THERE ARE STEPS
THE STATE CAN TAKE TO ENSURE
ALL THE WORDS ARE PAID OUT AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE ACADEMIC
YEAR WHEN THEY HAVE THE
GREATEST IMPACT ON LOW INCOME
STUDENTS SIX BACK WE ALSO URGE
YOU TO CONSIDER OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES TO INCREASE
STUDENT ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID
FOR TOTAL COLLEGE COSTS
INCLUDING REQUIRING LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES. SUPPORT
HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR COMPLETION
OF FINANCIAL AID APPLICATIONS
STRENGTHENING CAL GRANT FOR
FOSTER YOUTH AND BROADER
FINANCIAL AID REFORMS THAT
ADDRESSES THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES
INCLUDING THE CRITICAL NEED FOR
ACCESS TO WORK FOR NON TUITION
COSTS AT GROWTH MEANINGFULLY
OVERTIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. NINE SIXTY FIVE.
YOUR LINE IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE MOMENT. NINE SIXTY FIVE
NINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
SAMANTHA THANK POLICY ADVISOR
AT NEXT IN CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THE BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
REQUIRE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO CONFIRM THAT ALL
HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS COMPLETE
THE FACT. OR THE KITA
FINANCIALLY THAT'S CRITICAL FOR
STUDENTS WITH RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT EVEN TO COMPLETE THE FACT
THAT ARE MORE LIKELY TO
DIRECTLY ROLE IN COLLEGE 90%
PER STUDENT TO COMPLETE THE
PATH BUT COMPARED TO FIFTY FIVE
WHO DO NOT- IT SHOULD BE DENIED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PURSUE A
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION BECAUSE
THEY WERE NEVER MADE AWARE.
OTHER FINANCIAL OPTIONS AND THE
PROPOSAL WILL INCREASE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS ACCESS TO THE
IN DEPTH SUPPORT NEEDED TO
COMPLETE THE FORM WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE MODERNIZATION OF
CAL GRANT WITH THE EQUITY
FRAMEWORK THAT FEEDBACK
OUTLINED AND THE CONTINUATION
TO ELIMINATE ELIGIBILITY.
TERRIERS THANK YOU. NINE FORTY
SIX SURVIVORS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ERICA
ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES WE
SUPPORT COMPREHENSIVE FINANCIAL
AID REFORM BUT- LACKING THE
COMPLETE ELIMINATION OF A TIME
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL REQUIREMENTS
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO AT
LEAST PROVIDE THE LAST TWO
CLASSES. WITH THE EXTRA TIME TO
ENTER COLLEGE BEFORE THEY LOSE
THEIR ENTITLEMENT CAL GRANT
THIS IS AN EQUITY ISSUE WE KNOW
THAT IN THE LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ARE TAKING TIME AWAY FROM
COLLEGE WE DON'T WANT THEM TO
JUMP INTO THE COMPETITIVE POLL
THEY SHOULD STILL BE. ABLE TO
ACCESS. OUR ENTITLEMENT CAL
GRANT IN ADDITION WE SUPPORT
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT OUR
STUDENTS IN HIGH SCHOOL FILL
OUT THE PROCESS KITA. AS PART
OF THEIR HIGH SCHOOL YEAR WE
THINK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE. OKAY
IT'S EASY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I WITH THAT WE WILL DURING.
FOUR SEVENTY TWO HOURS. YEAH